Musik
Hallo Chat.
Schon jemand am Start.
Ne.
Laut Twitch habe ich einen Zuschauer.
Das ist mein Vorschau-Rechner.
Dann warten wir doch nochmal.
Wie es Twitch das mitgekriegt hat.
Ah ja.
Warte mal, ich muss mal husten.
So.
Exit.
Bei der Gelegenheit, wenn noch keiner da ist,
dann
kann ich doch einfach schon mal
meinen
Linux-Rechner
hochfahren.
Brauchen wir doch eh.
Moin. Ah, jetzt
kommen die Leute.
Schalten wir das Ding mal an.
Leute, ich weiß, ich habe wenig gestreamt in letzter Zeit.
Das liegt nicht daran, dass es mir schlecht ging oder so.
Es geht mir eigentlich aktuell recht gut, ja.
Ich kreise, kreine MMO.
Ja, moin Leute.
TheRackMan ist wieder am Start.
Lange nicht gesehen.
F-Programmer
Müller Joe
Der Umut ist auch mal wieder da
So, mal kurz das Satur umstöpseln
Das habe ich noch nicht automatisiert hier
Könnten wir auch machen
Wir hatten es ja schon mal, dass man per SSH anlocken kann
So, da sind wir.
Zack.
Umschalten.
Exzellent.
Und jetzt erstmal, Leute, ihr wisst ja.
Erstmal Update und dann Reboot.
Guck mal, wir können sogar...
reboot machen.
Und das funktioniert.
Excellent.
So.
Machen wir mal Update.
Oh, guck mal hier.
5,3 Gig
Update.
Ist mir nur aufgefallen,
dass ich lange nicht gesehen habe.
Mach dir keine Gedanken.
Jeder wieder Zeit hat.
Ich bin ja auch nicht der regelmäßige Stream-Sower in letzter Zeit.
Und Chat, mal an die Frage.
Was war down?
Max.de?
Kenn ich nicht.
Frage an euch, die auch beruflich so mit Linux was zu tun haben
Oder reicht ja auch Hobbymäßig
Achso, alle.de, ja das habe ich mitgekriegt
Der Denik hatte Probleme, sie hatten irgendwelche
Geschichten, aber was habe ich gelesen
Sie hatten irgendwie ein automatisches Tool
Was ihre DNS-Zonen überprüft
Das hat auch angeschlagen, aber es hat
Keiner mitgekriegt, dass es angeschlagen hat
Irgendwie sowas, naja
Das habe ich mitbekommen, ich muss aber ehrlich
gestehen ich habe es nicht komplett im detail durchgelesen was denn jetzt genau war nur mit
gekriegt dass die irgendwelche probleme mit ihrer zonen konfiguraten dns technisch das nicht gemerkt
haben weil keiner auf ihr tool was es gemerkt hat reagiert hat so das habe ich mitgekriegt
aber sonst keine ahnung ich muss auch ehrlich sagen mich hat sie sich so großartig interessiert
weil das war irgendwann in der nacht da habe ich gepennt weil sich morgens aufgewacht bin da hat
man nur noch die nachwirkung gelesen und es war schon alles vorbei also insofern
es hat auch auf der arbeit keine sau interessierte es gab wohl es gab es gab
so eine mail von unserem provider diese internet stelle und sowas machen dass
das dass es halt eine störung gab aber es halt nicht in ihrer macht liegt da
was zu machen und ansonsten gab es da ein schnicks was ich jetzt bei euch
irgendwie probleme gemacht was bei uns viel mehr probleme gemacht hat ist copy
fail ja ob die fail und wie hieß das andere ding black frack irgendwas mit
frack
Dirty Frag.
Das hat uns alles viel mehr Probleme gemacht hier.
Copy Fail und Dirty Frag.
Die haben richtig hier die Chance vertan.
Wisst ihr, was die hier hätten für eine Granate nehmen müssen?
Mal gucken, Chad, wer als gleiche denkt wie ich.
Welche Granate hätten die hier nehmen müssen?
die da hätten die nehmen müssen es hat viel besser gepasst
irgendwas mit dns sack das habe ich auch gelesen keine ahnung also bei uns hat es
auch ehrlich gesagt nur Probleme gemacht,
weil wir das so schnell patchen mussten
und Red Hat ewig gebraucht hat,
bis es Patches gab.
Also nicht das hier, sondern das hier.
Hier gibt es mittlerweile, glaube ich,
auch Patches. Da bin ich mir...
Das letzte Mal, wo ich bei Red Hat reingeguckt habe,
war das noch ongoing.
Status ongoing ist immer noch.
Das heißt, es gibt noch keine Patches,
oder? Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Alter, die sind aber
Das kann doch nicht sein. Warum sind die so langsam?
Sind die wirklich so langsam, dass es immer noch keine Patches gibt?
Äh, hier, da. Okay.
Affected. Gut, das wissen wir.
Affected, affected.
Und gibt es Patches?
Nö, oder?
Gibt es schon irgendwas?
Gibt noch keine, oder?
Gibt noch keine.
Das ist halt echt bitter, weil man sich überlegt,
dass das jetzt öffentlich bekannt ist
und gefühlt jeder mit einem Login auf irgendeinem Linux-Server root werden kann
und es tagelang ungepatcht bleibt.
Was ist da los?
Also Alma...
Alma Linux hatte doch schon einen Patch letztens.
Hier, guck.
Hier, Dirty...
Ey, Chat, Chat.
Sehe ich das richtig? Wir haben es zum ersten Mal, soweit ich es mitbekommen habe, dass ein Redhead-Klon, nennen wir es mal, schneller Sachen patcht als Redhead selbst.
anscheinend oder ich habe jetzt bei red hat nichts gesehen
naja rocky linux ist auch schon gepatcht kann durchaus sein einmal linux waren eine der ersten
weil als ich, also ich hab,
ich guck ja immer morgens, ich les ja
morgens immer hier ne Runde aufm Handy.
Noch bevor ich wirklich
aufstehe, guck ich hier immer mal
ein bisschen durch. Und da
ist mir sowohl Dirty Frag
als auch Copy Fail ist mir
quasi morgens um halb acht oder so
ist mir das schon aufgefallen. Ich hab's dann auch gleich
bei uns auf der Arbeit in den Chat gepostet.
Einer meinte
noch, dass es garantiert irgendwie
AI-Slob, die Webseite sieht so fake aus.
Nee, aber das war echt, ja, sowohl Copy-Fail als auch Dirty-Frag.
Ja, das lese ich morgens immer.
Und da habe ich relativ schnell, gleich morgens noch gesehen,
dass Alma Linux schon ein Testing-Patch rausgebracht hat.
Und, also wenn das wirklich so ist, vielleicht bin ich einfach nur zu doof, das zu sehen bei Red Hat, ja.
Aber.
Ja.
Aber Redhead noch nicht.
Übrigens, das kann ich tatsächlich für alle, die beruflich in dem Umfeld unterwegs sind, echt nur empfehlen.
Einfach morgens mal ein bisschen Twitter und Reddit scrollen.
Man kriegt dort in der Regel die Sachen deutlich schneller mit, als das Heise oder irgendjemand
da drüber postet.
Oh Hyperland hat jetzt eine Lua-based-API bzw. eine Lua-based-Config.
Das finde ich ja eigentlich ganz nice.
Mein Terminal hat ja auch eine Lua-based-Config.
Das sieht jetzt hier erstmal nicht so geil aus.
wie eine stinknormale Config, aber
das ist eine vollwertige Programmiersprache
und da kann man zum Beispiel solche Dinge hier machen.
Guck, von 1
bis 99 mittlere
Mausklicks und
rechte Mausklicks macht da was
unterschiedliches.
Ich habe das bei mir zum Beispiel
so programmiert und das geht auch nur, weil das eine Lua-Config
ist. Wenn ich
hier sagen wir mal, ich klicke
das hier doppelt an, dann ist es markiert.
Wenn ich jetzt rechts klicke,
dann geht es in das Clipboard und wenn ich
jetzt noch mal rechtsklicken pace der kuk quasi guckt kann man das kann ich kann
man hier sehen ja der guckt ob das terminal selection hat wenn es ein
selection hat dann kopiert er die selection in das clipboard und anzelegte
das und wenn es keine selections hat dann paste das heißt ich kann quasi je
nachdem was was für ein statement terminal hat mit der rechten maustaste
sowohl copy als auch pasten was ich mega praktisch finde und deswegen bin ich ein großer fan von lua
based oder generell so programmier sprachen based configs das mega nice und ich denke mal das ist
auf hyperlens auch mega nice zu sagen auch kein patch geile ja da fragt man sich doch wenn alba
linux und rocky wahrscheinlich wenn der programmer das sagt dann wird es wohl so sein wenn die schon
Patches haben und die Dinger,
wofür du fett Lizenzgebühren abdrückst,
noch keine Patches haben, da haben die ganz schön
verkackt, oder?
Sollte eigentlich nicht sein. Ich würde da eigentlich
erwarten, dass Red Hat Patches
rausbringt, bevor die anderen
freien,
kostenlosen Red Hats, könnte man
sagen,
Patches rausbringen.
Aber naja, wir wissen
ja, nur weil man,
ich muss gerade mal ein bisschen leiser machen, die Musik,
Wir wissen ja nur, weil man für irgendwas Lizenzgebühren bezahlt, wird es nicht automatisch gut.
Aber wir können ja mal zu Oracle gucken oder SAP.
Inwieweit hat SAP was mit den Linux-Kernel-Patches zu tun?
So, habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Chatge, habe ich hier auch meine Jetplane Toolbox und so alles geupdatet?
Anscheinend, oder?
Oh, sieht so aus.
So, das haben wir geupdatet, das haben wir geupdatet.
Our Packages noch updaten, mal gucken, gibt es auch nichts.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen...
Ups, dann würde ich sagen...
Was ist das?
Wenn ich hier auf...
Ah, ich bin doof, guck mal, ich habe so...
Ich habe hier gerade so auf den Knopf gehauen, dass ich RF...
RF-Programmer, bist du so auch zu deinem Namen gekommen, weil du aus Versehen R und F zusammengedrückt hast?
Ich wollte eigentlich sagen...
Reboot.
Zum Glück habe ich meine Aliasse 1-999-Rs.
Also ich rebooten kann.
Weil in allen größeren SAP-Umgebungen hat SAP alleine geatmen Recht.
Ach so.
Auf dem System für Security, wenn man sich dort Routerechte verschafft, gibt es keins.
Ach ja, ist das so?
Ey, da habe ich letztens auch sowas gehört bei uns.
Auch irgendein Dienst.
Das war nicht SAP.
Ja.
Spielst du wieder Dark?
Ne.
Daok heißt das Venture.
Nee, spiele ich nicht.
Ich spiele Head of the Ring Online.
Wieder mal.
Also was heißt wieder mal?
Ich habe das früher mal ein bisschen gespielt, dann ganz jahrelang nicht mehr.
Und jetzt level ich gerade wieder.
Irgendwie hatte ich Bock drauf.
Daok ist gerade so Ende der Season.
Ich spiele nächste Season wieder.
Habe ich letztens auch gehört von irgendeinem Dienstleister bei uns.
Es war nicht SAP.
Die haben gesagt, die stellen uns die Systeme auch nur zur Verfügung.
und wir haben da keine Admin-Rechte drauf.
Es gibt wohl die Möglichkeit, einen, boah, frag mich nicht,
ja, irgendwie auch so Dark-Support oder irgendwie sowas anzuschalten,
dass man Admin-Rechte drauf hat,
aber dann gibt es von ihnen keine Support-Unterstützung mehr.
Also komplett unsinnig.
Willst du den Witcher 4 holen?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Witcher 3 war so nice.
Wenn die nur 50% davon liefern, dann wird das wieder nice
Das andere Ding ist
Ich habe halt so ein bisschen den Vertrauen
Über die letzten Jahre oder Jahrzehnte könnte man fast schon sagen
So ein bisschen Vertrauen in die meisten großen AAA-Produktionen
Oder was hat Bethesda letztens erzählt?
Die haben doch erzählt, wir haben eine AAA-Produktion
Was war das nochmal?
Quatreple A Production und das war dann der größte
Kack überhaupt
Äh, das war doch dieses Piratenspiel
Oder?
Dieses, oh ich hab schon wieder
Das war keine Sau mehr interessiert heutzutage
Ähm
Skulls and Bones?
Skulls and Bones
Ah ne, das war nicht, war das nicht Bethesda?
Okay, dann war es Ubisoft
Whatever, nimmt sich alles nix
Quatreple A Production
Das ist so ein dummes Geschwätz
Ähm
Aber ich gehe mal dafür.
Aber hat Witcher 4 überhaupt schon ein Release Date?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Das hat einfach ein Release Date.
Ja, das hätte mich jetzt auch...
Hätte mich jetzt auch sehr gewundert, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, wir machen mal kurz...
Reboot.
Weil wir hatten bestimmt Kernel-Updates.
Das war...
Nein, nein, das war nicht IBM.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das war.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Ich weiß nur noch, dass das der Chef von meinem Chef auf irgendeiner Runde erzählt hat, dass das so ist.
Und sich halt überlegen, ob sie das wollen oder nicht.
Es ist eh geil im Business Enterprise Umfeld.
Wenn man das nicht kennt, hält man das gar nicht für möglich.
Aber es ist da gar nicht so unverbreitet, dass man Geld bezahlt für Software, für Hardware, für eine Kombination aus Software und Hardware und es einem am Ende gar nicht gehört und man dann beispielsweise bezahlen muss für Rechenzeit und sowas.
Also ich glaube, eines der bekannteren Dinger ist IBM Mainframes.
Chatge hat noch einer von euch
die große
Ehre, kann man das ja wohl kaum nennen,
die große Ehre
ein IBM Mainframe zu haben.
Das ist meistens eher was für Banken
und Versicherungen.
IBM Host.
Zumindest dort ist es auch so,
da bezahlst du, die Hardware
bezahlst massig Lizenzgebühren,
Nämlich Lizenzgebühren.
Ja, dann lernst du mal Lizenzgebühren.
Du bezahlst massig Geld und das Ding gehört dir nicht.
Du musst trotzdem bezahlen pro CPU und Rechenzeit auf diesem Ding.
Obwohl es bei dir im Rechenzentrum steht.
Obwohl du es bezahlt hast.
Obwohl du es quasi mit Strom versorgst und allem.
Aber die Rechenzeit drauf musst du trotzdem mit einem Abo-Modell bezahlen.
Ja, solche Dinger meine ich, genau.
Nee, AS400 war das nicht.
Irgendwelche Storage-Dinger.
oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander
ach ja 1988 heißen die dinger nicht IBM Z series oder so was
ja diese dinger hier meine ich
Was ist das denn?
Microprocesadores.
Das ist bestimmt Spanisch.
Trotto lo
kudebe sabo.
Aha, alles klar.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal Battlefield 3 gespielt?
Ähm.
Ich hab's sogar noch installiert, glaube ich.
hab ich nicht installiert?
Das Ding ist, das Problem,
warum ich kein Battlefield 3 mehr spiele,
ich hätte tatsächlich ab und zu schon noch Bock auf
die eine oder andere Runde Battlefield 3,
dass die Rush kaputt gemacht haben.
Seit Jahren
sind die Rush-Server kaputt.
Wenn du Rush spielst,
crasht der Server meistens
nach einer Runde.
Auf der Xbox 360 und der PS3 sind die Server mittlerweile weg.
Zu den Root-Grechten. Einige USV-Hersteller machen sowas.
Da kostet das Upgrade. Das Linux-Kern ist gelb.
Beziehungsweise soll da für extra ein Techniker vorkommen.
Ja, wir hatten auch...
Die Geschichte habe ich euch ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Ich weiß, Chat, Recycle-Story.
Aber es sind ja auch immer neue Leute dabei.
Habe ich sogar ein Video zu gemacht.
Wir hatten auch mal ein Storage-System von IBM.
Und da war das ganz genau so.
Das war eine XIV.
War das.
Mal kurz zeigen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
IBM XIV.
Diese Dinger.
hier, so ein Teil war das.
Also die Säulen gehören nicht dazu.
So ein Ding war das, ein Storage-System.
Letztendlich war das einfach eine Kiste aus ganz
vielen 2 HE-Servern. Zumindest
ist es da auch so, du bezahlst
das Ding, du betreibst das Ding, aber
du hast da auch keine großen Admin-Rechte.
Und für Firmware-Updates muss ein Techniker vorbeikommen.
Und
die IBM-Leute
sind dann am Wochenende vorbeigekommen, weil am Wochenende halt, das war das freigegeben, da durfte man das.
Und da war ich und ein Kollege zusammen, waren in Frankfurt.
Und wir sollten im Endeffekt einfach nur, weil es ja unser Rechenzentrum war, dabei sitzen, als die IBM-Leute,
wenn wir Updates gemacht haben, ja, da kamen die IBM-Leute, wir haben die ins Rechenzentrum gelassen,
die haben sich das angeguckt, alles gut, und da hat der eine IBM-Techniker gesagt,
ah, sie haben den USB-Stick mit der Firmware vergessen, also die kamen wirklich mit dem USB-Stick an,
und dann ist der mit dem Kollege runtergefahren, zum Auto, hat den USB-Stick geholt,
und dann hat er es geschafft, Leute, ich weiß, das ist sehr unglaubwürdig,
weil es so unwahrscheinlich ist, aber es ist so passiert.
Trust me, Bro.
Es ist so passiert.
Die sind dann mit dem Fahrstuhl hochgefahren,
Kollege und der IBM-Techniker.
Der IBM-Techniker hatte den USB-Stick dabei.
Und dann hat das geschafft,
beim Aussteigen aus dem Fahrstuhl
den USB-Stick runterfallen zu lassen.
Und der USB-Stick ist in den Spalt
zwischen Fahrstuhl und dem Stockwerk gefallen.
Wisst ihr, wenn bei einem Fahrstuhl die Tür aufgeht,
ist ja so ein 1-2 cm
Spalt zwischen
Tür, zwischen
Stockwerk und Fahrstuhl.
Da ist der USB-Stick in den
Fahrstuhlschacht gefallen.
Und noch besser, es ist nicht einfach
nur in den Fahrstuhlschacht gefallen, dass man
irgendwie unten noch hätte rausholen können.
Nein, der ist in eine Ölpfanne
gelaufen, die unten im...
in eine Ölpfanne gefallen,
die unten im Fahrstuhlschacht
stand.
So.
Und da war natürlich das Ding mit
Firmware-Update am Wochenende erstmal gelaufen.
Zumindest,
zumindest,
also, da wollte dann auch keiner
reingreifen oder sowas. Ich glaube, wir wären da auch
gar nicht unten dran gekommen.
So, und dann hat das
ewig gedauert. Das hat wirklich
ewig gedauert. Die mussten dann
eben in Israel anrufen. Also,
die Firmware dieser Kisten
wurde in Israel. Ich glaube, das
sieht man auch noch.
Genau, hier, guck. Das ist eigentlich ursprünglich
von einem israelischen Startup
entwickelt wurde, dieses Ding.
Und die mussten dann den Israel anrufen.
Es war am Wochenende, da war keiner da.
Ja, dann hat es erstmal eine Weile gedauert,
bis, ich weiß nicht, welche Zeitzone die sind,
aber ich glaube, so ein großer Unterschied von der Zeitzone ist es gar nicht.
Und da haben die dann angerufen,
dann mussten sie noch irgendwie da einen rausklingeln,
der dann in die Firma gefahren ist.
Und dann mussten sie sich irgendwie bei VPN verbinden
und um fünf Ecken konnten sie sich den Graben anstecken lassen.
Das hat ewig...
Ne, ne, die konnten das dann irgendwie...
haben es dann über das Laptop gemacht und haben es dann über das Laptop
sich ein USB-Stick, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
So, und zumindest,
es hat ewig gedauert.
Wir haben da, keine Ahnung, acht Stunden
oder so sinnlos in Frankfurt
rumgehockt. Wir haben nichts gemacht. Gut,
dann wurde alles bezahlt. Also insofern kann man sich,
das war Free-Money-Klitsch.
Aber es war super langweilig.
Wir haben den halben Tag
bei irgendeinem Dönerladen, bei McDonalds oder sonst wo
rumgehockt, weil wir halt nichts machen konnten.
Konnten die das nicht
irgendwo downloaden. Ne, ne, Quatsch.
Das gibt es doch nicht irgendwie in einem Support-Bereich oder so.
Das war wahrscheinlich eine extra für uns
kompilierte Firmware. Keine Ahnung.
So. Zumindest wurde
uns das dann zugeschickt. Also nicht uns, den
IBM-Technikern wurde das zugeschickt und dann hat es
funktioniert. Riesenakt. Und wir
sind sogar über unsere erlaubte Arbeitszeit
an dem Tag gekommen. Und wir hatten
natürlich keinen Ausweichplan
an dem Tag, weil wir waren zu zweit
da. Die Wartungsarbeiten waren
für, keine Ahnung, zwei, drei Stunden oder
so angesetzt und nach 10 Stunden
oder so war dann halt, ne, es war
halt keiner mehr da am Wochenende. Da haben wir
damals unseren Chef angerufen. Der Chef hat gemeint,
ja gut, er geht jetzt halt
zum Bahnhof und fährt selber hin, weil
was wollen wir machen, ne?
Wir dürfen ja nicht länger als 10 Stunden und dann ist gut.
Und dann ist er auf dem Weg zum Bahnhof
gewesen. Als der Chef gerade auf dem Weg zum Bahnhof
war, ich bin froh,
dass den IBM-Technikern ersparen zu können,
weil der war garantiert nicht sonderlich happy
an dem Tag.
Und dann haben sie es aber hingekriegt. Dann ist er
wieder umgedrehten ist nicht ist nicht in zug gestiegen ja ich habe dazu
übrigens irgendwann wir es ganz ausführlich wissen will
ich habe dazu sogar mal ein video irgendwann gemacht
Wo ich das ausführlich erzählt habe.
Schon ein bisschen her anscheinend.
Ah ja, ich habe schon lange keine Videos mehr gemacht.
Irgendwie finde ich meine Thumbnails schön.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Irgendwie gefallen mir meine Thumbnails.
Das ist doch auch ein gutes Thumbnail.
Wie sehen IBM-Leute aus?
Anzuholen können?
Nö, die hatten keine Krawatte.
Ich glaube, die hatten ein Hemd oder so an.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Hier, da habe ich es auch.
Server zerstört Wohnungen, wie man kein Rechenzentrum baut.
Nee, das war was anderes gewesen.
Das war was anderes gewesen.
Das war Storage-System im Wohnzimmer.
Na, egal.
Mal Chaterino anmachen.
Äh.
Chat, schreib mal was.
Ist Chaterino kaputt?
Ah, ne. Es hat nur ein bisschen gebraucht.
Kannst du auf Arda
reagieren? Arda.
Das ist die Erde
bei Herr der Ringe.
Wie soll ich da drauf reagieren?
Shirt vom letzten Festival und was du nicht vergessen darfst, was bei einigen da auch sehr angesagt ist, Bändchen von den letzten Festivals.
Kennt ihr das? Die Leute, die irgendwie mit gefühlt 30 Bändchen am Handgelenk rumlaufen?
Ich würde die auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so lange anziehen, aber okay.
Instana. Oh, hat es euch auch erwischt.
Bei uns versuchen sie auch Instana unter die Leute zu bringen.
Instana ist doch irgend so ein Kostenanalyse-Tool für die Cloud, oder?
Bring ich das jetzt durch? Das ist das doch, oder?
Irgend so ein Analyse-Tool mit Dashboards und Gedöns.
Die sind bei uns auch am Start und wollen in Stana verkaufen.
Taugt das? Taugt das?
Observability, ja genau.
Cloud-Überwachung.
Das wollen die bei uns auch verkaufen oder haben es schon verkauft? Ich weiß es.
Guck mal, die Seite ist so kacke, dass noch nicht mal der Zurück-Button funktioniert.
Die Seite hat meinen Zurück-Button kaputt gemacht.
Guck mal, die...
WTF?
Chat?
Die Seite freest einfach meinen Browser komplett.
Ein CPU-Kern.
Ist komplett...
Alter, was ein Schrott.
Was ist das für eine Kackseite schon wieder, ey?
Wenn ich sowas schon wieder sehe,
dann kriege ich schon wieder Anfälle, ey.
Ich meine, die IBM-Seite ist eh abgrundtief kacke.
Wisst ihr was das Allerschlimmste ist? IBM Firmware Download. Die Seite für Firmwares.
Da kommst du dir vor wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend.
Das ist wirklich die letzte Dreckseite.
Ja, genau, das Dashboard Gedöns. Das wollen die bei uns auch laufen verkaufen.
So wie ich uns kenne, haben wir bestimmt beides.
Wir haben gefühlt 100.000 Tools gekauft,
die parallel existieren
und
keine Ahnung davon hatten.
Hier war nochmal die Story,
wo das Gewicht der Server zu schwer war für die Etage.
Das ist aus dem Video, was ich eben gezeigt habe.
Mit dem Storage
aus dem Wohnzimmer.
Ach ne!
Ach nee, du meinst das andere bei uns im Rechenzentrum.
Ja, da ging es auch um dieses Ding.
Sie wollten sich noch ein zweites Storage.
Also bei uns im Rechenzentrum war es so, guck mal.
Wir hatten ein Storage, so eine Kiste.
Also das ist eine Kiste, das hier ist eine zweite Kiste.
Dazwischen ist irgendwie ein Netzwerk.
Wobei, vielleicht gibt es die mittlerweile auch als zwei.
Ich weiß nicht, bei uns war das so ein Schrank.
So, die hatten einen Schrank und wollten noch einen zweiten Schrank hinstellen.
So, damals war unser Rechenzentrum im fünften Stock oder so.
Also es war, achso und by the way, fun fact, Chad, ratet mal, warum unser Rechenzentrum, warum unser Rechenzentrum, also für, also an diesem Standort im fünften Stock war und nicht etwa im Erdgeschoss oder im Keller.
Hat jemand eine klarreiche Idee, woran das liegen könnte?
Es gab, es gab theoretisch Platz im Keller.
Überflutung, Mietwohnung, ne
Der Grund war
Es gab Vorstandsparkplätze
Im Keller
Und die waren wichtiger als das Rechenzentrum
Da kannst du nichts machen
Das geht nicht
Da muss das Rechenzentrum im fünften Stock
Vorstandsparkplätze
Schlägt Rechenzentrum
Zumindest
hatten sie das Rechenzentrum im fünften Stock,
hatten so einen Schrank hier stehen
und haben gesagt, ey, sie wollen sich noch einen zweiten
Storage-Schrank daneben stellen.
Und der
Architekt-Statiker
hat damals gesagt,
das könnt ihr nicht machen,
das ist zu schwer.
Und
Chat, was
meint ihr?
Wie hat meine alte Firma darauf reagiert?
Haben die gesagt, ach, wir
stellen das woanders hin, haben die
gesagt, ach, wir machen es trotzdem.
Oder haben die gesagt, wir brauchen kein Storage.
Was haben die gemacht?
YOLO. Nee. Ja, fast.
Fast. Die haben einfach
das Architekturbüro gewechselt.
Bis sie eins gefunden haben, was ihnen die Statik
schön gerechnet hat, haben sie das zweite Storage reingestellt.
So geht's.
Und dann wurde die zweite Storage reingestellt.
Und meines Wissens nach ist das auch bis heute nicht durch die Decke gebrochen.
Wobei das echt ohne Scheiß, Leute, überlegt euch mal.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Denkt mal, stellt euch das mal vor.
Über euch, ihr wisst das nicht, ne?
Über euch steht ein mehrere Tonnen schweres Storage-System.
Ihr sitzt da drunter.
Und die Statik...
Was ist da drinnen?
da sind zwei HE-Server drin,
voller Festplatten.
Damals noch Festplatten,
noch keine SSDs.
Vielleicht ein bisschen SSDs damals schon.
Das ist ordentlich schwer.
Also ich habe jetzt
gesagt, mehrere Tonnen,
ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher,
aber ich denke mal,
dass wir durchaus schon eine Tonne
oder so wiegen können.
Ich meine, wie viele
Höheneinheiten sind denn das hier?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber einige. Und da hier alles
voller 2 HE-Server, voller Festplatten.
Och, das wiegt schon ein bisschen was, ne?
Dann USV
und Stromgedöns
und so. Batterien und so.
Das wiegt schon ein bisschen was.
Wir fragen mal. Komm, komm.
Wie viel wiegt ein
vollbestücktes
42 HE-Rack
mit Storage-Systemen
mit HDDs?
Mal gucken, ob
unsere KI da, guck mal,
zwischen 800 und 1300
Kilogramm. Also, kann
sich jetzt jeder selbst überlegen, wie viel
er da drauf gibt, was die KI sagt.
Komm, wir fragen nochmal die
China-Chinesen-KI, ob die das besser weiß.
Kann man hier nicht mehr?
Kann man hier nicht mehr das Model auswählen?
Früher ging das noch.
Guck mal. Seht ihr das?
Guck mal.
Die China-Chinesen-Seite ist ein bisschen kaputt
Da dumpen sie irgendwelche
JavaScript-Objekte raus
Ah, hier kann man jetzt auswählen
GLM 5.1, okay
Sie haben die bestimmt vibe-coded
Die haben die Seite, wisst ihr wie das passiert ist?
Ich könnte wetten
Die haben die Seite vibe-coded und dann ging irgendwas nicht
Und dann haben sie so Debug-Ausgaben gemacht
Und vergessen rauszunehmen
Okay, die China-Chinesen-Seite
Ganz nicht, was sagt
Wir fragen jetzt mal
Ein paar KIs, was da so Sache ist
500 Kilo bis 1,5 Tonnen
Ja, das ist ja nun wirklich ein sehr großes
Range, ja
Also, sag mal
Ich war mit einer Tonne
Ich war mit einer Tonne oder eineinhalb Tonnen
Gehen wir mal von einer Tonne aus, okay
So, stellt euch mal vor
Eine Tonne
Ja, okay
Eine Tonne bis 1,5
Also sagen wir mal so, irgendwas um eine Tonne wiegt das Ding
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr sitzt da unten drunter
Und das Ding bricht durch die Decke und fällt auf euch drauf
Ich glaube, wenn man sagt, ihr seid Matsch
Ist das noch eine Untertreibung
Matsch trifft
Ihr seid noch nicht mal mehr Matsch
Wenn es auf euch drauf fällt, so aus, keine Ahnung, drei, vier Meter Höhe durch die Decke.
Ihr seid nicht mal mehr Matsch.
Ihr seid...
Plattgedrückte Brühe.
Wenn das Ding mit 1,5 Tonnen aus vier Metern auf euch drauf klatscht.
Aber das geht schnell, auf jeden Fall.
Kriegt er nicht mal viel von mit.
Ah, das hat es bei uns nicht gegeben.
Da hätten sie die Haustechnik
irgendwo anders hingejagt.
Der erste Stock hätte nicht gereicht.
Äh, ich glaube im ersten Stock.
Das ist eine gute Frage, warum die das nicht weiter unten gebaut haben.
Wahrscheinlich waren da irgendwelche Konferenzräume oder sowas.
Also im Erdgeschoss waren Konferenzräume, das weiß ich auf jeden Fall.
Im ersten Stock. Ich glaube ich war nie im ersten Stock.
Keine Ahnung. Weiß nicht.
IBM hat ihr eigenes UI-Framework.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Carbon Design.
Ich habe noch nie einen gesehen, der das benutzt.
Aber es hat tatsächlich relativ viele Sterne.
Auf GitHub.
Ja.
Wer auch immer dieses IBM-GUI-Zeug benutzt, keine Ahnung.
Das sieht schon...
Allein von der Seite ist es so kacke, dass du nichts findest, Alter.
Ein Dropdown.
So, toll.
So, habe ich eigentlich Updates gemacht?
Ich habe Updates gemacht, ne?
Egal, wir machen nochmal Updates, weil Arch, Linux,
by the way, Bleeding Edge.
Hast du Tipps? Ich wechsle jetzt in einem Monat zum Ende meiner Ausbildung von Inhouse zu Dienstleister. Was kannst du mir so ans Herz legen? Keine Ahnung. Gute Frage. Also erstmal würde mich interessieren, warum wechselst du? Übernehmen die dich nicht? Oder ist der Laden kacke und du willst nicht?
Wenn du Pech hast, kracht es...
Ähm, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Wahrscheinlich wird das sogar so sein.
Wenn das Ding erstmal Schwung hat, wird es wahrscheinlich bis ins Erdgeschoss durchbrechen.
Dienstleister hört sich nach...
Ne, nicht zwangsläufig.
Das heißt nicht, dass du automatisch First Level Support machst.
Wie wollen wir das jetzt...
Okay.
Ähm, und dann bist du...
dann hast du relativ easy einen neuen Job gefunden.
Sprich doch schon mal für dich.
Vielleicht, ja.
Ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich kein,
fallen mir da gerade keine Tipps ein.
Letztendlich das Gleiche,
wie wenn du überall einen neuen Job anfängst, ja.
Was man immer nicht vergessen darf, so generell, wenn man bei einem neuen Job anfängt, erster Eindruck ist wichtig.
Also es schadet nicht, sich die ersten 1-2 Monate wirklich von seiner besten Seite zu zeigen.
Dass alle einen guten Eindruck von dir haben.
Dann ist das gefestigt und danach kannst du dann zum Tagesgeschäft übergehen.
Es schadet auch nichts, ein bisschen Interesse zu faken und nachzufragen und sowas, weil die Leute lieben es, wenn man sich für ihre Themen interessiert.
Ein bisschen guten Eindruck machen, so die ersten ein, zwei Monate ist definitiv nicht verkehrt.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich würde am Anfang kein...
So nicht auf irgendwie wichtig tun und...
Ich sag euch, wo es lang geht und so machen.
Ich würde gucken, dass man in den ersten ein, zwei Monaten wirklich bei allen Leuten einen guten Eindruck macht,
weil man weiß vom Anfang an ja nicht, wer wichtig ist, beziehungsweise wichtig in den passenden Positionen ist.
und wenn man da
beim Falschen direkt
an den ersten paar Tagen auf dicke Hose macht,
der haben dann gleich vielleicht der Chef vom Chef
einen schlechten Eindruck. Also ganz ehrlich,
so die ersten ein, zwei Monate sich von seiner
besten Zeit zeigen, ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Danach interessiert es
keinen mehr, aber man glaubt das gar nicht.
Der erste Eindruck ist oftmals wirklich entscheidend.
Und eine Sache, wo ich festgestellt habe, die bringt tatsächlich was, wenn du irgendwas nicht verstehst und das wird wirklich in Massen sein, weil jedes Unternehmen, jetzt mal Hand aufs Herz, sag mir mal im Chat, ob das bei euch auch so ist.
jedes unternehmen hat tausende abkürzungen die so benutzt werden als
wäre es das alltäglichste auf der welt und jeder auf der welt würde sie
benutzen dabei ist es was sehr unternehmen
spezifisches und was noch viel besser ist unternehmen haben auch doppelte
abkürzungen
Also wir hatten beim alten Unternehmen zum Beispiel ADS.
So, ADS stand für drei Sachen.
Einmal das alt... Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr alles.
Einmal das altbekannte Active Directory Services.
Für was steht ein ADS noch, Leute?
Active Directory?
Was gibt es denn da sonst noch?
Also ich weiß noch die andere, aber es gibt doch noch was ADS.
Ich weiß nicht.
Zumindest bei uns war das so, dass viele Leute ADS nicht für Active Directory benutzt haben,
sondern für, jetzt kommt's, Antrags-Dispatcher.
Und da hast du erstmal ADS gehört
Und hast dir gedacht
Warum reden die so komisch über Active Directory
Aber nein, die haben über den Antrags-Dispatcher geredet
Und was auch besonders witzig ist
wenn du Dienstleister hast, die die gleichen Abkürzungen
doppelt verwenden und sowas mit dir.
Und so das ganze...
Ja, das ist halt auch Fail.
Was ist ein Antrags-Dispatcher?
Also ich habe ja bei einer Bank
gearbeitet, ja, und da gibt es viele Anträge.
Und diese Anträge werden
irgendwo hin
dispatcht, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, was das macht.
Bist du eigentlich so Boomer,
dass du LinkedIn und Xing benutzt?
ne, ich hab kein LinkedIn oder Xing Account.
Wobei ich nicht unbedingt sagen würde,
dass LinkedIn Boomer ist.
LinkedIn ist eher so
so Business Instagram.
So möglichst
viel Bullshit posten.
Wie geil man ist und wie viel
wie viel man selbst quasi im Kopf der Welt voraus ist.
Ja, ach genau, was ich sagen wollte.
Also ist bei euch ja auch so, dass ganz viele,
du kannst ruhig, wenn du neu bist,
und die mit irgendwelchen Abkürzungen um sich werfen,
komm dir nicht dumm vor,
so nach dem Motto,
ich darf jetzt nichts sagen, weil die denken doch alle, man weiß es und wenn ich jetzt frage, was das ist, dann denken die, ich bin doof.
Das stimmt nicht. Die vergessen einfach nur, dass nicht die ganze Welt weiß, was ihre 3000 unternehmensinterne Abkürzungen bedeuten.
Wenn die irgendwie sagen, so nach dem Motto, der ADS auf dem HPA ist heute Nacht mit dem ZPMG auf dem ZUIPU gelaufen und hat einen ADFG gebracht oder so.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe mir jetzt irgendwas ausgedacht. Und die sagen dann, ah, ein ADFG, okay, okay, das heißt, können wir dann mal einen PLO starten oder sowas.
Da kannst du ruhig sagen, ey wartet mal Leute
Was wollt ihr eigentlich?
Ich finde das macht gar keinen schlechten Eindruck
Zu sagen, Alter
Redet mal normal
Ja gut, das ist dumm
Das nervt mich übrigens auch
Das nervt mich richtig
Wir haben auch so Kandidaten auf der Arbeit
Wir diskutieren manchmal bei uns
Im Teams-Chat
also im Teams
im Teamchat
diskutieren wir manchmal über irgendwelche Sachen, ja
zum Beispiel, wie machen wir jetzt am besten Updates für Copy-Fail
oder sowas, und da kommen dann manchmal
auch irgendwelche Fragen
und dann gibt es Leute
die pasten diese Frage
in eine KI und pasten
die KI-Antwort, die
useliste, unsinnigste KI-Antwort
zurück in den Chat
das triggert mich immer richtig, so nach dem
Motto, als wären die Leute nicht in der Lage
gewesen selbst das schon mal in die ki zu passen und was die ki antwort ist halt
dumm so nach dem motto ach leute ich habe mal die ki gefragt guck mal so geht's
dann also das nervt mich immer wenn leute einfach sinnlos fragen ki posten
und posten die antwort in den chat das kann ich selbst
man kann eigentlich davon ausgehen die meisten leute copy pasten heute bevor
sie irgendwie bei uns im teams chat irgendwas schreiben dieses zeug selbst
mal eine KI, wenn sie es nicht wissen.
Die KI weiß was Sinnvolles.
Ich habe letztens auf Reddit
was Witziges gelesen und zwar
da hat jemand
Moment, warte mal.
Reddit
Anti-Work war das glaube ich in dem Post.
Clouds?
Warte mal, muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Oder was?
Anti-Work? Ich weiß nicht.
Irgendwelche Subreddits, wo die Leute
sich über ihre heißt es cloud pro oder premium account
Ich glaube, das war bei Antiwork.
Zumindest, da hat einer, ich muss mal kurz gucken, da hat einer letztens was gepostet.
Das fand ich wirklich richtig, richtig pepega.
Warten wir mal, gucken wir mal, vielleicht finden wir das.
Vielleicht können wir hier nach Clowns suchen.
Aber die Reddit-Suche ist halt...
Ist halt dumm, ne?
So, vielleicht soll ich auch richtig schreiben.
Ah ja, das hier.
Das hier.
So.
Man weiß bei diesem Subreddit nicht wirklich, ob das echt ist.
Aber dass das so dumm ist, glaube ich mir.
Und zwar hat hier der Chef geschrieben an die Leute, ich fasse das mal kurz zusammen, wir müssen das jetzt nicht lesen. Der Chef hat an die Leute geschrieben, so hallo meine Team-Members, es ist Zeit hier eine Kurskorrektur durchzuführen in meinem Team.
Und zwar, ihr habt jetzt die Aufgabe, einen Cloud Pro Account zu erstellen.
Übrigens kein Wort dazu, wer das bezahlt oder sowas.
Einen Cloud Pro Account zu erstellen und dann diesen Prompt da rein zu pasten und eben die Antwort von dem Prompt, also die Antwort von Cloud rein zu pasten.
Und zwar, der Prompt bezieht sich darauf, dass Cloud, also die sollen quasi an Cloud Code eine Beschreibung von ihrem Job posten und Cloud Code soll ihnen einen Vorschlag posten, wie sie ihren Job möglichst optimieren können.
und das sollen sie dann als Anfordernd
ihren Chef posten, das ist so
unglaublich dämlich, Alter
also, jetzt mal im Ernst
wenn da bei uns einer was in der Richtung
bei uns wird das nicht passieren, da bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher, das wird nicht vorkommen, ja
Alter, da würde ich mir auch echt an den Kopf greifen
und direkt nach was Neuem suchen
also das ist richtig hängen geblieben
und
Ähm
Den letzten Satz finde ich hier auch geil
Guck mal
I'm available for questions about the tools or the prompt
I'm not available for excuses
Also wenn einer keinen Bock hat
Das zu machen, kann er sich gleich verpissen
Joa, ist auch eine Ansage
Ich hoffe, dass sich einfach instant
Alle verpisst haben
Ach ja, und was ich auch witzig finde, er hat geschrieben
I will read each one personally
Hat er geschrieben
I will read every response personally
Ich wette mit euch, der liest sie nicht personally
Der lässt sie sich auch von der KI zusammenfassen
Das habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Ganz ehrlich, also wenn ich
sowas machen würde, ja, mal ganz einfach abziehen,
dass ich mir instant nach was anderem umgucken würde,
würde ich es wahrscheinlich
auch so machen. Ich würde Claude
sagen, ey, weißt du was?
Bla bla bla bla bla,
hier, so und so,
schreib das mal,
dass ich besonders gut dastehe, aber erwähne
diesen Prompt nicht. Und dann den Kram reinpasten
vom Chef.
Es gab doch letztens sogar eine Untersuchung zu, dass KI besser ist als die meisten Manager.
KI oder AI better than management.
Okay, da findet man bei Google nichts.
Aber da gab es doch letztens was drüber, dass KI besser ist als die meisten Leute in Entscheidungspositionen, um eben diese Jobs zu erledigen.
Chat, wer von euch hat auf der Arbeit auch noch größere Patch-Aktionen vor sich für Copy Fail und Dirty Frag?
Also Copy Fail haben wir mittlerweile gepatcht.
Dirty Frag noch nicht, weil es noch keine Patches für Red Hat gibt.
Würde mich mal interessieren, wie es bei euch da aussieht.
So, nochmal gucken, ob wir Bleeding Edge
Ja
Du hast recht, ja
Falsch, aber das ist egal, das checken die
Das checkt die Suche auch so, dass ich das meine
Habt ihr
Pepe Potter, habt ihr Copy Fail schon gepatcht?
Und wartet noch auf Dirty Frick Patches?
Oder habt ihr beides noch nicht gepatcht?
Oder seid ihr gerade noch dabei?
Also bei uns ist Copyfail so gut wie durch.
Es gibt noch, glaube ich, ein paar Prod-Systeme, die noch nicht gepatcht wurden.
Ah, zum größten Teil ist es durch.
So, dann gucken wir doch mal, was auf GitHub so trendet.
So, nicht
this week und zwar nicht für Go, sondern
für alles.
Hallo Max, denkst
du, ich verschwende meine Zeit mit Scrum
PMO?
Ups.
Fuck.
Ähm, denkst du, ich verschwende meine Zeit
mit Scrum PMO
beziehungsweise
PMO ist
Projektmanagement?
Was ist PMO? Projektmanagement?
was ist das was ist das o organisation projektmanagement organisation kann ist
der koppel dankeschön für den sub box abschluss und lucky look dankeschön für
die subs leute exzellente
euch ist das durch ja gut wie es bei anderen teams ist weiß ich nicht ja das
das bei mir auch so also genau was wollen jetzt sagen
hallo da habe ich was krollen hallo mag 6 ich verspreche meine zeit mit scrum
pmo bzw ki zertifizierung ich weiß es viel quacksalberei aber mir geht es um
die beruflichen vorteile ok also ihr wisst dass ich kein total
ansagen schulden sapok subskript wenn das ganze gefällt kann übrigens auch ein
voller lassen wird mich auch freuen natürlich freue mich subskriptions auch
Also danke, Totoruns.
Aber Follows freu mich auch.
Grüne Balken, die hochgehen, sind immer pog.
Ähm, genau. Und vielleicht
kann ich ja
meinen MMO-Cry ein bisschen
zügeln und mehr streamen in nächster Zeit.
So, ähm,
also, ich weiß nicht wie Quacksalberal
dabei, aber mir geht's so berufliche Vorteile.
Also, wie gesagt, ihr wisst, dass ich persönlich von
Zertifizierung, ich bin überhaupt kein Fan von
Zertifizierung.
Das hängt aber immer ein bisschen davon ab,
ob der jeweilige Arbeitgeber oder der Bereich, wo man unterwegs ist, da drauf steht.
Also bei mir hat sich nie einer für Zertifizierung interessiert.
Ich habe auch keine Zertifizierung.
Die einzige Zertifizierung, die ich irgendwann mal gemacht habe, schon ewig her in der Ausbildung, ist ein Cisco CCNA.
Von dem weiß ich heute aber nichts mehr.
Die laufen ja auch ab nach einer Zeit, glaube ich.
Das einzige, was ich noch weiß von dem CCNA ist, man muss EN machen auf Cisco System und dann CONVT.
EN, CONVT und wenn man die Config speichern will, sagt man Copy, Run.
Ich weiß schon, Copy, Run?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie man Config speichert.
Ich habe schon keine Ahnung mehr.
copy run start ja genau das ist es das ist es das ist es
ja also mit ein bisschen tutorial und so könnte ich schon noch irgendwie cisco
router mit ospf und so aufsetzen aber ganz ehrlich da müsste ich auch viel googeln dabei ich habe
keine ahnung mehr von und außerdem ccnr hat gefühlt eh jeder juckkassau hat sich aber bei mir auch keiner dafür jemals interessiert großartig nach zertifizierung
und
das das war's ja
Wenn es in deinem Bereich relevant ist, dann ist es sicherlich sinnvoll. Ich kann dazu aber nichts sagen, weil ich persönlich von Zertifizierung nichts halte. Für mich ist diese ganze Zertifikats-Zertifizierungsbranche so ein selbst erhaltendes, selbst versorgenes Ökosystem.
Da gibt es Schulungen für Lehrer, also die Schulungsleute müssen Schulungen machen und die Schulungen laufen aus, dann musst du wieder eine Schulung buchen und wieder Geld.
Wir drucken selber Geld, so dieses ganze Zertifizierungskram, so ein bisschen die Lizenz zum Geld drucken.
Deswegen, ich halte davon nichts von Zertifizierung.
Ich habe auch noch keinen gesehen, wo ich gesagt hätte, alter, krass hat der viel Ahnung und das liegt an den ganzen tausend Zertifizierungen, die er hat.
geschweige denn, ich habe auch noch, mir hat es auch, also, umgedreht muss ich sagen,
also, ich habe auch noch keinen getroffen, wo ich denke, krass, der hat viel Ahnung
und der hatte überhaupt viele Zertifizierungen.
Ja, also, keine Ahnung, ich halte davon nicht viel.
Wenn es in deiner Branche, wenn es in deiner Richtung sinnvoll ist,
kann ich nichts zu sagen, kann aber durchaus sein, ja.
Was ich an sich nicht verkehrt finde, ist,
ein Scrum, also, wenn dich das interessiert, ja,
Ja, also KI-Zertifizierung halte ich für komplett sinnlos.
Weiß nicht, was man da großartig zertifizieren soll.
Da muss man sich persönlich eh ordentlich einarbeiten, dass man da halbwegs Durchblick hat.
Und ich meine damit jetzt nicht, wie schreibt man einen ordentlichen Prompt.
Ja, da kriegt man so, wenn man KI benutzt, so halbwegs das Gefühl dafür.
Und man kann es natürlich auch komplett übertreiben.
Gibt ja Leute, die haben das richtig, richtig krass drauf.
So ein bisschen so wie man früher gelernt hat zu googeln, lernt man heute.
wie fragt man eine KI am besten, Zertifizierung für KI, das glaube ich ist aktuell einfach nur Geldmacherei,
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendwas bringt, Scrum, also zu PMO kann ich gar nichts sagen,
zu Scrum, da kann ich mir aber tatsächlich vorstellen, dass es sinnvoll macht,
falls du dich in dieser Richtung in Zukunft ja austoben willst, beim Thema Scrum,
da könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass es Unternehmen interessiert,
interessiert, ob du so eine Scrum Master
Zertifizierung hast oder nicht,
dass du quasi prinzipiell weißt, wie man sowas
leitet und auf was man achten
muss und wie das Ganze so funktioniert.
Also das ist, glaube ich, so diese Scrum-Geschichte,
wenn es dich interessiert, ist, glaube ich, die
einzige Geschichte von diesen ganzen
Zertifizierungen, wo ich sagen würde, ey, das
könnte tatsächlich
sinnvoll sein.
Aber mich darfst du dann nicht großartig fragen, weil ich
habe keine zertifizierung und ich habe auch noch nie zertifizierung gebraucht hat sich bei mir noch
nie einer für interessiert noch habe ich bei anderen großartig mitgekriegt aber scrum master
zertifizierung da könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass das noch die sinnvollste ist
projektmanagement kein blassen schimmer und ki glaube ich einfach nur geld geldmacherei aktuell
Packet Tracer
Packet Tracer ist das beste, Leute
Habe ich überhaupt Packet Tracer installiert?
Oh ne
Wir haben gar keinen Packet Tracer
mehr installiert
Packet Tracer, beste, jetzt brauchen wir wieder
wobei das konnte man ja gar nicht mehr installieren das ging das ging das ging
nicht ging glaube ich nicht mehr packet racer zu installieren da musste man sich
das ganze da muss man sich den cisco account machen und das runterladen erstmal
habe das gefühl dass es bei codern wirklich nur auf die skills ankommt
Bei der ich kenne kaum programmieren die sich gerne koder nennen
sage ich jetzt einfach mal weiß ich wie es bei euch geht ich finde koder ist ein doofes wort ich nenne die leute entwickler oder programmierer
Coda ist nicht so beliebt
Aber das ist irgendwie als projektmanagement so schwer nachweisbar ist kann ich mir vorstellen ja
das liegt aber auch daran dass es bei gerade im managementbereich
bereich ganz viele leute gibt die gut schwätzen können aber nicht aber sonst
nichts gut können deswegen natürlich auch schwierig da
irgendwas zu zeigen ja ich glaube das beste was du als projektmanagement
projektmanagement zeigen kannst ist projekte vorzuweisen die gut gelaufen
sind
du brauchst gerade eine webseite mit ruby ja ne ruby ist eine schöne sprache
oder also generell ruby und rails ist auch ein super framework
habe das gefühl dass alle vorstellungsgespräche nur herr geschoben und name-topic von irgendwie
ja das ist so ja also gerade gerade wenn er irgendwas irgendwas frei wenn es nur hr ist
dann haben wir auch keine ahnung davon sondern haben irgendeine liste mit irgendwelchen buzzwords
von dem Team bekommen, die jemand suchen
und fragen die dann einfach ab.
Ja, so nach dem Motto
Jira, check.
Irgendwelche Tools, check.
Check das, check.
Kanbanboards, check.
Ishikawa-Diagramme, check.
Guncharts, check.
So, keine Ahnung.
Also, das kannst du meistens eh vergessen.
Wenn du dann mal mit jemandem reden kannst
aus dem Team, beziehungsweise deinem Teamleiter
aus dem Team, wo du bist, oder
deinem Chef, dann sieht das schon wieder anders aus.
Aber wenn es wirklich nur HR ist,
die irgendwelche Checklisten arbeitet, dann ist das
natürlich
meistens verschwendete
Zeit, aber muss man trotzdem
durch. Da kannst du nur
versuchen, einen möglichst guten Eindruck zu machen.
Was ist Gepäcketracer mittlerweile zum Download?
Was wäre denn das von mir?
Tracer.
Äh.
Packet Tracer Installer.
Ja gut, aber muss ich das...
Ja, aber muss ich das von hier downloaden?
Oder muss man sich das da nicht mehr
selbst runterladen?
Wir gucken mal kurz in das
Skript rein.
Install Packet Tracer.
Ach, gucke mal.
Der hat es hochgeladen
unter Releases.
Ach, guck mal, der hat Packet Tracer
einfach so... Okay, nice.
Exzellent.
Das finde ich aber nice.
Was witzig ist,
wir laden uns das jetzt irgendwo von GitHub runter.
Wir haben ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung,
ob das nicht irgendein manipuliertes
Zeug ist, was wir jetzt installieren.
In der heutigen Zeit weiß man ja nie so genau.
wie ist deine meinung zu scram kommen darauf an ob man es richtig macht oder mich die ursprüngliche
idee hinter diesem ganzen age zeug da gibt es übrigens ein gute ein gutes video auf youtube
von einem der agile erfinder die ursprüngliche idee dahinter war entwickler und management so
gut wie es möglich ist voneinander zu trennen so dass management immer noch
seinen senf dazu geben kann aber die entwickler möglichst lange ruhe vom
management haben das ist der eigentliche sinn hinter
agile gewesen was da heute teilweise daraus fabriziert wird ist schon wieder
teilweise fragwürdig vor allem wenn es dann solche auswüchse gibt wie der
projektmanager ist auch das crumb master und solche geschichten das ergibt ja
überhaupt keinen sinn das kram master soll dafür sorgen dass
die Abläufe möglichst,
sag mal, möglichst ideal
funktionieren,
was komplett gegen das
läuft, was vielleicht
der Projektmanager will. Also das
macht keinen Sinn, was da teilweise läuft.
An sich finde ich die Idee, dass man
sagt, okay,
Entwickler werden nicht jeden Tag von
Management genervt, eigentlich einen ganz
guten Ansatz. So nach dem
Motto, Management kann neue Sachen einkippen,
was gemacht werden soll. Man schneidet
sich das dann so, wie man denkt, dass
man es packt. Ein bisschen anhand
der Priorisierung, wie wichtig
verschiedene Sachen sind. Und dann
schafft man einfach 14 Tage oder eine Woche
oder drei Wochen oder so vor sich hin.
Und dann
plant man das nächste. An sich finde ich das
eigentlich ganz sinnvoll. Wenn es
gescheit gemacht ist.
Der KI-Kram
bewegt sich eh so schnell, sobald du mit dem
Zertifikat das Gebäude verlässt.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, deswegen halte ich
KI-Zertifizierung auch für
komplett heiße Luft.
Also ich kann euch sagen, wie das
bei mir war
mit Vorstellungsgespräch.
Das war glaube ich
so ziemlich die kürzeste
Bewerbungsrunde, die man sich vorstellen kann.
Also da für meinen aktuellen Job.
Ging folgendermaßen.
Ich hab auf YouTube ein Video hochgeladen
Muss man sich mal vorstellen, was für ein geiler Zufall eigentlich, ne?
Ähm
Entweder das hier
Ich hab gekündigt, was jetzt
Also entweder das, lass mal kurz gucken, von wann ich das hochgeladen hab
Sieht man irgendwo, wann man das hochgeladen hat?
30.12.
Ne, das ist zu spät.
Ich kündige, jetzt reicht es.
Das hier.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und ich.
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Genau, ich habe dieses Video hier hochgeladen.
Deshalb werde ich kündigen.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Und da schreibt mich ein ehemaliger Kollege an.
Auf dem Handy.
Schickt mir da ein Message.
und sagt, ey Max, ich hab dein Video gesehen.
Bei uns suchen sie gerade neue Leute, das wäre genau was für dich.
Willst du nicht mal bei uns gucken?
Aber er sagt, ach ja, das ist ja spannend.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, zu diesem Zeitpunkt, ne,
hatte ich mir schon einen neuen Job gesucht
und hatte sogar schon den neuen Arbeitsvertrag in der Post.
Und ehemaliger Kollege hat das Video gesehen,
hat mich angeschrieben, hat dann ein iMessage geschickt,
Er hat gesagt, ey Max, bei uns suchen die schon seit irgendwie einem Jahr oder so nach einem neuen Linux Pro und hättest du nicht Bock drauf, richtig leiser laden und guck dir das doch mal an bei uns.
habe ich mir die Stellenanzeige angeguckt, habe mir gedacht, ja, das passt eigentlich schon ziemlich gut, ja, also es ist auch genauso, es war auch Finanzbranche, ja, ihr wisst ja, ich war vorher bei einer Bank, jetzt bin ich bei einer Versicherung und Frankfurt, es ist Finanzbranche, es ist irgendwie 800 Meter Luftlinie von meinem alten Job weg und ich kenne mich mit den Sachen aus, es passt eigentlich ziemlich gut, ja.
dann habe ich dem schon mal unter der hand meine bewährung geschickt bzw meine skill liste
geschickt die skill ist da die habe ich jetzt nicht mehr hier skills die habe ich nicht mehr
hier die ich habe doch die rechner neu aufgesetzt wir hatten im stream einmal so eine skill liste
gemacht für meine bewerbung damals somit was ich war von was ich alles ahnung habe ja das
waren drei Seiten Skills, bam, bam, bam, alles der, also alles mögliche drinne und wirklich sehr breit und habe ich dem geschickt, dann hat er das seinem Chef weitergeschickt und da war ich gerade im Bauhaus und habe einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft, das müsste dann 2000, 2022 war das, ja, da war ich im Bauhaus und habe einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft für Weihnachten 2022,
Da ruft mich sein Chef an
Und sagt, hey Max
Also sinngemäß, hey Max
Also er hat nicht gesagt, er hat gesagt, hallo Herr
Max, hallo Herr Max
Ähm
Der Kollege XY hat mir das hier
Weitergeschickt
Finde ich super
Finde ich sehr nice und hätten Sie nicht nächste Woche
Zeit, dass wir uns mal kennenlernen
Ich habe keine offizielle Bewerbung oder sowas
Geschrieben, ne
Ich habe meinem Kollege einfach nur so
quasi mal so unter der Hand den Kram geschickt.
So, hier, guck mal, kannst ja mal
weiterleiten. Ja, da können
wir uns mal treffen. Also haben wir
einen Termin vereinbart zum
Vorstellungsgespräch. Bin ich
dahin, hatte ich ein
Vorstellungsgespräch mit einem
von HR, der war
remote
zugeschaltet und
meinem zukünftigen Chef,
der war vor Ort.
Und wir haben uns am Anfang des
Vorstellungsgesprächs alle beide Seiten
darauf verständigt, wir können uns
heute nicht entscheiden,
weil wir müssen
uns das noch überlegen. Hab ich
gesagt, weil ich hatte ja schon einen
Arbeitsvertrag von dem
anderen Laden am Start,
ja, und
die haben das gesagt, weil sie
müssen sich ja nochmal überlegen, so. Und da
hatten wir, glaube ich, zweieinhalb Stunden
oder sowas, ging ewig
Vorstellungsgespräch, ja.
Zumindest so nach eineinhalb Stunden
Vorstellungsgespräch. Wir haben
übrigens auch im Vorstellungsgespräch, witzigerweise,
über mein GitHub, ich hab ein GitHub-Repo
mitgeschickt.
Der hat einen Lebenslauf von mir
und
der hat einen Lebenslauf
von mir und meine Skill-Liste und ich
hab mein GitHub-Repo drin, da stand der Fiat-Champ
und irgendwie ist der sehr Auto
und Motorrad interessiert, der hat mich
nach meinem Repo
für meinen Fiat gefragt, im Vorstellungsgespräch.
Damals hatte ich zum Glück nicht
47 und gelöste Issues.
Alles Anwendungsfehler natürlich.
Und das ist nicht
vor vier Jahren zuletzt aktualisiert.
Egal. Whatever.
Und
da haben wir dann
drüber geredet. So nach eineinhalb Stunden
hat er dann gesagt,
also ich hab gesehen, er hat sich
so unterm Schreibtisch
SMS geschrieben mit dem HR-Typ
und anscheinend haben die sich da auch gerade abgestimmt, dass es doch wohl ganz gut passt
und es war uns ja allen klar, wir müssen das schnell über die Bühne kriegen,
weil ich habe ja schon einen neuen Arbeitsvertrag quasi in der Post liegen bei einem anderen Unternehmen
und da haben wir uns dann nach eineinhalb Stunden Vorstellungsgespräch drauf geeinigt,
es gefällt uns beiden und wir gehen jetzt direkt in die Gehaltsverhandlungen über.
Also wir sind uns einig, das passt.
Habe ich gesagt, jawohl, ich finde es bei euch nice, was ihr mir so erzählt habt.
Und die haben gesagt, Max, wir finden es bei dir nice und wir wollen dich einstellen.
Gut, dann haben wir noch ein bisschen Gehaltsverhandlungen gemacht und ich habe erzählt bekommen,
wie das da mit Bonuszahlungen, ich habe ganz ehrlich, ich habe damals versucht, einfach einen guten Eindruck zu machen.
Ich habe die Hälfte davon nicht gecheckt.
Zumindest habe ich damals eiskalt gesagt, als sie mich gefragt haben, was wollen sie für ein Gehalt haben.
Habe ich eiskalt gesagt, ich will 115.000 Euro im Jahr.
Das war 2022.
Ich will 115.000 Euro im Jahr.
Und da haben sie erstmal gesagt, oh, das ist aber ein bisschen viel.
Aber ich habe absichtlich schon ein bisschen mehr gesagt als das, wo ich zufrieden mit bin.
Und am Ende haben sie mir das dann vorgerechnet mit Rufbereitschaften und allem, was es sonst so gibt,
dass man dann doch irgendwie so in den Dreh kommt.
Und das ist auch so. Wohlgemerkt, wenn man 100% arbeiten würde. Ich arbeite ja nicht 100%, also ich verdiene weniger. Aber mittlerweile ist es so, es gab jetzt schon... Ne, ich habe es nicht eingescannt.
Also mittlerweile ist es tatsächlich so, ich habe ziemlich genau 100k so Grundbasisgehalt mittlerweile, wenn man 100% arbeiten würde.
Das ist ohne die Bonuszahlung, ohne Schichtzulage, also in der Schicht trifft es sich, ohne Rufbereitschaftszulage und ohne Rufbereitschaft und alles mögliche dabei.
Also ich kann euch sagen, mein Kollege, der 100% arbeitet, der fast das gleiche kriegt wie ich, 2000 Euro weniger oder sowas, der verdient knapp, so je nachdem wie viel Rufbereitschaft es ist, nehmen wir mal die Mitte, so 135k ungefähr im Jahr.
Brutto, wohlgemerkt, ja die Hälfte davon geht ja schon mal weg
An Steuern, damit dann irgendein Plötzchen
Gemacht werden kann
Aber das hat ziemlich genau
Meinen Vorstellungen entsprochen
So, zumindest waren wir uns dann einig und dann ging das Ganze
Zweieinhalb Stunden
Eigentlich wollte er noch das Team mir vorstellen, aber die waren dann schon
Alle daheim
So, und dann waren wir uns einig
Das war mein Vorstellungsgespräch
Quasi
Beworben
So unter der Hand beim Kollege
Anruf vom Chef, offizielles Vorstellungsgespräch
Zweieinhalb Stunden Vorstellungsgespräch
Wir waren uns einig, inklusive Gehalt
Arbeitsvertrag kommt nächste Woche per Post
Und der Arbeitsvertrag kam auch nächste Woche per Post
Da muss man mal wirklich sagen, Hut ab
Vor unserer Personalabteilung
Ist das immer noch die Stelle bei der Bank?
Das ist die Stelle davor, jetzt bin ich bei einer Versicherung
jetzt bin ich bei einer versicherung davor war ich bei einer bank und da
waren wir uns einig da muss ich wirklich sagen so gut ab vor der personalabteilung
weil die alte personalabteilung wo ich davor war die hätten es nicht in der woche hingekriegt
das ist immer schön so was zu lesen
Genau, und die haben das auch hingekriegt, weil wir mussten es ja auch schnell hinkriegen.
Weil erstens hatte ich schon den Vertrag von einem anderen Arbeitgeber in der Post, wo ich eigentlich hinwollte.
Die musste ich dann irgendwie noch hinhalten für eine Woche.
Und ich musste ja bis 31.12.2022 kündigen.
Also das war wirklich super knapp.
Wir haben das Vorstellungsgespräch am, keine Ahnung, 10.12. oder so geführt.
Und ich glaube, ich hatte einen Tag vor Weihnachten, ich glaube am 23. oder so, hatte ich den Vertrag in der Post.
Also das war mega knapp alles.
Wirklich mega knapp.
Ich habe doch jetzt noch ein Video gehabt hier letztens.
Warte mal, ich hab doch sogar gesagt
Morgen letzter Arbeitstag
Ich habe gekündigt, genau
So, hallo Leute hier
Und das war am
30.12.
Leute, bis 31.12.
Hätte ich es abgeben müssen.
Das war wirklich auf den Tag, wo das geklappt hat.
Ohne Scheiß.
Übrigens auch geil, wenn man sein Leben anhand von YouTube-Uploads nachvollziehen kann, oder?
Das war wirklich super knapp.
Ja, so lief mein Vorstellungsgespräch.
So lief mein Vorstellungsgespräch.
Also.
Ich bin nicht der Beste, wenn es um Bewerbungsverfahren und sowas geht.
Bisher, egal wo ich war, war das super easy.
Bewerbung, also Ausbildungsplatz, hingegangen, ein bisschen gelabert mit denen, Tag später Anruf, wir nehmen dich.
Okay, Ausbildung fertig, kurz vor der Ausbildung mit denen gesprochen, ja, wir übernehmen dich, so und so und passt alles, ja gut, übernommen.
Dann gewechselt zur Bank, gesagt, ey Max, wir wollen dich übernehmen da vom Provider, willst du nicht zu uns? Ja doch, okay, passt.
Zur Versicherung, Vorstellungsgespräch, ja okay, passt. Ich bin da echt nicht der Beste, wenn es um irgendwelche Bewerbungsverfahren und sowas geht.
Ein Vorteil hatte das Ganze aber, und das muss man tatsächlich auch mal sagen, dadurch, dass ich quasi schon einen neuen Vertrag in der Tasche hatte, bin ich super entspannt in das Vorstellungsgespräch gegangen.
Weil ich mir gedacht habe, ob das klappt oder nicht, ist doch wurscht. Versuch das Beste rauszuholen, versuch zu checken, ob die wirklich was taugen oder nicht und wenn das klappt, ist super. Wenn nicht, du hast immer noch, du hast einen Job aktuell, du hast einen neuen Arbeitsvertrag schon in der Post und wenn jetzt noch was besseres rauskommt, ja umso besser.
Also ich bin da super entspannt ins Vorstellungsgespräch gegangen
Und das lief dann auch gut
Also das war schon echt
Es ist schon alles echt glücklich gelaufen
Und um da noch eins oben drauf zu setzen
Ein ehemaliger
Das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt
Ein ehemaliger Kollege von mir
Also vom alten Arbeitgeber
Der hat ja auch einen neuen Job gesucht
Und ich habe bei meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber
Auf der Homepage gesehen
Die suchen noch einen zweiten Linux-Kenner in einem anderen Team.
Die suchen noch einen anderen Linux-Kenner bei einem anderen Team.
Und dem seine Bewerbung habe ich zu meinem Vorstellungsgespräch mitgenommen.
Und habe es meinem damaligen Chef in die Hand gedrückt und habe gesagt,
hier guck mal, ich habe doch auf der Webseite gesehen, ihr sucht noch jemanden.
Ich kenne da noch jemanden.
Und den haben sie dann auch eingestellt
Das heißt, mein ehemaliger Kollege ist auch wieder mein neuer Kollege
Und ich hab dafür sogar noch
Mitarbeiter werden Mitarbeiter
Premium Bonus gekriegt
Obwohl ich noch nicht mal zu dem Zeitpunkt
Mitarbeiter war
Hab ich Mitarbeiter werden Mitarbeiter gekriegt
Also, da muss man echt sagen
Das ist super glücklich
Und top alles gelaufen
Ich bin auch wirklich sehr zufrieden
Also generell muss man sagen
der Arbeitgeber, wo ich jetzt bin, der ist echt gut, die Führungskräfte sind auch wirklich gut, also sind die fähigsten Führungskräfte, so im Durchschnitt, würde ich mal sagen, die ich bisher erlebt habe, also man merkt da echt den Unterschied, bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber war es so, da bist du Führungskraft geworden, wenn du nicht bei drei auf dem Baum warst, wenn die welche gesucht haben und dort, wo ich jetzt bin, ist es tatsächlich ein Karriereweg in dem Sinn, ja, also du kannst sagen, ich würde das gerne machen, du machst dann Vorbereitungsschulung und alles mögliche, bis es dann mal wirklich soweit ist und kannst dich auch jederzeit umentscheiden,
also die Führungskräfte sind viel besser.
Also, so mal, durch die Bank weg,
als beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Und das ist echt, echt toll.
Also, finde ich, finde ich wirklich gut.
Ja.
Okay.
Lange genug erzählt.
Programmierst du weiterhin Oldschool
mit Stack Overflow? Ne.
Ja, den Stackoverflow gucke ich natürlich immer noch ab und zu, ja.
Oder benutzt du CodeX à la Vibe-Coding?
Ich bin mittlerweile gefühlt abhängig von denen, man gewöhnt sich zu sehr,
habe das Gefühl, dass man dabei weniger selbst lernt als früher mit Stackoverflow.
Ich mache halbe, halbe.
Also, was ich nicht mache, ist komplettes Vibe-Coding.
Ich glaube, dafür macht mir das Programmieren auch zu viel Spaß.
Und ich habe dann am Ende irgendeine Codebase vor mir,
die zwar funktioniert so halbwegs,
aber ich absolut nicht verstehe und spiel immer schwieriger wird was zu erweitern ja also vielleicht
erinnert morpheus warum plötzlich alles china chinesen 40 minuten da habe ich was zu tun also
das mache ich nicht ich mache kein komplettes vibe coding wie gesagt dafür programmiert zu
gerne ich will auch keine codebase haben wohl keiner mehr durchblick nicht mal mehr die ki
Irgendwann das alles fixen ich mache das halbe halbe also ich proklamiere was
Und zur unterstützung ziehe ich kai ran
Verschieden in verschiedene sachen ja zum beispiel wenn ich irgendwas
Immer mal zum beispiel weiß ich habe ich habe hier überhaupt schon mal jemals irgendwas drauf gebastelt auf dieser kiste
Also die de domains gab bei uns keine probleme weil es war nachts und morgens ging es wieder
Okay, wir haben auf dieser Linungskiste noch nichts gemacht.
Also insofern kann ich euch nichts sagen.
Zumindest, was will das denn?
Was ich bei KI ganz gerne mache, ist zum Beispiel zu fragen, ey, guck mal, ich habe hier eine Funktion in Go.
Wie würde ich das in C Sharp machen?
Oder würde ich das in Rust machen oder sowas, ja?
Oder fällt dir noch ein besserer Weg ein, dieses Bash-Skript schöner zu schreiben?
Solche Sachen frage ich gerne in KI.
oder ich frage dann auch mal ganz gerne nach so, ey, ich würde gerne mit Library XY das und das ansprechen.
Oder gibt es Alternativen, ja, zum Beispiel sowas wie, kennst du eine Alternative zu Rich in Python in Rust, sowas nach dem Motto.
Das gucke ich mal ganz gerne. Also ich benutze das als Unterstützungstool.
übrigens das ist kompletter blödsinn was das ja auspuckt aber da kann die ki
nichts für weil es gibt leider nichts gescheites in rust was eine alternative
zu spektr console oder rich wäre kann die ki nichts für so was mache ich ganz
gerne komplettes vibe coding mit ich lasse den agent für 15 stunden laufen
oder mehrere agents für 15 stunden laufen mache ich nicht bin ich auch kein
großer fan von ja ich kenne die ganzen videos auf youtube so nach dem motto
ich schippe mehr als ich jemals gemacht habe ich bin produktiver als ich jemals
gemacht habe ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob die auch qualitativ so hochwertige
sachen schippen wie sie jemals geschickt haben da habe ich meine meine bedenken
und ich habe auch meine bedenken wenn das was ist was du länger benutzt als
wir hauen neuen service raus und gucken mal ob das gut ankommt wenn du was hast
was du vielleicht auch längerfristig weiterentwickeln will, dann weiß ich nicht, ob reines Vibe-Coding so die beste Variante ist.
Da würde ich sagen, die Kombination aus von Handprogrammieren mit KI-Unterstützung ist langfristig das zukunftsfähigere Modell.
Und so mache ich es auch.
Warum sollte ich was machen, was ich selbst für blödsinnig halte?
Und man darf nicht vergessen, bei KI kommt teilweise richtiger Bullshit raus.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist immer das hier.
Also das wollte ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen.
Aber warum ist das so ein uralt Post?
Air Media.
Katzi, Katzi.
Die war heute Morgen übrigens wieder da.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Äh, ups.
Wo ist denn mein Chattorino hin?
Das glaube ich nicht.
In 10 Jahren schreibt niemand mehr Code, selbst das glaube ich nicht.
Das wird nicht so sein.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass irgendwann nochmal eine große Aufräumwelle kommt.
Wenn die Leute ihre 3-4 Jahre vibe-codete Anwendungen langsam zerbröckelt.
10 Jahre schreibt niemand mehr Code selbst.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
das okay chat chat wir machen mal eine umfrage was was ihr denkt kann ja auch sein dass ich
komplett falsch liege ja schreibt in zehn jahren keiner mehr code selbst fragezeichen ja nein
Nein. Gucken wir mal, was der Chat dazu denkt.
Also wie gesagt, das glaube ich nicht.
nach zehn jahren zerbrockelt auch normal geschriebener code also zumindest noch die
chance zu verstehen was abgeht außerdem wenn du was wenn du was gescheites hast ist das zwar
es lässt sich nicht vermeiden dass es paar wildwüchse gibt aber guck dir mal köln an
köln wird seit wieviel jahrzehnten gemain taint gut ich weiß nicht wie ich
weiß nicht wie ordentlich köln ist du kannst ja auch sagen code gescheit okay
make no mistakes think extra hart dann ist alles okay kein problem
Okay, also die meisten Leute denken nein, ein paar denken ja.
Okay.
Oh ja.
Schauen wir mal.
Kanister Koppel schreibt, bei meinem letzten Einstellungsgespräch wollten die am Ende von mir, dass ich deren ZFS-Backups bereinige.
Ohne Vertrag bei was passieren...
Oh, das ist natürlich...
Auf der einen Seite ist es ja cool, wenn man das Gefühl hat, es kommt richtig gut an, dass man voll was drauf hat.
Aber das ist schon echt etwas merkwürdig.
Das heißt, am Ende, du bist dann auch der einzige Typ, der da irgendwie Ahnung hat, musst dich um alles kümmern.
Klingt auch nicht gerade so toll.
Das ist auch das Beste. Das ist ohne Scheiß, das ist das Beste.
empfehlung von kollegen oder ex kollegen von neuen abend ist das beste für dich und das für
die arbeitgeber weil es empfiehlt ja niemand jemand den du nicht im team haben willst ja
also sprich das spricht schon mal dann auch von sich das arbeitgeber ist dafür okay da passt
wahrscheinlich bei uns ins team und umgedreht wenn den einmal der kollege von dem du was hält sagt
ey guck mal willst nicht zu uns heißt ja auch für dich okay da laden kann nicht ganz so schlecht
sein ist das normal in frankfurt dass man 100k verdient das kann ich nicht bestätigen nein in
frankfurt ist das wahrscheinlich auch nicht normal wo gerade dabei ich habe letztens bei
kunu gesehen kann man jetzt von halten was man will bestbezahlte branchen nach branchen und
Die schreiben, dass Versicherungen und Banken auf Platz 1 sind.
Also in Frankfurt, Finanzbranche, beziehungsweise gerade Versicherungen und Banken, Versicherungen und Bankenbranche, da gibt es ordentlich Kohle zu holen.
Und das kann man jetzt nicht so sehr mit, keine Ahnung, irgendwie im Osten auf dem Land oder so vergleichen.
Versicherungen und Banken, also ich habe da schon echt ganz schön viel Glück, dass ich hier in der Region wohne, weil nicht nur Versicherungen und Banken bezahlen am meisten, nein, auch noch in Frankfurt Versicherungen und Banken, also das ist schon echt ordentlich.
Hast du auch andere Lebenshaltungskosten in Frankfurt?
Das Zeug ist hier schon ganz schön teuer
Aber
Ich finde es geht
Also was ich halt nicht mehr mache ist
Ich gehe beispielsweise
Selten nur noch irgendwie
Essen oder so
Weil dann kriegst du irgendeinen Mini-Burger
Mit Pommes Frites für 12,50
Oder sowas
Es gibt in Frankfurt nur noch ein Laden, also außer unserer Kantine.
Es gibt in Frankfurt nur noch ein Laden, zu dem ich regelmäßig essen gehe.
Und das ist der hier.
Mittags, Mittags, Mittagsmenü.
She King Frankfurt.
Das ist so geil, das Zeug, Leute.
Das ist Korean Fried Chicken.
Das ist ein Mittagsmenü da, genau.
Du kriegst eine Portion Reis.
Ähm.
Fried Chicken mit
scharfer Soße, ein bisschen Salat
und Krautsalat dabei. Und du kannst dir
für 2,50 noch ein Getränk
dabei holen. Das ist kein KFC.
Das ist Korean, das ist was anderes.
Das ist Chicken.
Viel weniger fettig und viel besser als
KFC, finde ich, meiner Meinung nach.
Mein Tipp ist,
nehmt euch kein Getränk beim Mittagessen
dabei, holt euch für
1,50 noch ein extra
Reis dabei.
Dann bezahlt ihr nämlich am
Ende, ich weiß nicht, ob man das hier erkennt.
Guck mal. Mittagsmenü
10 Euro.
Ich glaube, das ist immer noch so.
10 Euro, das heißt, ihr bezahlt
11,50 Euro hier mit einem
extra Reis.
Ah, hier oben.
Das ist eine andere Karte hier.
Extra Reis 1,50.
Das heißt, ihr bezahlt 11,50 Euro, ihr bekommt das Mittagsmenü plus einen zweiten Reis, davon seid ihr richtig gut satt und schmeckt mega nice. Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Und ansonsten muss man sagen, ich bin in letzter Zeit tatsächlich ein bisschen darauf gucken, meinen Fleischkonsum einzuschränken.
Erstens, also bei mir ist es jetzt weniger aus tötest du noch Tiere und sowas, sondern eher aus Gesundheitsgründen.
Weil ich habe vor nicht allzu langer Zeit einen Artikel gelesen, dass zu viel Fleischkonsum das Krebsrisiko erhöht.
Da habe ich mal überlegt, okay, du frisst schon relativ viel Fleisch.
Eigentlich muss das gar nicht sein.
Und seit ein paar Wochen futter ich deutlich öfters bei uns in der Kantine die Vegetarier- bzw. veganen Options und Salat.
Aber ich esse auch immer noch Fleisch
Aber dann meistens mit wenig
Also das einzige was ich diese Woche
Wirklich mit Fleisch
Mit einer größeren Menge Fleisch gegessen habe
Ist gestern und heute
Nudeln mit Hackfleisch
Und Tomatensauce
Da kam insgesamt glaube ich
150 Gramm oder so Hackfleisch dran
Aber man soll ja in der Woche unter 300 Gramm
Fleisch bleiben
Und das müsste ich diese Woche gut gepackt haben
Das versuche ich gerade.
Heute gibt es Nudeln,
nicht Nudeln mit Reis,
Nudeln mit Hackfleisch.
Tomatensauce.
Was ist die bestbezahlten Berufe in Deutschland?
Okay, zeig mal her.
Wirtschaftsprüfer. Ja, wer hätte das gedacht, Alter?
Ey, Leute, die Wirtschaftsprüfer,
die müssen sich bei uns
so krass die goldene Nase verdienen.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Wir haben permanent Horden von irgendwelchen Beratern und Wirtschaftsprüfern bei der Versicherung am Start.
Die müssen allein schon von uns reich werden.
ITI Pilot, Arzt, Medical Advisor, Programmer, Solution Architekt, Professor, Software Architekt.
Dann würde ich gerne wissen,
wie man als normaler Arbeitnehmer,
man muss was machen, was gefragt ist auf jeden Fall.
In einer Branche, die gut bezahlt
und man muss halt nicht,
also man muss nicht nur was machen, was gefragt ist,
man muss halt auch so viel können,
dass es da jetzt nicht an jeder Ecke was gibt
von Leuten, die das können.
Klar, in Frankfurt und München sind die Gelder höher,
da kostet auch alles mehr, aber 100k sind selbst
100k ist viel, ich sag da
überhaupt nichts dazu.
Das ist richtig viel Kohle.
Aber wenn ich die Auswahl habe, nehme ich lieber mehr oder weniger Kohle, warum sollte ich weniger nehmen?
Aber das ist richtig viel Kohle, ich sage ja gar nichts.
Ich rede das jetzt ja irgendwie nicht klein, so nach dem Motto, ah, das ist aber gerade an der Schmerzensgrenze oder so.
Nee, nee, das ist richtig massig Geld.
Das sage ich gar nichts.
Was ich verstehen kann, ist, wenn man Wissen in einer Nische hat, der gefragt ist, aber der ist wenig sexuell am Mitklasse.
Also ich bin kein Defop, ich war beim alten Arbeitgeber, war ich tatsächlich Senior Defop Engineer.
Jetzt bin ich Senior Linux Engineer, wobei, Leute, das stimmt ja auch nicht mehr.
Ich bin ja gar nicht mehr Senior Linux Engineer.
Ich bin ja mittlerweile, weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich es schon bin oder ob ich es, zumindest unsere Jobs werden ja umbenannt.
Ich bin jetzt Senior Site Reliability Engineer.
Ich mache nichts anderes wie vorher.
Die haben sich nur gedacht, unsere Jobbezeichnungen sind zu alt, die benennen uns jetzt einfach um.
ich mache nichts anderes wie vorher heißt es nur anders weil sie sich
gedacht habe seligen linux engine das klingt zu old school site reliability
engineer das ist es woher diese differenz kommt ich kann dir sagen woher
die differenz bei uns kommt bei dem job den ich habe kann ich dir sagen also die
richtig viel in der so diese richtig viele kohle so diese bis bis zu 140 k
kriegst du ja wegen bonus ja und wegen rufbereitschaft also ein nicht
unerheblicher teil des gehaltes ist rufbereitschaft und das liegt einfach
daran dass ich mal irgendjemand überlegt hat ey guck mal wir haben hier systeme
für beispielsweise handel an der börse oder irgendwie welches anderes kram ja
oder sei es jetzt auch nur irgendwelche filialen oder außendienststellen oder
sowas ja da hat sich irgendjemand mal überlegt okay wenn dieses bestimmte
systeme ausfallen dann verlieren wir ich sage jetzt mal irgendeine fiktive zahlen
dann verlieren wir fünf millionen pro stunde
ja man manchen sachen gibt es ja auch vorgaben und du musst tatsächlich das
innerhalb von einer gewissen zeit fixen sonst musste strafe bezahlen und alles
mögliche sagen wir mal irgendjemand hat ausgerechnet
guck mal wenn wenn bestimmte systeme weg sind kostet und das fünf millionen pro
stunde so das heißt wenn wir da ein hinsetzen und den ordentlich bezahlen so dass der innerhalb von
maximal einer stunde reagieren kann und das system in der stunde oder zwei wieder ans laufen kriegt
anstatt dass es zehn stunden oder fünf stunden dauert dann hat sich das schon gelohnt selbst
wenn der nur einmal in zehn jahren was fixen muss hat sich schon gelohnt
das hat sich da jemand mal ausgerechnet deswegen gibt es so viel geld für
und das ist auch der grund warum wir so viel geld ich sage ich sag nicht dass
es gerecht ist beziehungsweise okay ist ja aber das ist auch der grund warum wir
so viele Kohle in Popo geblasen
kriegen und
irgendwelche Leute im Altersheim
für ein Appel und ein Ei arbeiten.
Weil bei uns
kostet die Stunde
Ausfall 5 Millionen.
Im Altersheim, die Opas, die kosten
nur Geld. Wie gesagt,
ich sag nicht, dass das okay ist.
Ich sag nicht, dass das schön ist.
Aber da hat jemand mal durchgerechnet
und hat gesagt,
ey, guck mal,
5 Millionen die Stunde,
da setzen wir uns mal lieber jemand hin
und blasen dem Geld in die Pobbes,
dass das schneller gefixt ist
und wir sparen Kohle.
Das ist so.
Das haben die sich halt
ausgerechnet.
Und ganz ehrlich,
für die Millionen
und wahrscheinlich sogar Milliarden,
die da rumhantiert werden,
ist das halt ein paar Leute
hinsetzen und 100k plus im Jahr
bezahlen immer noch nicht die welt ist das bei dir so der fall ja also wir
haben ein system was unter anderem mit börsenhandel zu tun hat und wenn das
ausfällt das ist glücklicherweise am wochenende nicht so schlimm wenn das
ausfällt kostet das wirklich millionen pro stunde
Das ist so.
Tja.
Ich finde das auch jetzt nicht wirklich fair und gerecht,
wenn ich sehe, was wir verdienen versus jemand, der im Altersheim arbeitet.
Das will ich gar nicht sagen.
Das ist irgendwie...
Dass ich das voll unterschreiben könnte oder so.
das finde ich auch nicht aber aus sicht von leuten die das entscheiden ist das halt kritischer weil
da hängt richtig geld dran der opfheim aus dem altersheim den interessiert keiner leider wie
genau darf ich mir das vorstellen musst du dann überall ein laptop mit hinnehmen ja wenn ich
rufbereitschaft habe und irgendwo hinfahren muss man laptop mitnehmen
also ich hab ich habe reaktionszeiten wenn ich es schaffe innerhalb der
reaktionszeiten bei mir daheim wieder im arbeitszimmer oder am rechner und
eingeloggt zu sein kein problem wenn ich jetzt sagen wir mal irgendwo hin fahr
oder so dann muss ich mein laptop nehmen und muss gucken dass ich dort ordentlich
das internet habe also man könnte natürlich auch sagen ich nehme ein
firmenhandy mit und lockt mich dann da per hotspot irgendwie über mobile ein
will man wirklich wenn man dann irgendwie auch oben keine ahnung oben
auf dem feldberg sitzt will man wirklich dann einem laptop mit mobilfunk
verbindung da irgendwas arbeiten und fixen ich glaube nicht da willst du
daheim sitzen im büro mit ordentlichen headset auf weil er ist natürlich auch
angerufen und muss Status abgeben und alles mögliche.
Und, äh,
also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich Rufbereitschaft hab,
auch am Wochenende,
dann, ähm,
schau ich, dass ich
nicht weit weg von zu Hause
gehe.
Äh,
öffentliche Cafés, du kannst das theoretisch
machen. Wir haben ein paar Policies,
was du nicht machen darfst,
wenn du in öffentlichen Bereichen
bist.
Du darfst zum Beispiel kein Screensharing von anderen Leuten dir angucken und sowas.
Und ich glaube, du darfst doch nicht selbst Screenshare?
Ne, ich glaube, du darfst dir kein Screensharing angucken von anderen Leuten.
Aber es gibt ein paar Sachen, die du nicht machen darfst.
Das heißt, wirklich im öffentlichen Bereich, wenn du im Café sitzt, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher,
ob du, äh, ja, äh, regelkonform überhaupt arbeiten könntest.
Aber das mache ich eh nicht.
Also, wenn ich Rufbereitschaft habe, übers Wochenende, dann gucke ich, dass ich, äh, nicht weit weg bin.
Wie oft hast du Rufbereitschaft im Jahr? Belaste das teilweise privat?
Ja.
Ja, ja, also das schränkt schon ein.
Also ich habe, also wir haben es ja so über das Team verteilt, dass jeder ungefähr gleich viel hat.
Das ist ungefähr so, also wir haben mehrere Sachen.
Wir haben einmal Rufbereitschaft und wir haben Anwesenheits- bzw. Erreichbar- also wir haben Pflichterreichbarkeitszeiten und Rufbereitschaftszeiten.
in den Zeiten, wo du verpflichtet bist, erreichbar zu sein,
das ist dann, ich sage jetzt einfach mal eine Zeit, 7 bis 19 Uhr, sagen wir jetzt mal,
da muss immer jemand vom Team da sein.
Und muss auch direkt drangehen.
Das ist nicht so nach dem Motto, du hast zwei Stunden Zeit zu reagieren.
Nein, da wird erwartet, wenn das klingelt, dass du drangehst.
So, sagen wir mal von 7 bis 19 Uhr.
Und wir haben das so eingeteilt.
einer macht vormittags,
einer macht nachmittags.
Also quasi von 7 bis 12
und andere von 12, 12.30 Uhr
bis 19 Uhr, so in dem Dreh.
Doch, ist bei uns aber so.
Ist bei uns so. Es ist einer
fest zuständig, dass wenn Anrufe
reinkommen, weil irgendwas kaputt ist oder weil
irgendwelche Inzidenz aufgehen
oder sonst was, der kümmert sich
drum und der guckt dann auch, der kümmert sich
auch drum auf system xy läuft die platte zu so so daily admin sachen habt ihr ein leitstand modell
näher wenn ich habe nur zu bestimmten anlässen wenn größere größere arbeiten sind ja also bei
uns guckt dann beispielsweise von 7 uhr bis 12 uhr 30 guckt einer auf die ganzen sachen und der
muss dann auch wirklich erreichbar sein und du musst dann auch sieben uhr vom rechner sitzen
schon und dann einer der bis 90 und er muss dann auch bis 19 uhr vom rechner sitzen und danach
übernimmt die rufbereitschaft und die muss innerhalb von zeitpunkt x einsatzbereit am
rechner sitzen also das schränkt schon ein so wie oft habe ich das also machen wir mal diese diese
nennen wir es mal früh und spät schicht vormittags das lassen wir jetzt mal weg das teilen wir uns
wir teilen uns das aber alle also wir teilen uns sowohl frühschicht spät schicht als auch
Rufbereitschaft verteilen uns da so im Team ein, dass jeder ungefähr das gleiche hat.
Ich persönlich bin jemand, der gerne früh, früh, vormittags den Dienst macht.
Das heißt, ich bin meistens relativ oft vormittags eingeteilt.
Ich habe kein Problem mit früh aufzustehen.
Ich habe aber keinen Bock bis 19 Uhr da zu bleiben.
Also das teilen wir uns so ein bisschen nach Vorliebe.
Rufbereitschaft gucken wir, dass ungefähr jeder dran muss.
Ich würde sagen, im Durchschnitt ist das so, jeder vom Team hat einmal im Monat,
einen Wochenende Rufbereitschaft
und dann
boah, variiert so ein bisschen
noch so
5, 6
5, 5, 5, 6 Tage
5 Tage ungefähr
nachts unter der Woche
Rufbereitschaft
so irgendwie
oder da vielleicht auch nicht
4 Tage, 4 Tage
ja das heißt du kommst so auf 6, 7
Tage im Monat Rufbereitschaft.
Wurde dann aber auch wirklich in Zeit X
egal wann,
also auch nachts um drei
oder auch sonntags, mittags,
wenn die Leute gerade Fahrradausflug
machen oder was auch immer,
da musst du innerhalb von Zeit X
ready, eingeloggt, mit Headset auf,
vorm Rechnen sitzen.
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ich scroll gleich nochmal durch.
Das musst du dann machen.
Also das schränkt schon ein bisschen ein.
So ist es nicht.
Ich habe letztens Rufbereitschaft über Ostern gemacht.
Und Leute, das hat massive Kohle gebracht.
Rufbereitschaft über Ostern heißt ja, ab Donnerstag 19 Uhr bis Dienstag 7 Uhr.
Weil das ist ja quasi die Nacht auf den Freitag.
Dann Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag, Montag.
und dann die Nacht auf den Dienstag
bis die Früh ist. Das sind quasi
Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag,
Montag Feiertage.
Feiertage gibt nochmal extra Kohle.
Ähm,
und dann noch die zwei Nächte dabei.
Also sind quasi
fünf Nächte.
Stimmt das?
Das gibt
richtig Kohle.
Aber es war halt auch so, ich konnte an Ostern
nichts machen.
Ich hab nichts gemacht.
an Ostern. Kein Fahrradausflug
oder irgendwas.
Das höchste der Gefühle war,
dass ich immer eine Runde gejoggt bin,
sodass ich gleich wieder umdrehen kann und innerhalb von ein paar Minuten
daheim bin. Also im Kreis gelaufen.
Ich konnte an Ostern halt nichts machen.
Max, wann ist das nächste Mal Bereitschaft?
Ich weiß nicht, wann ich das nächste Mal
Bereitschaft habe. Keine Ahnung,
habe ich habe ich nicht nicht im kopf
was bekommst du netto für den wochenende rufbereitschaft 500 euro ungefähr 400
400 euro 450 euro so irgendwie dem dreh
Ja, so 400, so 400 Euro, 450 Euro, würde ich mal so drauf tippen, ungefähr.
Oh, Max, ja, ich habe es letztens im Stream sogar schon gesagt.
Du musst ja noch dein Nas kriegen.
Ja, ich bin zu sehr im MMO-Kreisel-Crime.
Okay, Lars, ich scrolle jetzt mal die Fragen durch.
Falls ich deinen übersehe, sag nochmal Bescheid.
Der Kollege hat auch Vermittlungsprovision für mich gekriegt.
Jaja, auf jeden Fall.
Ach hier, guck mal, da sind wir doch schon.
Ich habe bald eineinhalb Stunden Vorstellungsgespräch für Junior-Linux-Position.
Hast du Tipps, was man zu erwarten hat, außer sich auf einen Server zu SSHen?
Ich hatte bisher noch nie so ein Interview und ich frage mich, was in der Zeit bespricht.
Tja, so wie ich das vorhin erzählt habe, meine Vorstellungsgespräche waren immer ziemlich kurz und knackig.
Irgendwelche Übungen mit Leuten, die mir über die Schulter geschaut haben, musste ich nie machen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Chat, vielleicht habt ihr da irgendwelche Vorschläge, was er sich im Vorfeld angucken kann.
Der Lars, ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, du wirst da so die Basics-Sachen gefragt.
Wie kommt man aus Wim raus? Wie würden sie unter Linux Webseite hosten? Wie würden sie unter Linux den Login absichern? Wie stellen sie sicher, dass ein User nur Dateien löschen kann in dem Verzeichnis?
irgendwie so Standard-Linux-Dinger.
Ehrlich gesagt, habe ich aber keine Ahnung.
Chat, vielleicht
habt ihr eine Idee, was in so
einem Interview und Fragen drankommt.
Also, es scheint
ja ein Interview zu sein mit so
Hands-on-Testing-Sachen.
Oder besser gesagt,
Lars, weißt du denn,
dass das was ist mit Tests,
wo die wirklich dir zugucken wollen?
Oder vermutest du das?
Weil vielleicht wollen die einfach nur mit dir
quatschen.
also hätte okay ja da habe ich leider keine großartigen tipps für was du machen könntest
ist was sicherlich zum üben nicht verkehrt ist also set servers schon mal gemacht da gibt es
da gibt es die lux server übung die du machen kannst im vorfeld vielleicht sind da ist den
Szenarien dabei,
wo die dich auch mit nerven.
Also ich habe versucht,
meinen Chef dazu zu überreden, dass wir uns
einen Set-Servers-Premium-Account
kaufen.
Für solche Fälle, aber haben wir bis jetzt
noch nicht gemacht, weil es gibt auch aktuell
keine Bewerbung bei uns.
Ja.
Was gibt's News vom alten Laden?
Ich hab immer noch regelmäßig Kontakt zu den Leuten beim alten Arbeitgeber. Ich gehe ab und zu mit denen auch mal mittags was futtern.
Aber jetzt irgendwie super spannende neue Sachen, wo man mal eine Runde kekwehen könnte, habe ich nicht gehört.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, als Junior Linux-Admin werden sie dich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht mit ganz den Hardcore-Sachen nerven.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich einfach nur wissen, ob du schon prinzipiell ein bisschen Ahnung von Linux hast.
Logg dich per SSH, also rate ich jetzt mal.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich wissen, logg dich mal per SSH ein, sicher das mal per SSH-Keys ab.
Installier mal Pakete, guck dir in Logs an, wo es Fehler gab.
Vielleicht setzen sie dich auch eine Kiste dran, die manipuliert wurde, so nach dem Motto, hier ist ein Server, auf dem der Web-Server nicht startet, finde raus, warum der Web-Server nicht startet, hier ist eine Kiste, wo ein Port offen ist, schließe den Port mal, hier ist eine Festplatte voll gelaufen mit Log-Dateien oder hier ist eine Festplatte voll, finde raus, woran das liegt, solche Sachen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie für eine Junior-Position jetzt mit ganz abgedrehten Sachen ankommen, wie setze uns ein Kubernetes-Cluster auf mit Argo-CD-Deployment aus einem Git-Repo oder sowas.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ob es irgendwie realistisch oder unrealistisch ist für solche Interviews, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich hatte so ein Interview noch nicht.
Musik
Ja, ich warte auch immer noch auf irgendwelche Flugautos.
Ja, also Burnout-Probleme kriege ich bei mir nicht.
Das ist alles sehr gut geregelt bei uns.
Um da mal zuvor zu beugen.
Zum Beispiel.
Ich möchte das nochmal unterstreichen.
Ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, also ich bin der Meinung, dass wir im Durchschnitt wirklich sehr gute Führungskräfte haben.
Bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber oder neuer Arbeitgeber ist auch gut.
Ich bin ja schon drei Jahre da.
Um das nochmal zu unterstreichen, ja.
Copy-Fail-Patches.
Copy-Fail-Patches hatten wir für einen Service noch offen.
Und ich habe mit den Leuten, die für den Service verantwortlich sind, gesprochen.
Und habe gesagt, ey Leute, wir müssen Copy-Fail patchen.
Wir haben hier harte Deadline bis da und dahin.
Bis dahin muss das gepatcht sein.
Es gibt auch keine Ausrede.
wir müssen das machen haben die gesagt aber dann an den wochentagen und gerade abends laufen noch
wichtige jobs und unter dem tag da müssen die leute da was man ja ja ja ja das geht ja nicht
da haben wir uns darauf geeinigt wir machen copy fail patches sonntag 18 uhr 30 sonntag 18 uhr 30
habe ich seit 18 30 kein thema sonntag 18 30 blog ich mich halt immer kurz ein
macht dann irgendwie auf was sind das 17 18 jenkins ist ja noch dabei oder
jenkins 18 systemen update reboot die und gut ist mache ich kein problem
ich wollte da ich wollte da auch gar nichts groß beantragen führen so habe
ich mir die leute für eine halbe stunde am sonntag 3 scheiß drauf ja scheiß
machen wir einfach gut ist und das hat das hat mein chef mitbekommen und hat zu
mir gesagt max weißt du was fragt die doch mal und sagt ihnen zur not auch ich
habe das gesagt dass sie das gefällig am samstag um 18 uhr 30 machen sollen weil
mir liegt ja auch deine erholung am sonntag am herzen hat zitat von meinem
Chef. Ihm liegt am Herzen,
dass ich mich am Sonntag erholen kann.
Und dann bin ich da hin, hab gesagt,
ey Leute, mein Chef hat gesagt, wir sollen
das gefälligst 18.30 Uhr am Samstag machen.
Dann haben die gesagt, ja, okay,
wir machen das Samstag 18.30 Uhr.
Ja,
Win für den Chef, ne?
Und
was wir jetzt gemacht haben, ist folgendes,
wir haben das einfach per Ansible
gescheduled und ich musste
18.30 Uhr gar nichts mehr von Hand machen.
Und eben...
Und eben habe ich gerade
im Teams eine Nachricht gelesen, dass die
sich irgendwie 23 Uhr nochmal
eingeloggt haben, um zu gucken, ob alles funktioniert.
Ja gut, kann ich ja nichts für.
Ich habe 18.30 Uhr
den Reboot gescheduled.
Und das Patchen.
Also,
das hätte man theoretisch auch Sonntag machen können, aber das war
uns zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht klar.
Ja.
Also da sind die sehr drauf bedacht, sich das anzugucken.
Deswegen sage ich, die Führungskräfte da sind wirklich top.
Mein Chef besonders.
Habe ich ihm auch schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Ich denke mal, als Chef hört man das auch gerne, dass man das gut macht.
Jeder hört das gerne, dass er seinen Job gut macht.
Ist es eher ein junger oder ein älterer Chef?
So in der Mitte.
Ich würde sagen, der dürfte entdecken älter als ich sein.
Also ich wäre dieses Jahr 42.
Ich würde mal sagen, der ist ein Ticken älter.
Aber nicht viel.
Heute keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Ne, heute gibt es Nudeln mit Bolognese-Soße.
Okay, das hatten wir schon.
Wirtschaft früher sind wild, vor allem war ja kein...
Ja, ey, diese ganzen Prüfungen, die passieren ja nicht unbedingt rein, weil die Unternehmen denken, ey, lass uns mal prüfen.
Diese Prüfungen passieren ja, weil es da gesetzliche Vorgaben gibt, dass geprüft werden muss.
Ah, und wie gut das funktioniert hat, bei Wirecard sieht man ja.
Da überlappt viel, ja, das ist so.
wobei ich schon sagen würde also es überlappt sich viel aber es hat schon unterschiedliche
schwerpunkt ja klassische linux sachen linux admin sachen ist ein bisschen was anderes wie
sich um entwickler tools und workflows zum beispiel zu kümmern ja oder sich um cloud
infrastruktur zu kümmern und da hoch verfügbarkeit also es hat sehr viel überschneidung was auch
was auch daran liegt, dass oftmals Leute, die das hier machen, aus der Linux-Ecke kommen und umgedreht.
Aber es hat schon unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte.
Du vermisst die Katzis in der Türkei, kann ich mir vorstellen
Ich hätte auch gerne an jeder Ecke eine Katze
Ich musste bei meinem Job auch ein polizeiliches Führungszeugnis vorlegen, dass ich nichts verbrochen habe.
Ach ja, und was? Eine Sache habe ich noch vergessen. Wisst ihr, was bei meinem Vorstellungsgespräch auch lustig war?
Ich hatte da reingeschrieben, also da stand ja im Lebenslauf, so, ich hab den Lebenslauf ja rückwirkend gemacht.
Also ich hab mit dem Neuesten angefangen und es ging dann runter, so bis zur Schule.
Und irgendwann, nachdem ich damals mit der Realschule fertig war, also zwischen Realschule und Zivildienst,
hatte ich
eine Lücke im Lebenslauf,
Leute, von irgendwie
einem Jahr oder so.
So.
Und ich habe nicht gedacht, dass
es irgendjemand interessiert.
Ich meine,
ihr könnt euch überlegen, wie lang das her ist.
Ich bin 1984 geboren,
das heißt, ich habe meinen Realschulabschluss irgendwann so,
keine Ahnung, 2000
oder so rumgemacht. 1999,
2000 oder irgendwie sowas.
Also wen interessiert es, dass ich
2002 oder so
irgendeine Lücke hatte
von einem Jahr. Aber
der
von HR hat mich dann
wirklich gefragt,
sagen sie mal,
was haben sie denn von, ich sag jetzt einfach mal
2002 bis 2003 gemacht?
Gut, wahrscheinlich wollte er checken, dass ich nicht im Knast gewesen
bin oder sowas.
Was haben sie denn gemacht?
Was haben sie denn gemacht zwischen 2002 und 2003?
Und wisst ihr, was ich damals gemacht habe?
Das habe ich aber nicht gesagt.
Wisst ihr, was ich damals gemacht habe, Leute?
Also erstens habe ich bei meinem Vater im Shop ein bisschen mitgearbeitet.
Das stimmt ja auch.
Als nächstes, was ich da gemacht habe,
MMO-Kreisel-Crime.
Ich habe von morgens bis abends MMOs gespielt
und wollte nichts arbeiten.
Das konnte ich jetzt ja nicht sagen, Alter.
Ich dachte, der hat Love Scam...
Das war davor, wo der Love Scam gemacht hat, mein Vater.
Ja, mein Vater...
Für all die...
Mein Vater hat ein Love Scam Business gehabt, so 1990 rum.
Nur, dass es damals noch keiner Love Scam genannt hat.
Ja, ich habe natürlich nicht gesagt, ich habe von morgens bis abends so vor dem Computer gesessen und MMOs-Kreise grindet.
Aber das habe ich gemacht und ein bisschen in meinem Shop von meinem Vater geholfen.
Und echt mir eine ganze Weile überlegt, was ich jetzt eigentlich machen will.
Äh, hey, ich komme gleich dazu, wenn ich fertig bin.
So, das hatten wir schon.
Hatten wir, hatten wir.
Okay.
habt ihr ein leitstand modell haben wir nicht aber wir haben manchmal ein bisschen größere
wartungsarbeiten die länger dauern und auch über das wochenende oftmals gehen und sowas
es habe nicht oft aber kommt ab öfters mal so was bahn mal im jahr da haben wir so eine
leitstand modell wo quasi so ein koordinatoren team gibt und einer im team kommuniziert mit
den koordinatoren und der mit uns und zum beispiel größere ausfalltests einmal
im jahr da wird dann zwischen verschiedenen
standorten umgeschaltet und das ist immer ein kurs dass das das immer
größere akt da sind da sind ja auch aus jeder abteilung alle teams die server
betreiben daran beteiligt und neuerdings auch cloud umgebung das heißt wird dann
auch geguckt okay wie ist die kommunikation von on-prem server zu
cloud-servern und geht das noch wenn das umgeschaltet und riesenakt
Wieso konntest du nicht sagen, dass du MMO-Cryen hast?
Überleg einfach, wie viel...
Ja.
Ich habe meine Social Skills online ausgebaut.
Oder wie könnte man das nennen?
MMO-Kreisel-Cryen.
Eigentlich ist Rufbereitschaft plus Teilzeit das perfekte Modell.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Wobei ich auch schon Teilzeit beim alten Arbeitgeber gearbeitet habe.
Also ich arbeite ja nur 80%.
Äh, wenn nix passiert, 500 Euro.
Wenn viel passiert, bekomme ich gar nix.
Dann bekomme ich Arbeitszeit, gut geschrieben.
Keck, wait.
Also es ist sogar für mich besser, wenn nix passiert.
Ich liebe dich, Peter.
Gibt es mehr Geld?
Das stimmt. Das ist richtig.
Aber viele Leute, die für ein 90-Minuten-Meeting einladen,
sitzen dann auch stur sinnlos 90 minuten rum und smalltalken und sowas anstatt zu sagen hey leute
wir sind nach 40 minuten schon fertig macht's gut moin max ich will zukünftig arbeitstechnisch ins
linux umfeld eher richtung admin und netzwerk wie würdest du da vorgehen beim lernen wenn du jetzt
gerade nur it umfeld windows system war es also erstmal sehr gute entscheidung gerade was server
sachen angeht und sowas kannst du windows ja komplett knicken ok sag ich als linux fanboy
es gibt natürlich sachen die nach wie vor auf windows laufen ja ganze client windows
kleinen versorgung active directory sachen man kann zwar theoretisch active directory
mit sammler machen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das jemand ernsthaft wirklich machen will
also windows hat seinen daseinsberechtigung aber ich bin der meinung 90 prozent der server wo es
nicht den ganz klaren grund für gibt warum das windows sein muss weil deswegen eine proprietäre
windows kabel ist dann ist es einfach linux gut ist aber fährt mit linux auch in der regel viel
besser wie ist das beste also gibt zwei sachen das erste ist setzt ihr selbst als arbeitssystem
eine linux kiste auf ich meine damit nicht dass du deinen windows rechner ablösen soll ist ja so
ins kalte wasser spring ich installiere linux auf meinem windows rechner und kann ein paar sachen
nicht mehr machen habe probleme ist nichts kauft ihr entweder einen mini pc so wie ich sie habe ich
Ich habe hier einen Mini-PC am Start.
Das ist ein Beelink SR7 mit einem 8-Kern Ryzen und ich glaube aktuell sogar nur 8 Gb.
Kauft ihr einen Mini-PC, installiert den Linux drauf und benutzt den als Daily Driver.
Benutzt Linux täglich für deine Arbeiten.
Damit lernt man enorm viel.
Damit lernst du auch vieles, was du in Server-Systemen brauchst, nämlich um dich auf der Kommando-Zeile zu bewegen.
Und das ist das zweite, was ich sagen würde, was mir gerade noch eingefallen ist. Man ist es ja von Windows gewöhnt, unter Windows wird viel geklickt und in GUIs gemacht. Unter Linux wird 99% und auf Servern 100% über Kommandozeile erledigt. Linux-Kommandozeile ist nicht mit diesem Schrott-CMD-Batch-Kram unter Windows zu vergleichen. Linux-Kommandozeile taucht.
Man darf nur nicht damit rangehen, dass das quasi genauso kacke ist wie unter Windows.
Weil ein ordentliches Shell und ein ordentliches Terminal ist unter Linux meilenweit besser wie unter Windows.
Du musst dich an Kommandozeilen-Usage gewöhnen.
Und das bringt ja auch auf dem Server was.
Das heißt, installiere deine Linux-Kiste und benutze das täglich.
Du kannst deine Windows-Kiste weiterhin benutzen für Windows-Sachen.
Ja, wenn du Thumbnails machst, Videos schneidest, Sachen spielst, Streams, so Sachen, die gut unter Windows gehen, mach die ruhig weiter unter Windows. Das spricht ja überhaupt nichts dagegen. Aber für die Daily-Aufgaben, die du erledigst und die du auch unter Linux erledigen kannst, erledig die einfach unter Linux. Da lernt man wirklich enorm viel.
bist überhaupt noch da nx weil die message ist schon ein bisschen älter aber gut ich
beantworte trotzdem macht und das nächste ist es spricht ja überhaupt nichts dagegen dass du
dich privat ein bisschen beschäftigt mit linux server ja also du kannst auch du kannst dir gibt
es verschiedenste möglichkeiten kann sie raspberry pi holen auch wenn die dinge relativ teuer sind
aktuell kann sie resten kannst den linux mini pc holen kannst dir den nass holen kannst du
einen server bei hetzer mieten für ein paar euro und wobei server direkt im internet vielleicht
nicht zum einstieg so das allerbeste ist kauft den linux kauft den mini pc kauft den raspberry
pi und dann basteln ein bisschen drauf rum hoste ein paar sachen daheim das müssen jetzt nicht
unbedingt sachen seien die du dir wirklich ernsthaft vor hast zu benutzen ja also muss
jetzt nicht sagen ey guck mal ich löse alle meine cloud services durch was lokales ab macht ja auch
nicht unbedingt immer sind ja du kannst dich dann aber zum beispiel
damit beschäftigen wie setzt man vpn auf dass du dich beispielsweise vom handy
lokal einloggen kannst wenn es kauft ihr kauft ihr wenn du dich in richtung
netzwerk beschäftigen willst kauft dir ein mikro tig router mikro tig ist super
zum netzwerk sachen lernen und die dinger kosten auch nicht viel kosten 60
70 euro und du hast und da ist auch in linux darunter aber mit eigener
oberfläche du hast super advanced super advanced oberfläche und du kannst guter
os kann alles irgendwie ja also wenn du dich mit routing protokoll und sonst was
beschäftigen willst so mikro tick ding ist für netzwerksachen zu lernen
wirklich nicht verkehrt dann hast du eine linie last linux mini pc und raspberry pi den mikrotik
switch oder mikrotik router mikro die geräte mit router us drauf und da kannst du dir lokal
wie lands einrichten du kannst dann was bei drei drei nennen was vpn lockt sich von außen von einem
handy beispielsweise per vpn auf der raspberry pi ein das ganze ist schön isoliert in einem
eigenen wlan macht den komplett eigenes wieder nur für deine bastel dinger da bist du auch eine
ganze ecke sicherer unterwegs da lernst du netzwerk lernst du linux du kannst auf deinem
linux system die einen home assistant installieren und bisschen heim automatisierung rumbasteln oder
oder alles mögliche kannst du lokales geht's frontend installieren so kitty oder oder pro
geo oder sowas um deine look projekte lokal zu hosten wie gesagt es ist nix wo du jetzt sagst
ich löse damit alle meine services ab aber es ist sinnvoll nicht einfach nur nach irgendeinem
guide was zu installieren und dann nicht mehr zu benutzen sondern sich was zu installieren was
einem auch was bringt und das dann versuchen möglichst täglich zu benutzen ja zum beispiel
heim automatisierung heim automatisierung ist ein ass ohne boden ja und da kannst du
den kaufst dir linux mini pc installiert der linux drauf benutzt ihn als desktop als daily
desktop neben einem windows pc du kannst du machen wie ich beispielsweise guck mal ich habe hier
windows und ich habe hier linux nebeneinander das ist jetzt ein setup das habe ich bei mir so damit
ich im stream gut verwenden kann das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt ein setup was man lokal
hätte aber du kannst ja zwei monitore anschließen auf eine monitoring der linux mini pc auf dem
anderen monitor dann windows pc oder eben an dem gleichen monitor und dann umschalten das geht ja
ist ja auch kein problem dass du die sachen parallel hast ja oder du machst so wie ich
das eine ganze weile gemacht haben oder installiert er einfach eine vm wobei ich
ehrlich gesagt wenn du wirklich ernsthaft linux lernen willst somit viel gebastelt dabei ist eine
echte hardware gar nicht so verkehrt weil du dich dann auch mit so sachen wie grafikkarten
treibern und system geht kaputt wie fix ich es wieder und wie mache ich pts mit
snapshots und sowas bisschen schöner auseinandersetzen kannst wie mit einer
form wenn du unter linux auch mal was
virtualisieren willst ist das nested in vm wäre unter windows mittlerweile
relativ schwierig also gerade wenn man ernsthaft die sachen lernen will ist es
so eine mini pc nicht verkehrt also kaufst den mikro die drei sachen kauft
ihr einen mikrotik router oder mikrotik switch mit router os kauft den linux mini pc muss auch
kein teurer sein den du als desktop verwendest und kauft den raspberry pi auf dem lokale services
ausprobieren kannst und linux server admin lernen kannst und bau dir damit irgendwas schönes auf was
dir auch was bringt beispielsweise ich kann ich kann heim automatisierung empfehlen heim
automatisierung ist ein fass ohne boden holz den sick be stick holz ihren pass
mate steckdosen kannst automatisieren beispielsweise benachrichtige mich wenn
die waschmaschine fertig ist und so was und machst du dir so ein setup wie ich
mit zwei monitoren hier windows linux aber ist perfekt aufgestellt probierst
einfach alles soweit es gut geht unter linux unter linux zu machen und mit gut
geht meine ich jetzt nicht nur weil du kannst also sachen die halt einfach
nicht gescheit funktionieren unter linux die würde ich nicht unter die nuchs
machen ja wenn du zum beispiel spiele spielen willst die antizip brauchen oder
so das kannst du nicht unter die nuchs machen das würde ich weiter und der
windows machen ich würde nicht sagen ich mache die sachen weiter unter windows
nur weil du noch nicht weiß wie es unter linux geht weil das ist ja gerade der
sinn die sachen unter linux zu lernen ja also sachen die unter linux gehen da
sich durchzufrickeln und durchzubasteln und command line zu basteln so dafür ist
die linux kiste da also das würde ich machen und dann hast du wahrscheinlich schon nach ein
paar monaten mehr ahnung als 90 prozent 95 prozent der weltbevölkerung weltbevölkerung von linux
und kann sich gar nicht vorstellen wie viel es ausmacht täglich eine linux kiste zu benutzen
das tägliche nutzen auch für den desktop betrieb das bringt einem so viel bei was ja auch im server
was bringt du lernst mit bedienung glanz kommando zeilen tools ja du lernst log dateien lesen du
Du weißt, wie man Services neu startet.
Du lernst auch verschiedene OS-Sachen, wie man Packages installiert,
wie man Config-Dateien liest, wie man ein Samba-Share installiert,
wie man einen Web-Server drauf hat, wie man Docker-Container startet, stoppt und solche Geschichten.
Du lernst sehr, sehr viel, was du auch auf Servern brauchst.
Das ist übrigens bei mir auch der Grund, warum ich viele Sachen bei mir nicht sonderlich customised habe.
Guckt mal, meine Wim-Config ist übersichtlich.
übersichtlich da ist nichts großartig kompliziertes trenne warum habe ich das so naja wenn ich meinen wenn ich jetzt in eo wim hätte den super
customised hat mit mit 40 plugins und ich mache den ich mache eine neo wim auf habe ich gar nicht verliebt waren neo wim auf es ist
kloppt erst denn mein neo wim hat überhaupt nichts mit dem normalen zu tun da kann ich ja nicht mehr ich habe alles
customised gemap da kann da finde ich mich mit dem auf dem server nicht mehr am ende dann zurecht
Ja, so sieht's aus.
So, jetzt hab ich ausführlich genug beantwortet, oder?
Jetzt weißt du Bescheid.
Und wenn du was lernen willst über Linux,
kannst du bei mir auch regelmäßig im Stream vorbeigucken,
wenn wir Linux-Zeug basteln.
Das heißt, jetzt am besten direkt follow.
Erstmal Sellout reinhauen.
Natürlich auch alle anderen, die noch nicht gefollowt haben,
das gefällt. Könnt ihr gerne followen.
Und ich hoffe, ich grine ein bisschen
weniger MMO in nächster Zeit und streame
wieder mehr. Wir müssen immer noch unser
Niri richtig einrichten.
Es wird auch mal wieder Zeit für C++
Microcontroller gebastelt, dass ich ein bisschen
schön C++ flamen kann.
Kanisterkoppel sagt, er hat eine Position im DevOps-Bereich und muss mir Uhr als Systeme antun.
Das ist weird, weird champ.
Tja.
Es gibt halt viel Umgebung mit sehr viel Legacy-Krempel.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist,
wir hatten auf der Arbeit,
ähm,
ich glaube, einen Red Hat 4 auf der alten Arbeit.
Ich glaube, das war noch ein Red Hat...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
es war ein Red Hat 6,
glaube ich. Ein Red Hat 6 oder ein Red Hat 5.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, ob es ein Red Hat 5
oder ein Red Hat 6 war.
Ich glaube, es war noch ein Red Hat 5. Richtig, richtig alt.
Da war ein Warenwirtschaftssystem drauf.
Also ein ur, ur, ur altes System.
Und
wenn ihr
Ups.
Ich glaube,
es war noch ein Red Hat 5.
Ja.
Docker run.
gibt es so was gibt es gibt es überhaupt diese dinge ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich
habe glaube ich noch nie ein red hat system gestartet über doch überhaupt nicht gibt es
Na gut, wir können
einmal Linux 9 oder so verwenden.
Ne, einmal Linux heißt das.
So.
ETC Red Hat
Release. So.
Und bei
uns war das so,
das war ein
Red Hat
5 oder 6
ich bin mir nicht sicher, wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, das war ein Red Hat
nee, das war
das war glaube ich ein Red Hat 5 noch
das ist ein ganz ganz altes Warenwirtschaftssystem
so und wenn du da
das war ein Red Hat 5
und wenn du dort ETC Red Hat Release reingeguckt hast
gibt es eigentlich auch einen ETC Alma Release
ah ja
äh, wenn du da in ETC Red Hat
Release reingeguckt hast
da stand dort Red Hat 4 drin
Red Hat Enterprise Linux 4
obwohl es ein Red Hat 5 war
Und wenn du dich eingeloggt hast und die Message of the Day dir angeschaut hast, stand dann da drinnen Red Hat 4 als Red Hat 5 getarnt. Und da musste in ETC Red Hat Release, also Red Hat 5 als Red Hat 4 getarnt.
Weil das Warenwirtschaftssystem, das war so alt, das war irgendwas auf Oracle 9 Basis oder sowas.
Wann kam Oracle 9 raus?
Release Date.
Okay, nee, dann stimmt das nicht.
Es war so alt, dass einer der DBAs noch eine Oracle CD bei sich im Spind liegen hatte.
Also zumindest das Warenwirtschaftssystem ist halt nur auf einer Oracle Version gelaufen,
die so alt war, dass sie nur offiziell Red Hat 4 unterstützt.
Deswegen musste man auf dem Red Hat 5 so tun, als wäre es ein Red Hat 4.
So, das war das älteste System, was wir beim alten Arbeitgeber hatten.
Und das durfte auch nicht eingeschaltet bleiben,
weil das eben Security-mäßig komplett für den Arsch war.
Das war ein System, das wurde immer ausgeschaltet.
Und wenn irgendjemand in diesem wahren Wirtschaftssystem was brauchte,
hat er dann bei uns ein Ticket aufgemacht.
Wir haben das System für eine Stunde eingeschaltet und es wurde hart ausgeschaltet nach einer Stunde wieder.
Das war ganz abenteuerliches Zeug.
Wobei, man muss sagen, bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber haben wir auch noch ein paar richtig alte Dinger.
Da gibt es noch ein paar Solaris-Kisten.
Solaris Linux, äh, nicht Solaris Linux, äh, Solaris UX?
Ne, einfach nur Solaris heißt das, gell?
Die Solaris Unix-Geschichte, einfach nur Solaris.
Da gibt es noch ein paar uralte Solariskisten, wo auch irgendwelche Archivsachen noch drauf liegen, wo sich noch keiner dran getraut hat.
Also was braucht eine Bank ein Warenwirtschaftssystem? Was weiß ich denn?
Auf echte Hardware oder virtualisiert? Virtualisiert.
Glaube ich. Ja doch, muss virtualisiert gewesen sein.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, virtualisiert.
waren wirtschaft fragt mich nicht keine ahnung was sie da drin haben weil ich
was macht ihr eigentlich für dort die fragten wir warten bis es rettet patches gibt
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich denke schon, dass wir potenziell die Möglichkeit hätten zu live patchen, aber wir live patchen
nicht.
Ist das zweite Interview mit zwei Teammitgliedern und ich soll einen SSH-Client ready haben?
Ja, da kannst du dich so auf die Standardsachen, die ich vorhin gesagt habe, wahrscheinlich
einstellen.
hilfe web server startet nicht da musste er musste in log datei gucken was legt ihr starten
man ein service neu sichere mal das login per ssh abmachen wim auf editieren was machen wir
dazu das ist juniore stelle ich wie gesagt ich glaube nicht dass sie um die ecke kommen werden
mit installieren uns ein kombiniertes cluster mit agro cd automatisch und die pläne aus dem
gt pro ja die wollen vielleicht dass ein docker container vielleicht vielleicht wollen die auch
dass ein docker file erstellt docker feier stellst an den container startest bildest
und startest mit docker und im container irgendwas irgendwas ausgibt oder so ja
irgendwelche basics sachen würde ich würde ich war vermuten aber du bist öfters im stream das
heißt du weißt schon mal mehr als 95 prozent der weltbevölkerung über linux
Du machst das easy.
Eats.
Kannst ja mal nächste Woche berichten, wie es war.
Ich sag dir, das wird garantiert
easy.
Wenn nicht sogar
easy as fuck.
Max, hast du Tipps, wie ich meinen
ersten Linux-Job als aktueller Windows...
Das haben wir doch gerade schon.
Habe ich mich doch gerade schon
lange drüber ausgelassen. Hat dir das auch geholfen?
habe ich auch gerade lange drüber ausgelassen bei
Inux
oder ich weiß den Namen nicht mehr genau.
Inux? Irgendwie so.
Der wollte ja auch von Windows zu Linux.
Da habe ich mich lange drüber
ausgelassen.
Ich bin hinten dran mit dem Chat.
Okay.
So.
so
kennst du leute aus dem wirecard umfeld
Also wie gesagt, ich habe es ja ganz am Anfang schon gesagt, ich bin kein großer Fan von Zertifizierung.
Die Zertifizierungsindustrie da hat ein bisschen die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken erfunden.
Nee.
Du auch?
Du hast auch da gespielt früher?
Welcher Server?
Das würde mich jetzt echt interessieren
Server und Realm
Jetzt
ganz ehrlich cloud und sich sich im bereich terraform ansible und mit google oder auch
aws auszukennen ist nicht verkehrt man muss dazu sagen ich habe von aws nicht so richtig
viel Plan. Ich kenn mich ganz brauchbar in Azure
aus und recht gut in Google.
Das Ding ist halt,
die großen Cloud-Anbieter,
die haben mittlerweile so
viele verschiedene Services.
Wenn du bei Google dich mittlerweile einlässt,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob wir uns
hier einloggen können. Ich versuche euch mal ein Screenshot zu zeigen.
Dashboard.
Genau, wenn du das hier mittlerweile ausklappst bei Google,
hier, dieses Menü,
gil neos gil neos ist ein world of warcraft server das kann nicht in der
oxa war sein
albion albion ist aber wenn ihr mittlerweile bei google das ausklappt
das hat da keine Ahnung, 80 verschiedene
Services oder so.
Da kann keiner
hundertprozentig überall den Durchblick haben.
Das vergesst es einfach.
Und jeder Service hat noch verschiedene Sub-Dinger,
wo man sich wieder auskennen muss.
Monka ist halt da, wo wir jetzt hier gelandet.
Also man muss sich da schon
ein bisschen auch so auf einen Service spezialisieren,
wenn man halbwegs Durchblick haben will.
Aber es ist nicht verkehrt.
Also Leute mit
Cloud-Know-How werden auch gesucht.
Du warst bei den schwarzen Templern?
Das ist Stonehenge gewesen, oder?
Stonehenge? Warst du auf Stonehenge?
Ich war auch auf Stonehenge Albion.
Vielleicht kennen wir uns sogar noch von früher.
Lul.
Kann durchaus sein.
Ich sag aber nicht, wie ich in-game hieß.
Weil das ist mir zu gut.
peinlich ich war damals der übelst junge kack spaß so der rum genervt hat
Wie ist denn bei euch die Verantwortung von Entwicklung und Betrieb gehandhabt?
Was meinst du jetzt genau?
Achso, ah!
Ich glaube, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Du meinst, wer bis wohin für was zuständig ist.
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
Bei klassischen Services, die wir haben, ist es so,
Entwickler entwickeln auf ihrer Workstation
oder lassen über CI, CD irgendwas bilden,
dann in die Testumgebung deployen und probieren da aus
und alles danach, also spätestens ab der produktiven Umgebung,
am meisten späteste als eine integration umgebung ist dann deployment über irgendeinen cd workflow
oder aber auch klassisches wir kopieren irgendwelche tars hin oder so gibt es unterschiedliche sachen
aber da ist der betrieb dann komplett bei dem betrieb halt für die kiste und auch die
verantwortung bei neueren services die auf den westen war so er auf ja
vielleicht so er auf infrastructure service aufsetzen also irgendwelche
geschichten die auf dem kubernetes cluster laufen mit kassen resource
definitions und sowas dort können die entwickler das selber machen also
sprich da gibt es ein team die betreiben nennen wir es mal plattform kubernetes
Service
und wenn jemand eine
Service-konforme Standard-Anwendung hat
mit so einem Standard-Stack, so nach dem Motto
ey, wir hätten gerne einen Ingress
mit der und der Domain
und wir hätten gerne
dass das
eine Java-Anwendung ist, bla bla blub
so, dann können die das selbst deployen
die können dann YAML-Konfigurationen schreiben
es gibt ein paar Custom-Resource-Definitions dafür
mit Crossplane wird das Ganze übrigens gemacht
es gibt ein paar Custom-Resource-Definitions
die müssen entwickler müssen dann beispielsweise eine definition für ihre app anlegen da steht
also sachen drin wie wir wollen postkosten bank und wir wollen reddits haben und wir hätten gerne
eine public ip oder wir hätten gerne da eine interne ipo balancer davor schreiben wieder rein
die plan das und dann macht das crossplane für die da kümmern sich dann die entwickler sowohl
um den betrieb der anwendung als auch um die entwicklung der anwendung der infrastruktur
service unten drunter zu dieser kubernetes cluster und die ganzen sachen die man darauf
braucht so für gateway api die sachen anlegen zertifikatsmanagement mit manager und die kassen
resource definitions für crossplay das macht das jeweilige infrastruktur betriebsteam aber
die anwendungen die drauf laufen da kann man sich dann die entwickler selbst rum soweit ist
in der schönen neuen welt ist das so das ist bei weitem noch nicht bei allen services so und das
wird wahrscheinlich auch nie bei allen services möglich sein aber das ist für so klein kram ist
das wirklich top weil du brauchst keine extra linux server und extra systemverantwortlich und
hast du nicht gesehen für irgendwie eine web server die für webseite die fünf
user verwendet verwenden also das ist gut dass es so einen sammeln
infrastruktur service gibt wo die entwickler machen können was sie wollen
sofern sie sich im rahmen so die standard stacks bewegen sage ich kann
sinnvoll so ist das geregelt bei uns hat man das verstanden
ok
kannst du auf deinem linux server gta 6 spielen auf dem linux server kannst du
schon mal gar nicht spielen weil ich eine grafische ausgabe hast
hast du lust mal die aktuelle lücke im stream zu zeigen oder ist das das kann ich machen nicht
heute, also nicht jetzt im
Aufwachen-Stream, weil wir sind schon
zweieinhalb Stunden drin, wir haben nicht ein YouTube-Video
geguckt und ich muss dann um 12 oder
12.30 Uhr oder irgendwann 13 Uhr auch was
futtern. Aber wir können uns tatsächlich
Copy, Fail und
wie ist das andere?
Frag? Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Irgendwas mit Frag.
Können wir uns mal angucken.
Ja, das ist sogar eine gute Idee.
Welche Möglichkeiten nutzt man aktuell
zur Linux-Client-Verwaltung statt Active Directory?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es gute
Linux-Managed-Clients
gibt.
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer. Wirklich nicht.
Ich war auch nie in der
verlegenheit das machen zu müssen bei uns hat das in der vergangenheit gut
funktioniert weil nur linux pros linux workstation satten also bei mir auf der
alten arbeit hatten wir die lux workstation zusätzlich zur windows kiste
also das waren das war ein laptop und das hat nur linux admins und die konnten
das halt selbst machen linux clients klein management ich habe
Keine Ahnung. Da müsstest du mal in Frankreich fragen. Die machen ja schon viel in Verwaltung und so mit Linux-Clients. Keine Ahnung, wie die das machen.
Früher mit Terminal-Server, so nach dem Motto, alle arbeiten auf einem Server und holen sich nur ihre X-Session rüber, war das sicherlich einfacher wie heute.
Keine Ahnung, wie man gutes Client-Management unter Linux macht. Ob es das überhaupt gibt?
ich habe keinen schimmer
das ist auch nicht verkehrt ja sagt er
es bei also die kombination
raspberry pi mikrotik gerät mit router
os drauf und mini pc für linux
workstation ist top kombination zum
üben und kostet die welt
raspberry pi kostet 50 euro naja 80 euro mittlerweile wohl eher mikrotik switch
kostet 80 euro 300 euro für ein mini pc für nilux workstation
n5r ja das ist von der hardware ist ein gutes nas die netzwerkkarte fangt mich
noch ein bisschen ab ja das ist das ist eine gute kombination cache us dualboot
ja ich bin ja kein großer dual boot fan ich finde beides parallel besser somit
einem linux mini pc und ordentlichen spiel rechner mit mit windows quasi
linux da windows da
widerschneiden und streamen geht unter linux schlechter als unter windows naja
also streamen das geht beides unter linux ja es gibt da vinci resolve für
linux und für alle anderen plattformen und obs funzt unter linux auch ganz gut
ich würde aber trotzdem sagen gerade wenn man eine nvidia grafikkarte hat
funktioniert das potenziell unter windows noch besser
Das war eine Scherzfrage.
Ich habe es trotzdem geantwortet.
Max, hast du dir mal wieder Werkzeug gekauft?
Schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Ich bin eigentlich ganz gut ausge...
Ein VIA Centrofix, das ist so ein Schraubendreher mit Einsätzen für verschiedene Bits, oder?
VIA macht gute Sachen.
Linux Learn, keine KI benutzen, sonst Copy-Paste immer.
Ey, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, das wollte ich ja eigentlich vorher schon zeigen.
Guck mal, zum Thema Linux und KI.
So viele Kazzis.
Zum Thema Linux und KI.
das hat mir chat gpt mal irgendwann letzten monat über vorgeschlagen nie blind cd aber
eine funktion machen die und die die root löscht wenn du kein parameter mit über gibst
m-f wenn dir und dollar 1 weil das erste argument leer ist also wenn du die sache
nur so aufruft dann löscht es dir dein lässt es dir deinen ruf verzeichnis
Also was auch immer sich ChatGPT dabei gedacht hat
Guck
Guck hier, ich leg mal die Funktion an
Und wenn ich jetzt sage, work dir, keckel
Dann macht er slash keckel draus, okay
Aber wenn ich die Funktion aufrufe, ohne Parameter, würde er quasi slash löschen
Also, blind copy-pasten ist immer so eine Sache, die ist nicht so toll.
Du bist seit 35 Jahren der Linux-PSD-Unix-Welt verpflichtet, okay.
Ich mache den Kram so seit 2005.
Also noch nicht ganz so lang.
Nutzt du auch manchmal Nano auf dem Server oder nur Wim?
Nur Wim.
Nano habe ich außer, wenn ich bei meinem Azubi geguckt habe und der hat den Nano rumgewurschtelt, benutze ich nie.
Das erste, was ich mache, ist einen vollwertigen WIM nachinstallieren und die Editor-Defaults umstellen auf WIM.
Welches MMO grindest du? Ich spiele gerade wieder Herr der Ringe Online.
und level 9 ich bin jetzt gerade 62 63 64 irgendwie so und das spiel hat 160
level da werde ich ein bisschen kreisel treiben können
Das gibt es immer noch, ja.
Das kriegt sogar immer noch Add-ons.
Dieses Jahr kommt wahrscheinlich wieder ein Add-on.
Das heißt auf Russisch, wie geht's?
Das kenne ich von zwei ehemaligen Arbeitskollegen, wo wir uns gewundert haben, warum sagen die laufen Kack?
Und dann haben wir die mal gefragt und dann haben die gesagt, wie geht's?
Wir haben immer nur gehört Kack, sind die irgendwie am rumflammern oder so?
Interessiert dich die Branche, in der du arbeitest, Finanzversicherung, oder ist dir das eigentlich egal, beziehungsweise hat wenig Einfluss auf deine Arbeit?
Naja.
Das ist schwer. Boah.
Also.
Ich finde das Umfeld eigentlich ganz spannend.
Moin Patrick, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription.
Huge.
Also, ich finde das Umfeld ganz spannend.
Das ist halt auch super restriktiv.
Also wie viele Vorgaben und Auflagen und was ist da nicht alles.
Gerade bei einer Bank und bei einer Versicherung auch.
was da gibt es teilweise echt nicht normal der bürokratieaufwand ist auch ultra krass also
ich finde das umfeld ganz spannend ja
Es ist jetzt aber nicht so dass ich sagen würde das ist das beste was man sich vorstellen kann
Ansonsten also so sehr interessiert mich die branche in der ich arbeite jetzt nicht also ob ich könnte
Ich könnte auch genauso gut glücklich werden in der, was weiß ich, Autobranche, Chemie, Energie, Rüstungsindustrie, was auch immer.
Sofern es Linux-Kisten gibt und Bastelkram, der mir Spaß macht.
Bei uns ist das genau umgekehrt, schreibt der Pepe Potter.
Server wird zwar von den Infrastrukturteams bereitgestellt, aber Entwicklung, eine Anwendung und Betrieb sind vollständig getrennt.
Der Betrieb wird unter anderem vom Leitstand sichergestellt, der nichts anderes macht als im Grafana zu arbeiten.
So was hatten wir beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Da hieß das...
Irgendwas mit Operation Center hieß das.
Nennen wir es mal einfach Operation Center.
Was ist ein PFM?
Nee, SOC hieß es nicht.
Das wüsste ich.
Irgendwas mit Operation Center.
Der Serververantwortliche, auch der Entwickler?
Die meisten Entwickler haben absolut keine Ahnung
in der Tiefe von Serveradministration.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, ja.
Die besten Entwickler, die ich kenne, die kennen sich auch mit Linux und Servern aus.
Aber der 0815-Jahre-Entwickler, der nur in seine IDE klicken kann und auf alles andere keinen Bock hat, hat absolut keine Ahnung von Linux-Servern.
Wie soll denn das funktionieren?
Gerade wenn die sich wirklich um Server kümmern müssen und nicht ein bisschen Jammel-Definitionen machen und unter der Haube passiert jetzt dann alles.
Die meisten Entwickler kriegen nicht mal einen Docker-File auf die Reihe.
übrigens ich will das jetzt ich will jetzt keine linux admins oder so loben ja die meisten linux
admins admins sind absolut konnten schlechte programmierer die können vielleicht ein paar
zeilen beschritten aber wenn du denen was in go oder java vorsatz sind die komplett lost
und da ist aber auch so die besten leute die ich kenne sind auch gute programmierer sind
beide richtungen so also die besten programmierer bzw entwickler die ich
kenne habe auch ahnung von linux und servern und umgedreht
das liegt aber einfach daran weil die besten leute generell sich sehr auch
für technik und interessieren und sich privat damit auseinandersetzen
2,5 gig gut das reicht ja auch wenn man beispielsweise im desktop nur selbst nur
2,5 Gigahertz.
Bis jetzt
komplett weg von VMware.
Nicht komplett.
Offstream
verwende ich das immer noch.
Und Onstream verwenden wir es ja auch ab und zu noch.
Aber ich bin weg von
meiner Linux-Workstation
für den Stream.
Da bin ich ja auf dem Mini-PC.
Hast du ein Depot bei einer traditionellen Bank oder ich habe einen Neo-Broker.
Weil scalable bin ich.
Was denkst du, was dein Chef verdient?
Keine Ahnung.
Theoretisch, so ungefähr könnte ich es ableiten.
Weil es gibt bei uns im Internet so eine Gehaltsrange-Tabelle.
und ich könnte daran wahrscheinlich auch ablesen, welche Stufe er ist und was er ungefähr verdienen wird.
Keine Ahnung. Interessiert mich aber auch nicht.
Ich habe eh absolut keinerlei Ambitionen, was irgendwelche Führungsverantwortung angeht.
Im Leben nicht. Den Stress würde ich mir niemals geben.
Never. Never.
Chat, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Würdet ihr freiwillig Teamleitung oder sowas machen wollen?
Wäre das was für euch?
oder sagt ihr euch, nee, geht mir weg damit,
viel zu stressig und viel zu ätzend und viel zu weit
weg von der Technik?
Also ich würde es
auf gar keinen Fall machen wollen. Teamleiter
ist auch so eine Kack-Position, ey.
Du kriegst permanent Gemecker von deinen Leuten
aus dem Team ab und permanent
Gemecker von den Leuten oben drüber ab.
Das ist echt eine undankbare Position.
Das liegt aber bestimmt daran, weil man zu faul war, für den Leitstand fähige Leute
einzustellen, oder?
Und was man bei so einem Leitstand auch nicht vergessen darf.
Ich muss da jetzt mal so die, wie heißt das nochmal, die Lanze brechen für den Leitstand.
Die Leute in dem Leitstand, die kümmern sich nicht nur um einen Service, sondern um keine
Ahnung, 400 Services.
Die können bei dem einzelnen Service gar nicht so genau durchblicken, wie das derjenige macht, der sich um den Service kümmert.
Ich war relativ nah dran bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Ich habe im gleichen Büro gehockt wie unser Operations Center.
Ich war da quasi Abgeordneter von uns als vom Linux Team.
ich hab ich hab dort im gleichen büro gehockt mit noch ein paar anderen die von ihren teams dort
waren als direkter ansprechpartner auch wenn was ist ich habe das mitbekommen wie das dort läuft
ja und da waren viele sachen schlecht dokumentiert viele leute haben einfach infos für sich behalten
haben tickets nicht richtig geupdatet haben super geheimnisse um ihre services gemacht haben nie
reingeschrieben was jetzt eigentlich die probleme waren waren super unfreundlich und kooperativ mit
dem operation center und die hatten 400 sonst was services um diese sich kümmern müssen und
oftmals war das monitoring und das observable zeug nicht mehr observable zeug aber richtig
eingerichtet also das ist gar nicht so einfach wie man sich das vorstellt in so einem leitstand
zu arbeiten ich habe das ich habe das live oftmals das elend da mitgekriegt ich hatte zum glück nichts
mit zu tun außer wenn sie zu mir gekommen sind haben gesagt max kann zwar linux mäßig was gucken
oder ich gesagt habe da habe ich doch schon mal was zu gesehen ich helfe euch
mal kurz also ich habe mich mit dem gut verstanden
Ja und als Teamlead ist es auch viel schwieriger Teilzeit zu arbeiten
So Chat wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft
Ich habe den Chat aufgeholt
Das kommt auch ab
Die bekommen auch den ganzen Hate ab
Ja, und da rennen dann auch auf einmal irgendwelche hochrangigen Führungsleute rum.
Wie sieht es denn aus? Wann geht es denn endlich wieder?
Und mein Problem ist das Wichtigste. Wann macht ihr denn endlich was?
Ja gut, das liegt dann aber auch daran, dass ihr nicht die richtigen Leute eingestellt habt.
Also nicht du, ja, du kannst ja gar nichts für.
Du hast ja nicht die richtigen Leute eingestellt worden.
Wer Leute einstellt, die nichts können und keinen Bock haben, muss sich auch nicht wundern, wenn er Leute bekommt, die nichts können und keinen Bock haben.
So, mal gucken, ob es neue Package-Updates gibt. Ganz wichtig.
Oh, ey, Update!
Leute, wir haben jetzt seit zweieinhalb Stunden schon kein Update gemacht.
Da wird es mal Zeit.
Was zum Teufel ist Purpose?
Was ist das?
framework for providing abstractions to get the developers purposes fulfilled
kde ich habe keine egal haben wir installiert hatte jetzt ruhig gut so
erzählt ob aktuell wie gesagt ich werde schon nervös wenn ich dann viertelstunde
keine updates mehr installiert habe das ist mir nicht bleeding edge genug ich
brauche top aktuelle distro package gibt es nicht mehr okay dann versuchen wir
auch wer accounts kummel qml an installen dürfen dürfen wir gut dann
brauchen wir es wohl nicht
ok weiter kommt man mal ein paar videos an
das btf mit snapshots aktiviert jawohl habe ich
so
Die EU wurde in zwei...
Eure... Ah, das gucke ich immer gerne.
Was andere Leute für abgedrehte Heimautomatisierungen haben, das gucke ich immer gerne.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Daniel, hast du jemanden in deinen Schrank eingeschraubt?
Völlige Eskalation bei euch zu Hause, drinnen und draußen.
und wir können wieder einiges lernen und uns vielleicht auch was abgucken.
Ich präsentiere eure Werke von Sci-Fi Zukunft bis Steam Park.
Boah, das sieht ja mal advanced aus, Alter.
Ist das ein Staubsauger?
Oder was ist das hier, was da rausgefahren kommt?
Oder ist das ein Controller?
Was bin ich?
Chat, hat jemand eine Ahnung, was ich hier gerade sehe?
Controllerhalter.
Ah, da kommt dann hier der Controller rein.
Ein Controllerhalter
mit ausfahrbarer
Controllerhalter.
Das ist so krass overengineert, dass es schon eigentlich
überhaupt keinen Sinn hat.
Okay, der Controller wird nicht staubig.
Zukunft
bis Steampunk, von Sauna bis Beat.
In einer neuen Folge
Menschentiere-Automation und dann sagen wir noch...
Moment, Moment, ich muss die Musik ausmachen.
Ich hab noch die Musik laufen.
KI den Kampf an.
Vielleicht, wenn wir mutig sind.
Ich habe mir sagen lassen, dass heute wieder
völlige Eskapaden an Bord sind.
Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Wenn wir mutig sind.
Ich habe...
Da kennt man jetzt nicht so genau.
Das hier ist wahrscheinlich
ein Netzteil für LEDs.
Sind es LEDs? Ja, wahrscheinlich LEDs.
So selbstgebaute...
Ich habe vergessen, wie diese Dinge heißen.
Die sind ultra teuer bei Amazon, diese Kacheln da.
Selbstbau-Variante davon.
Wir lassen es mir sagen, dass heute wieder völlige Eskapaden an Bord sind.
Wir gehen direkt rein.
Wir haben für unser Wohnzimmer ein Akustikelement gebaut.
Und ja, ich weiß, ist jetzt nicht ganz,
was dein Kanal sonst so für Inhalte hat.
Ein Akustikelement.
Heißt das, das kann je nach Musik und Rhythmus und Dingern
unterschiedlich blinken, oder was?
Also ganz grundsätzlich besteht das Akustikelement aus Schallabsorbern aus Schaumstoff in drei verschiedenen Größen, die auf einer Trägerplatte angebracht sind und umlaufend mit einem COB, einzeladressierbaren Stripe.
Wie kommst du auf die Idee, dass das nicht irgendwie die Themen dieses Formats sind? Einzeladressierbare LED versteckt in Akustikpanelen?
natürlich noch deutlich mehr Sachen zulassen, um sich zum Beispiel Statusmeldungen abzurufen.
In der Mitte sieht man, dass die Waschmaschine noch läuft. Cool! Das auch noch gleich als
Mini-Dashboard verwenden. Oben sieht man, dass der Trockner noch läuft und in diesem rechten
Feld könnte man zum Beispiel den Ladezustand des Heimspeichers noch sich anzeigen lassen.
Das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee, das Ding noch so quasi zu, ich nenne es mal Zweck zu entfremden als Dashboard.
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir.
Willst du mich verarschen? Das ist genau mein Ding. Genauso solche Sachen will ich hier sehen.
Also ich mag ja Smart Home Dinge, die im Haus verbaut sind, aber nicht so super offensichtlich daherkommen.
Zum ersten haben wir Lautsprecher eingebaut und zwar zwei Stück, die vollständig ins Heimkino integriert sind.
Sascha, pass mal auf. Du bist sicherlich auch so einer, der früher in der Schule immer gesagt hat,
ich habe bestimmt eine 4 oder 5 geschrieben und dann die volle Buchzahl abzusammeln.
Und hat dann das Beste ever.
Also sowas, Smart Home Komponenten, die nicht als solche sofort zu erkennen sind, spricht mich schon sehr an.
... Audio in einem selbstgebauten 3D-...
Ah, der hat da sogar Lautsprecher am Start.
... gedruckten Gehäuse.
Oh, okay.
Das ist aber auch kein billiger 3D-Druck.
Das ist auch kein billiger 3D-Druck, Leute.
Also hier.
Steinharder, danke schön für den Sub.
41 Jahre.
Exzellent.
Fast so alt wie ich.
Das sieht doch schlecht aus.
Und zum anderen...
Ja, aber der ist nicht billig.
Also bei meinem Drucker siehst du immer...
Gut, der ist auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Meinen 3D-Drucker habe ich 2020 oder so gekauft.
Oder noch älter.
Ich weiß nicht, der ist schon eine ganze Weile alt, der 3D-Drucker.
Der hat richtig deutlich diese Layer zu sehen.
Wollte ich dir zeigen, wie ich die Integration gemacht habe in Lockzone.
Dazu nehmen meine zaubernde Assistentin mal die zwei Serviceabdeckungen ab.
Okay, kein X ist das, oder? Loxon. Kein X.
Kein Home Assistant Gefrickel.
Auch wenn ich Home Assistant Fan bin.
Hat er alles selber gedruckt? Weiß ich nicht.
Würde ich so reininterpretieren, ja?
Auch noch alles ordentlich.
Habe ich jetzt die Spannungsversorgung.
Ist das ein Raspberry Pi? Zero?
Die Einspeisung und die Steuerung.
Ne, was ist das?
Also quasi der KNX-Client dafür, oder was?
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Mit einem LED-Controller von CodeM realisiert.
Was ganz hervorragend funktioniert.
Vago-Klemmen sind doch top.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Warte mal, muss ich mal gucken, was aktuell so 3D-Drucker
ordentlich kosten.
Ja, die sind geil, die Dinger.
Also wenn ich mir heute einen neuen 3D-Drucker
also wenn ich mir jetzt einen 3D-Drucker
kaufen würde, dann würde ich mir auch so ein Ding
kaufen. So eins hier.
So ein Bambulep.
Als ich meinen
3D-Drucker gekauft hab, waren diese
Prusa-Drucker
Sprich mal das Prusa aus.
Prusa-3D-Drucker
voll angesagt.
Prusa
die waren da voll angesagt
damals
und sauteuer
ich hab ja einen anderen
ich hab einen günstigen China 3D Drucker
ich hab einen
i3 Mega S, gibt's das?
Anycubic
ja so ein Ding hab ich
sieht noch deutlich
mehr gebastelt aus
wie das andere Teil.
Wenn ich mir heute einen kaufen würde, dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich
auch so einen kaufen.
Warum kauft man das nicht? Ich habe hier schon öfters
Reviews und Sachen zugesehen, die waren alle begeistert
davon.
Zumindest geht das doch preislich,
wenn das 600 Euro kostet.
Ich glaube, meiner war ein bisschen günstiger.
Aber meiner ist halt auch ein Bastelding im Vergleich zu dem.
Die machen Login-Scheiße, okay.
So viele Möglichkeiten.
Also auch diese
wolkenartige Form.
Du könntest ja auch...
Das sieht auch richtig gut aus,
diese Wand, die er da gebaut hat.
... darüber visualisieren,
indem da so blaue Wolken...
Drucker soll von Cloud abhängig werden?
Okay, dann kaufe ich mir doch nicht.
Also ich kaufe mir auch so nicht,
aber dann würde ich mir auch so nicht kaufen.
Wie du schon gesagt hast,
jeweils Status in den Innenräumen anzeigen.
Du könntest Lade- und Füllstandsanzeigen machen.
so viele Möglichkeiten. Ja, richtig nice.
Ich würde sagen,
das ist wirklich sehr cool geworden.
Sei wie Sascha und sende mir
deine besten Automationen und alle Einsendungen
werden mit einem 50 Euro Amazon-Gutschein
prämiert. Wer eine Spielekonsole im Haus
hat, kennt diese Probleme. Die Controller
liegen überall herum und sind damit eine ständige
Gefahr. Also ganz ehrlich, mein Controller
früher lag einfach immer auf der Xbox
drauf. Die lagen nie im Haus
rum, die lagen immer auf der Xbox drauf.
Weil da war das Play & Charge Kit,
ich kenne das überhaupt noch jemand, das braucht man
ja heute nicht. Heute kannst du ja USB dran machen.
Aber damals, Xbox 360
Play & Charge Kit
gab es damals noch.
Ja.
Da konntest du
quasi dann
aufladen
und hast einen ladefähigen
Akku drin gehabt. Play & Charge Kit hast du
damals gebraucht.
So ein Ding hier. Genau so sah das
aus. Weil da hängt auch das
Play & Charge Kit nebendran.
Das war vor USB-C.
Und vor Micro-USB.
Play & Charge Kit.
Ich benutze den 360-Controller auch.
Der ist super.
Für mich, meiner Meinung nach,
ist das der absolute Peak-Controller.
Für mich gibt es keinen besseren Controller
als Xbox 360-Controller.
Ich habe zum Glück noch drei originale Xbox 360 Controller hier.
Ein Wired und zwei Wireless.
Ich verwende so einen schwarzen Wired, also mit Kabel, Xbox 360 Controller für alles, was ich mit Controller spiele.
Die Dinger sind einfach top.
Mir gefällt der besser.
Ich habe auch noch einen Xbox One Controller.
Mir gefällt der auch besser als den Playstation Controller.
Ich mag die Form seit der PS1 nicht vom Playstation Controller.
Das D-Pad ist kacke.
Das stimmt. Aber wenn ich Sachen brauche, wo ich 2D-Sachen mitspiele und die Pad, wisst ihr, was ich da nehme? Da nehme ich meinen Super Nintendo Controller. Ich habe mir ja vor zig Jahren so einen Adapter gekauft, Super Nintendo Controller auf USB und für alles 2D und Sachen spiele ich mit dem Super Nintendo Controller.
Microsoft Sidewinner, das ist ein Joystick, ne?
Jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst, wie es losging.
Kennt diese Probleme. Die Controller liegen überall herum und sind damit eine ständige Gefahr für den Hausfrieden.
Und wenn man sich einmal der wohlverdienten Runde zocken widmen möchte, ist der Controller leer und muss geladen werden.
Aber gerade dann ist nie das passende Ladekabel zur Hand.
Und überhaupt, es ist 2026, wieso muss man denn da eigentlich immer noch einen Stecker manuell reinfummeln?
Wäre die Welt nicht eine viel bessere, wenn man sich nicht selber darum kümmern müsste, dass die Controller ordentlich weggeräumt werden?
Daniel, hast du jemanden in deinen Schrank eingeschraubt? Weiß nicht, ob ich das gutheißen kann.
Aufladen des Controllers automatisch erfolgen würde und man sich nicht mit USB-Steckern herumärgern müsste.
Und wenn die Playstation bequem per Sprachbefehl gestartet werden könnte und man standesgemäß den Controller...
Ich bin der Deko, die Playstation muss ich per Sprachbefehl starten, dann drücke ich einen Knopf auf den Controller.
Aber ich gette, dass das eine coole Spielerei ist.
Also wie ihr seht, wir leben bereits in dieser besseren Welt und es ist einfach fantastisch.
Wer den gleichen gehobenen Service genießen möchte, sich aber kein im Schnappschrank beruhendes Personal leisten kann, für den habe ich hier eine Alternative.
Dabei handelt es sich um eine robotische Ladestation, in der ein Playstation Dual-Sense-Controller sicher und automatisch verstaut und geladen werden kann.
Das Gerät ist so konzipiert, dass es sich unauffällig in das Wohnzimmermobilier integrieren lässt.
So ist der Controller immer griffbereit in der Nähe, liegt aber nicht...
Vor allem den Sound, den das Ding macht.
Warum macht das überhaupt so ein lautes Geräusch beim Ein- und Rausfahren?
Staubfächer in der Gegend rum.
Die Bedienung ist super einfach.
Entweder wird der einzelne Taster auf der Vorderseite verwendet, um die Ladeschale aus- und einzufahren.
Oder man sagt PlayStation an.
Rate ich jetzt einfach mal.
Wenn man sagt PlayStation an, dann geht die PlayStation an und der Controller fährt aus.
Alternativ ist aber auch die Steuerung per App oder Sprachbefehl durch die Einbindung in ein Home Automation System wie zum Beispiel Apple HomeKit möglich.
Über eine LED-Leiste auf der Vorderseite wird der Zustand des Gerätes dargestellt.
So kann man schnell erkennen, ob der Controller bereits voll geladen ist.
Geladen wird übrigens nicht über den USB-Port auf der Rückseite des Controllers, sondern über die Ladekontakte auf der Vorderseite.
Dadurch wird ein typisches Problem, das Verschleißen der USB-Ports, vermieden.
Hier noch ein nettes Zusatzfeature. Über das Gerät kann der Controller und damit die Playstation
automatisch eingeschaltet werden. Also einfach den Controller entnehmen und loszocken. Die
Playstation ist schon an.
Oh, das war ja Szene. Ja, ja.
Für die Nerds unter uns jetzt noch ein kurzer Blick unter die Haube.
Das Herzstück des Geräts ist ein Linearentrieb mit Schrittmotor und Gewindeschwindel.
Hat er komplett selbst gebaut?
Ich hab gedacht, er hat das nur in sein Home Assistant integriert.
Und das Gerät gibt's fertig.
Ja, und es sieht auch voll stabil aus, ne?
Das ist aber jetzt schon super advanced.
Ein CAD-Ding noch gebaut.
Das musste er erst mal können.
Im eingefahrenen Parkzustand werden die Kontakte sicher an den Ladeport des Controllers angedrückt.
Beim Herausfahren hingegen werden sie automatisch vom Controller wegbewegt, damit man ihn problemlos entnehmen kann.
Das Öffnen und Schließen der Tür erfolgt über einen speziellen Mechanismus am Boden des Gehäuses, der mit der Bewegung des Schlittens gekoppelt ist.
Ein völlig banales Detail ohne jegliche Probleme während der Entwicklung.
Auch das automatische Einschalten des Controllers und damit der Playstation ist mechanisch gelöst.
Der Schlitten fällt dafür zunächst ein kleines Stück weiter nach hinten, wo ein gefederte Nupsi an der Decke des Gehäuses direkt auf die PS-Taste des Controllers drückt.
Voila!
Gesteuert wird das Ganze von einem ESP32, der gleichzeitig auch die WLAN-Verbindung bereitstellt.
Sag mal, sag mal, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Gesteuert wird das Ganze von einem ESP32.
Hat er sich da noch ein eigenes PCB für noch designt und anfertigen lassen bei den China-Chinesen?
Wobei Mantis Mainboard?
Moment.
Das was, was der komplett gebaut hat? Das sieht voll professionell aus, Alter.
... der gleichzeitig auch die WLAN-Verbindung bereitstellt.
Auf der Hauptplatine sitzen neben der Stromversorgung und ein paar Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, das Haus nicht abzufackeln,
auch die Elektronik für die Ansteuerung des Schrittmotors und für die Soundeffekte.
Mehrere Magnetsensoren auf der Platine erfassen außerdem die Position von Schlitten und Tür.
Über flexibel Flachbandkabel ist die Hauptplatine mit der Elektronik in der Ladeschale verbunden.
Vier federnde Kontaktstifte stellen dort den Kontakt zum Ladeport des Kontrollers her.
zusätzlich sitzen auf der platine zwei leds für die beleuchtung sowie sensorik
und den ladestrom zum das ist ja mal krass ingeniert das ding und fehlerfälle
wie zum beispiel einen kurzschluss zu erkennen
außerdem sitzt hier noch ein winziger laser abstand sensor erkennt ob ein
controller ladeschale liegt und ob er korrekt positioniert ist muss darüber
lässt sich zum beispiel auch wie hier das automatische einfahren der ladeschale
triggern und wie weich das auch läuft ja homekit wird das gerät als accessory
erkannt und lässt sich einfach über die Home-App
hinzufügen. Offiziell unterstützt
Apple natürlich keinen Controller-Laderoboter,
also musste ich zum Netz-Test zum
Behördtyp greifen, dem Garagentoröffner.
Aber ehrlich gesagt ist es ja irgendwie
auch eine Art Garage, nur halt eben
für Playstation-Controller. Und damit ist der Weg
frei für... Keine Diskriminierung beim
Inhalt von Garagen.
Oder wie ordentlich es da ist.
Aber die meisten Konsolenbesitzer haben
sicherlich mehr als nur einen Controller. Warum machst du das nicht?
Ganz einfach, weil ich es nicht kann.
Also,
Ich habe schon mal einen Custom PCB bestellt bei PCBWay.
Haben wir sogar, glaube ich, im Stream zusammengelötet.
Aber die Schematics und so, die waren nicht von mir.
Antwortung der brennenden Frage.
Funktioniert das auch mit mehreren Controllern?
Ja, und zwar absolut synchron.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Du hast einfach zu 100% und vollkommen den Schuss nicht gehört.
Und ich liebe alles daran.
Daniel hat hier auch eine Seite verlinkt, wo ihr Interesse an dem Projekt bekommen könnt.
Generell verlinke ich euch alles, was ich...
Das ist ja schon... Also das ist wirklich ein krasses Ding.
Zeig mal her.
Ach, welche Nahrungsergänzungs... Das ist doch so ein Blödsinn.
Wo ist das denn?
Sehen wir es hier irgendwo? TV?
Wo ist es denn hier?
Chat, ich sehe es nicht. Wo ist es denn?
Hier, Luxusladestation.
MantisDoc.com
Demo ansehen.
Ah ja, gut.
Ja, Leute, wer da Interesse dran hat, kann
dann mal hier hinschicken. Vielleicht gibt es das irgendwann
demnächst als fertiges Produkt.
Schon nice. Und wisst ihr was?
Auch super pfeifett von ihm,
das hier hinzuschicken und quasi das im großen publikum vorzustellen
das ist das business mindset hier ja dass das ein richtiger macher
da gucken wir weiter cooles ding zu den jeweiligen sachen
finde auch unten in der video beschreibung inklusive der original
einsendung da die ja teilweise dann ein bisschen gekürzt hier im video sind also
Also wenn ihr mehr Details wollt, lohnt sich das bei einigen Einsendungen, die Videobeschreibung zu konsultieren.
Eine smarte Sauna. Das hatten wir, hatten wir das schon mal?
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich glaube eine smarte Sauna hatten wir noch nicht.
Ich brauche vielleicht mal eine Datenbank mit allen Einsendungen.
Naja, wie auch immer. Wir schauen mal die smarte Sauna von Benjamin an.
Ich möchte euch heute die Steuerung meiner Sauna in Home Assistant vorstellen.
Ist das KI? Ist das eine KI-Stimme?
Als wir unsere Sauna in Betrieb genommen haben, kam schnell die Ernüchterung.
Die Temperatursteuerung des mitgelieferten Ofens war eine absolute Qual.
Der Temperaturfühler saß direkt im Ofen. Er dachte also ständig, es sei schon heiß und taktete sich selbst aus.
Das Ergebnis? Bis die Sauna oben auf der Bank wirklich auf Temperatur war, vergingen über drei Stunden.
Keine Chance auf einen spontanen Saunagang.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Wer baut denn... Also ich meine, das gleiche Problem haben wir ja mit Thermostaten an den Heizkörpern,
die ja auch dann am Heizkörper messen, wie warm es am Heizkörper ist.
Dabei will man ja wissen, wie warm es im Raum ist.
Da gibt es aber externe Fühler und es lässt sich über Temperaturdifferenzen auch oft einfach einstellen.
In der Sauna arbeiten wir im Zweifel mit einem größeren Temperaturgefälle.
Gerade oben sollte es doch schneller als drei Stunden warm sein.
Was ist denn das für eine Fehlkonstruktion? Oder ist das irgendwie so ein Saunagrill, der irgendwie für so ein Zelt oder so gemacht ist?
Aufgrund meiner früheren Ausbildung in diesem Bereich darf ich solche Elektroarbeiten glücklicherweise selbst durchführen.
Ich habe mir die internen...
An dieser Stelle nochmal der Hinweis auf das Der-Elektriker-T-Shirt, wenn ihr selber euer Elektrikerfachbetrieb seid.
Ich bin mein Elektriker, nur wenn es nicht 230 Volt ist.
An irgendwelche anderen Kramsteile traue ich mich nicht dran.
Also ich will ja nicht abkratzen.
Abkratzen ist nicht im Scope.
Oder sein wollt. Kann man auch aspirativ kaufen.
Inklusive eventuell notwendigem Equipment im Zeugpunkt-Shop zu haben.
Steuerung angesehen. Regler und Zeitschaltuhr waren simpel in Reihe vor dem Heizelement geschaltet.
Ich konnte sie also problemlos überbrücken und deaktivieren.
Kann auch problemlos rückgängig gemacht werden.
Damit war der Ofen quasi dumm gemacht und bereit für eine externe Intelligenz.
die leistung wird jetzt über ein schiff assistant geschaltet dass ich mit einem
shelly ansteuere da bietet es sich an die temperatur jetzt mit gleich zwei
separaten fühlern über einen shelly zu erfassen
einer sitzt ganz oben unter der decke der andere unten auf höhe der fußbank
so habe ich das temperaturgefälle in der kabine präzise auch noch ki bild der
Er will es aber echt wissen, oder?
Das ist grafisch, ey.
Man muss auch sagen, ich finde diese Grafiken, diese KI-Grafiken, die was verdeutlichen sollen, machen immer alles andere als es verdeutlichen.
... steuern. Durch die extreme Trägheit der Saunasteine führte das aber zu endlos vielen Bedingungen und Überschwinn.
Nach einigem Feintuning der Parameter habe ich ein perfektes Setup gefunden.
Die Sauna ist mittlerweile in nur 35 Minuten auf Zieltemperatur.
Und die Schwankungen danach? Die liegen gerade mal bei plus minus 1,5 Grad.
Wenn das Ganze schon im Smart Home ist, lässt sich das auch alles komfortabel regeln.
Direkt an der Sauna hängt ein Philips Hue Dimmer Switch.
Darüber kann ich die Sauna nicht nur ein- und ausschalten, sondern auch die Zieltemperatur bequem in 5 Grad Schritten anpassen.
Aber du kannst sie nicht mit reinnehmen, oder?
Ich glaube, dafür ist der Dimmer-Switch nicht vorgesehen.
Starte ich die Sauna, bekomme ich eine Push-Nachricht und der Fernseher vor der Sauna bekommt schon mal Strom zum Hochfahren.
Warum muss der Fernseher hochfahren?
Sobald die Zieltemperatur erreicht ist, gibt es die zweite Push-Nachricht aufs Handy.
Was hat der Fernseher mit der Sauna zu tun?
Handy. Gleichzeitig startet auf dem TV automatisch eine YouTube-Playlist mit...
Ah, dass du aus der Sauna Fernsehen gucken kannst, dass es nicht so langsam ist.
Äh, nee, nicht so langsam. Nicht so langweilig ist.
Verstehe.
...beruhigender Musik und schönen Bildern.
Ein Timer im Hintergrund sorgt außerdem als Sicherheitsfeature dafür,
dass nach einer gewissen Zeit alles von selbst wieder abschaltet.
Als zusätzliche Sicherheit schalte ich den dreipoligen Leitungsschutzschalter aus, wenn die Sauna nicht genutzt werden soll.
Visualisiert ist das alles sehr schlank in meinem Dashboard.
Die Zieltemperatur kann ich direkt im Smart-Thermostat anpassen.
Außerdem arbeite ich viel mit bedingter Sichtbarkeit.
Die Kachel Ofen heizt taucht beispielsweise nur auf, wenn der Shelly-Ofen auch wirklich heizt.
Ja gut, hat er schön gemacht. Das Ganze noch ohne KI-Stimme wäre nice gewesen.
Und ohne KI-Bilder. Ich verliere da immer so direkt das Interesse.
... auch sehr gesund sein.
Ebenfalls sehr gesund sind die Produkte vom heutigen Partner Sunday Natural,
der mein Leben schon eine Weile jeden Tag bewässert hat.
Heute zeige ich euch mal meine automatische Gartenbewässerung.
Ach, mal wieder ein Gärtnerstelz am Start.
Das haben wir auch fast jedes Mal.
Das letzte Mal hatten wir den Typ, der irgendwie seine Wasser...
Was war das? Der hatte da so einen Wassertank?
Ich kriege schon gar nicht mehr zusammen.
in seiner Garage diesen Wassertank stehen hatte.
Mit Home Assistant.
Als Hardware nutze ich hier ein
Sonoff Zigbee Ventil in Kombination
mit einem Gardena 6-Wege-Verteiler.
Dieser Verteiler schaltet mechanisch weiter
bei einem Druckabfall. Dadurch kann ich
mit einem einzigen Ventil 6 verschiedene
Bereiche im Garten bewässern, ohne
dafür 6 Ventile kaufen zu müssen.
Am Anfang hatte ich das Ganze
über einfache An- und Auszeitpläne
mit einem IFA-Aqua gelöst.
Das war lokal und ohne
Eingriffsmöglichkeiten. Und ich habe es letztes Jahr mit vier Eve-Aquas gelöst. Aber sechs Dinge
mit nur einem smarten Ventil steuern zu können, indem man einfach immer kurz einmal den Druck
wegnimmt und der schaltet dann einen weiter, wird ja ein mechanisches Ding sein. Das heißt,
du musst irgendwo tracken, welcher von den sechs Ausgängen gerade Wasser führt. War aber leider
ziemlich unübersichtlich und vor allem super nervig anzupassen, weil das eben nur mit einer direkten
Bluetooth-Verbindung ging und wenn man da mal eben
schnell was anpassen wollte, war das
eher umständlich. Mein Ziel war es also
das Ganze in Home Assistant in einem
Dashboard zu lösen, bei dem
jede Zone als eigene...
Das ist ja mal hier
halber Bauernhof
Bewässerungssteuerung hier.
Ist doch krass, wie viel
Zeit und Mühe
Leute da reinstecken.
Ich sehe das ja hier auch bei meiner
Heimatobesiegungsgeschichte. Ich bastel
da teilweise wochen an sachen rum bis mir gefällt
karte dargestellt wird man kann hier also direkt sehen wann welche zone
startet und wie lange sie läuft und die werte lassen sich dann ganz einfach per
plus und minus anpassen oder auch zurücksetzen
dadurch ist die steuerung jetzt deutlich intuitiver geworden
das stimmt ist natürlich trotzdem schon noch eine aufgabe das hier alles
einzustellen also vor allem wenn du was an jedem tag anpassen willst die
Die Startzeiten werden hier über Input Daytimes gesteuert und die Laufzeiten über eine Input Number.
Daraus berechne ich mir dann über Template Sensoren automatisch die Startzeiten für jede weitere Zone mit jeweils einer Minute Puffer dazwischen,
damit der Druck auch wirklich abfallen kann und das Ventil weiterschaltet.
Eine zentrale Automation sorgt dann dafür, dass die Bewässerung zuverlässig ist.
Also quasi ein sehr langes If, was ich hier sehe.
... und zur richtigen Zeit startet.
Das beste Feature daran ist aber der Self-Repair-Mechanismus.
Vorher ist es oftmals passiert, dass über mehrere Tage hinweg die falsche Zone bewässert wurde, ohne dass ich es gemerkt habe, weil einfach kein Feedback vom Sechs-Wege-Verteiler kommt.
Außerdem konnte ich keine Wetterdaten berücksichtigen, was auch ein großer Nachteil war.
Das habe ich jetzt mit diesem Self-Repair-Mechanismus gelöst.
Dabei wird über die gemessene Durchflussmenge erkannt, welche Zone gerade aktiv ist.
Boah, High IQ Shit.
Das ist schlau.
Das ist wirklich Pfeifert.
Okay.
dann aber von 1 Beginn bis Zone 6. Und ganz am Ende des Durchlaufs wird dann die ursprüngliche
Startzeit wieder zurückgesetzt, sodass dann am nächsten Tag ganz normal weiter verbessert werden
kann. Was für ein Aufriss! Also ich meine, ich finde das sehr interessant, sechs Zonen in einem
Gerät, mechanisch weiterschalten und so. Das scheint das einzige zu sein, also wahrscheinlich
springt der nicht wieder auf die 1, wenn du ihn stromlos machst, sonst könntest du ja einfach noch
irgendwie irgendein Relais davor setzen, um den einmal wieder zu resetten, wenn du merkst, dass
dass die Durchflussmenge nicht zu der Zielgruppe...
Das ist halt auch schon abgefahren.
Ich hatte zum Beispiel letztes Jahr bei uns eine Tomatenbewässerung im Gewächshaus,
dass hin und wieder der Pfropfen von dem Micro-Drip-System hinten abgeschossen ist,
weil da immer noch zu viel Druck für zu wenig Abnehmer drauf war.
Solche Sachen könnte man ja dann auch alle erkennen,
wenn das Sonoff-Teil den Durchfluss zuverlässig misst.
Aber das ist, wie gesagt, Bewässerung steht dieses Jahr auch noch an.
Ich habe allerdings auch nach Rücksprache mit dem Galabauer für die Vorgarten-Einfahrt-Geschichte, werde ich mehr als sechs Zonen haben. Er hat mir schon nahegelegt, dass das, was ich als eine für vorne geplant habe, vielleicht besser drei sind.
Ich habe auch nicht vergessen, dass wir dazu noch einen Livestream machen wollten, um noch darüber zu sprechen. Der kommt noch, aktiviert die Glocke und dann kündige ich den...
Was, du bewässerst Tomaten?
Warum, warum?
Das check ich nicht so genau.
Also eigene Sachen anbauen, schön und gut,
aber das reicht doch von der Menge
hinten und vorne nicht,
dass du wirklich was davon hast.
Was bringt es, wenn du im Jahr
dreimal eigene Tomaten isst
und dann wieder eh nur die vom EDK?
Da kann man doch einfach immer die vom EDK essen, oder?
Livestream rechtzeitig an. Es ist ein bisschen was durcheinander gegangen in letzter Zeit.
Und dann habe ich immer wieder die Situation, dass hier auch Einsendungen dabei sind, die einfach zu lang sind, um sie in dieses Video zu packen.
Zum Beispiel hat Lars mir etwas über sein Dashboard geschickt. Das ist aber irgendwie zwölf Minuten lang, der Rundgang.
Und ich weiß, wir hatten letztes Mal als Nachsitzen-Folge für die Kanalmitglieder schon ein Dashboard.
Aber ich bin auch gerade voll im Dashboard-Fieber.
Also gucken wir uns heute für alle, die diesen Kanal unterstützen als Kanalmitglied in einer Sonderfolge nochmal an, was Lars geschickt hat.
Also wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt, könnt ihr hier Mitglied werden und euch auch die Sachen angucken, die nicht so richtig für ein langes YouTube-Video geeignet sind.
Wieder Lukas, anderer Lukas, Tablet-Wandhalterung ist das Thema.
Ich brauchte eine Wandhalterung für das 2HD10 Plus Tablet und da mir die auf dem Markt existierenden nicht so gefallen,
habe ich mir einfach eine Wandhalterung selber gebastelt.
Das habe ich gemacht, indem ich ein Hardcover genommen habe, das an der Wand gedübelt.
Und hinter dem Hardcover sind zwei Hohlwanddosen mit einem Induktionsladegerät, einem USB-Switch.
Ja Moment, da was dahinter zu kriegen ist ja bei vielen Wänden gar nicht so einfach.
Wir haben ja keine Ami-Häuser.
Das Motor geflasht wurde und ein 5-Volt-Netzteil.
und jetzt kann ich mir über den Fully Kiosk Browser die Prozentanzeige vom Akkustand holen
und den USB-Switch damit schalten.
Somit habe ich die Vorteile, dass ich A, deutlich weniger bezahlt habe,
B, ist das Tablet ganz an der Wand, ohne irgendwo einen Abstand dazwischen
und C, habe ich kein Kabel, welches ich mir an der Seite reinstecke und da die ganze Zeit herausreiße.
Ja und wie hat er die Löcher in die Wand gekriegt?
Also ich meine jetzt nicht die zwei Löcher zum Dübel reinmachen,
sondern den ganzen Hardware-Kram.
Da muss er ja wirklich Wand entfernt haben dahinter.
Das ist schon ganz cool, muss ich sagen.
Auch vor allem für Leute ohne 3D-Drucker,
die sich nicht mal eben eine Wandhalterung drucken.
Und vor allem ist die Halterung halt super dezent.
Und wenn das Fire-Tablet halt induktiv geladen werden kann,
sparst du dir ja irgendwie verstecken zu müssen,
dass da auch noch ein Kabel reingeht. Das war mir nicht vergönnt. Ich habe ja auch gerade mein
Tablet in der Küche an die Wand gehängt. Das Video dazu findest du hier. Einfach eine Hülle an die
Wand zu schrauben und dahinter alles zu verstecken, was versteckt werden muss. Ich meine, das ist jetzt
keine heftige Automation, aber ich glaube, das kann dem einen oder anderen von euch auch inspirieren.
Und dann schaut im Anschluss gerne mal bei meinem Video zu meinem Tablet vorbei. Wo ihr auch gerne
vorbeischauen. Du musst horizontal
und vertikal skalieren, Max.
Dann hast du genug Tomaten. Du meinst
diagonal skalieren sozusagen.
...könnt,
ist am
Arsch der Heide. Und zwar sehen wir uns,
wenn ihr wollt, am 14. November
irgendwo, nirgendwo
auf einem kleinen Bauernhof
zum diesjährigen Gastspiel, wo wir
zusammen einen Tag verbringen können, mit
Technik rumspielen und
auch gegenseitig
Und besser als eine Fernbedeinung.
Ist das auch KI?
KI geht Schwätze wieder.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf KI-Container.
Josis Garten.
Und schauen mal, was hier mit dem Bambus passiert.
Willkommen in meinem Garten.
Ich zeige euch heute, wie ich meine Bewässerung automatisiert habe.
Und zwar haben wir hier fünf verschiedene Bewässerungskreisläufe.
Also heute ist Gerda Stelz angesagt, hä?
Bewässerungskreisläufe für die unterschiedlichen Hecken, den Rasen und die Beete.
Und alles braucht unterschiedlich viel Wasser.
Ja.
Das Herzstück ist dann dieser Gardena-Verteiler.
Schon wieder das Ding. Das haben wir doch gerade. Schon mal.
Der schaltet mechanisch durch.
Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn Wasserdruck anliegt, springt der Einkreislauf weiter.
Moment mal. Habt ihr nicht abgesprochen? Das war doch wieder der Sohn auf Zigbee-Dings.
Wasserkreisläufer als auch den Gardenaverteiler habe ich dankbarerweise vom Hausvorbesitzer übernommen.
Moment, jetzt bin ich einer Sache auf der Spur.
Hat der letzte Typ zufällig sein Haus verkauft in letzter Zeit?
Hast du das Haus von Lukas gekauft? Nee, der hatte das auf einem anderen Pfahl und nicht an so einem blauen Haus.
Das ist das Sonoff-Sigbee-Ventil hier. Das schaltet den Wasserdurchfluss ein oder aus und ist mein einziger digitaler Schalter für das ganze System. Dahinter steht dann noch meine Pumpe.
Ja gut, das ist ja mehr oder weniger das gleiche, was wir eben schon mal hatten, oder?
Kreislauf, einen eigentlich günstig auf AliExpress gefunden.
Was ist das?
Ein Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor, nämlich recht günstig auf AliExpress.
Der sieht auch aus wie so ein Bodenfolger,
der nicht nach drei Wochen
leer ist. Ich hatte immer diese Akara-Dinger.
Die Dinger waren Schrott.
Das sieht aber
eigentlich ganz gut aus hier.
Ich glaube, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Das ist ja mehr oder weniger...
Guck mal, Katzi.
wünschst, ich eine simple Automation.
Und zwar, wann immer dieser rote
Knopf gedrückt wird, blinkt
einmal das Licht rot im Wohnzimmer
und der Speaker
sagt an, dass die Katzen raus
wollen. Ihn dann beizubringen,
auf den Knopf zu drücken,
wird mein nächstes Projekt.
Ach, die Katze soll Bescheid
sagen, wenn sie raus will. Viel Spaß,
die Katze macht dann bei jeder
Runde, die sie
dreht, drückt sie einmal drauf, weil sie
weiß, dann kommt das Herrchen vorbei.
Okay, das ist vielleicht der wichtigere Teil in diesem Projekt.
Ich finde das ganz spannend, also das mit den dynamischen Wassermengen interessiert mich.
Okay, eins gibt's noch.
Das war doch schon wieder eine AI-Animation, oder?
... hat Anzeige dafür, wie viel Leistung mein Balkonkraftwerk gerade noch übrig hat.
Das ist auch wieder KI. Alter, können die nicht alle mal selbst reden?
Also nicht direkt ins Netz einspeist.
Die Idee dahinter war ziemlich simpel.
Ich wollte ein Objekt in der Wohnung haben, das mir nicht nur eine Zahl zeigt, sondern das...
Wobei, ist das KI?
Ist das KI?
Das ist keine KI, ne? Das ist einfach nur schneller gemacht.
Hat sich, weil das so schnell war, am Anfang angehört.
Doch.
AI-Stimme und diese Animationen. Aber ist das jetzt alles? Also gibt es dieses Gerät wirklich?
Moment mal, jetzt müssen wir uns noch gucken.
Pass auf, das Video ist auch KI generiert und das gibt es gar nicht.
Der Text sieht noch echt aus.
Ja.
Take Viagra and Die Hard.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellent.
47 Jahre.
Pock.
Sehr.
Ja, das ist eine Kai-Stimme.
Ich nehme mal die Glasglocke ab und gehe die einzelnen Teile durch.
Das sah schon wieder eher nach echtem Video aus.
Das hier ist ein altes Voltmeter.
Die alten Anschlusskonsolen hier habe ich auf einer gelaserten Stahlplatte befestigt.
Und der Sockel darunter ist CNC-gefräst.
Auf der Unterseite sitzt der ESP32 in einem kleinen 3D-gedruckten Käfig.
Der empfängt die MQTT-Daten aus Home Assistant und übersetzt sie dann in die Bewegung des Zeigers.
Beim Einschalten fährt der Zeiger einmal komplett durch den Bereich, so wie ein Self-Test, und setzt sich dann auf den aktuellen Leistungswert.
Wenn ich jetzt einen Verbraucher einschalte, sieht man direkt, wie die noch verfügbare Leistung absinkt, weil entsprechend mehr selbst verbraucht wird.
Und wenn ich den Verbraucher wieder ausschalte, geht der Wert wieder hoch.
Aber ich fand die Idee charmant, technische Daten nicht nur im Dashboard zu sehen, sondern als physisches Objekt im Raum.
Hier seht ihr noch das Modell Infusion und ein kurzes Video von der CNC-Fräse.
Hä, war das jetzt echt? Warum klang die Stimme da plötzlich anders?
Na gut, das ist natürlich schon das...
Ich habe die Vermutung, dass es das Ding tatsächlich gibt.
Und dass das am Anfang vielleicht nur eine Einigung ist.
Demnächst gibt es hier noch Video Einsendungen wahrscheinlich, wo das Video auch KI ist.
Wir gehen jetzt einfach davon aus, dass du das wirklich gebaut hast.
Es ist ein ganz nettes Artefakt, würde ich sagen, dass man sich so hinstellen kann und
wo man so ein bisschen sieht, was zu Hause passiert.
Es ist natürlich jetzt auch nichts, was irgendwie wirklich...
Da brauchen tut man es nicht, aber das ist wahrscheinlich eher was für die Optik.
2,5 Gigabit über die Telefonleitung.
So was gibt's.
Also ich gucke ja gerne Morpheus-Videos,
aber 40 Minuten ist mir jetzt ein bisschen zu lang.
Chat, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe eine...
Automation kann man nicht sagen.
ich habe so eine Funktion, um zu checken,
ob es bald Essen gibt,
weil ich die
Stromverbrauch
von der Mikrowelle habe.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob wir noch ein Video
gucken können oder ob das Essen schon
in der Wache ist.
Lasst mich mal kurz schauen.
Warum ist das Einloggen im WLAN so lahm?
Okay, nee, noch nix.
Noch nix.
Essen ist noch nicht am entstehen.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich, weil ich habe ja selbst noch...
noch
ein zweidriges
Telefonkabel
liegen vom Keller
in meinen Serverraum.
Und
das brauche ich nicht mehr.
Darüber könnte man
vielleicht tatsächlich noch was machen.
Schaust du noch, lohnt sich das?
Ja, wenn es da was Gutes gibt.
Ich habe jetzt lange nichts mehr Spannendes gesehen, was mich jetzt so großartig interessiert hat.
Nicht so Spannendes.
Was verdient Marketing-Startup?
Oh, nee.
Wenn ihr wollt, dass ich flame,
dann braucht man das.
So ist der Umsatz einer privaten Praxis.
Ja.
Ich weiß, was die Stunde kostet.
Ich weiß auch,
dass du das eigentlich nur noch privat abrechnen kannst,
weil alles andere lohnt sich nicht.
Wir werden es heute ausprobieren.
Wir sind nämlich heute hier am Heise-Seminarhaus im Hannoveraner Osten und nicht in unserem typischen Videostudio.
Heise-Seminarhaus.
Hier kümmern Ernst und ich uns seit einigen Jahren um das Netzwerk.
Ich werde mal ein bisschen vorspülen.
Die richtige Netzwerkverdrahtung gibt es allerdings nicht, weswegen hier aktuell Coax Ethernet-Adapter zum Einsatz kommen.
Jetzt war allerdings letztens Glasfaserausbau und wir haben festgestellt, als wir die Telefonanlage außer Betrieb genommen haben,
dass die Telefonleitungen alle achtabrig sind.
Also wieso nicht mal Netzwerk-Hardware auflegen und ausprobieren, was darüber funktioniert.
Ja Moment, wenn ich 8 Adern hab, dann geht da natürlich mehr als über 2.
Ja das ist ja dann...
Außerdem werden wir an einigen Stellen das WLAN ein bisschen upgraden.
Es hat sich herausgestellt, dass die alten WiFi 5 Access...
8 reicht für Gigabit, auf jeden Fall.
Und ja, die sind nicht super shielded und nicht irgendwie sonst wie...
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn das keine lange Entfernung ist, geht das.
In einigen Stellen das WLAN nicht so richtig was bringen.
Ne, zwei Paare reichen nur, wenn du, also zwei Paare kannst du,
ich glaube sogar offiziell, wenn du direkt Ethernet machen willst,
plus 10 MBit drüber machen, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher.
So dieses ganz alte noch.
Ansonsten kannst du quasi DSL machen.
gibt es ja auch viele adapter die machen quasi dsl über oder vor dsl oder wie auch immer was
gegen den dsl zeug über die telefonleitung zwischen zwei endgeräten deswegen gibt es
da jetzt wifi 7 alles klar los geht's auf den ja gut das ist dann doch nicht so so
So interesting.
Wenn es immer
8 Adern sind.
Oh, Bonkers.
1 Gigabit über 2 Adern.
Ja, ich glaube, die machen
unter der Haube DSL. Das ist ein DSL-Modem.
Ja, ne?
bei mir ist Telefon eigentlich immer nur
zwei Adern gewesen
warum junge Fachkräfte keinen Job
weil es gerade scheiße ist einen Job zu finden
gerade für Einsteiger
ok
Marketingleute, ihr wisst ich flame Marketingleute
gerne, schau mal mal
was die hier treiben
Was ist das? Was machen die?
Bit-Übertragungsschicht.
Osi-Modell ist am Start.
So, gucken wir mal.
Wir haben alles vom ersten Euro an selbst aufgebaut.
Das ist ja zu, wie es sollte.
Das sollte normalerweise nicht so sein.
Wir haben es gestern natürlich noch tausend Mal getestet.
Ich finde es auch cool, so ein bisschen Monopoly zu spielen in Rühleich.
Guten Morgen!
Vielleicht sieht man uns ja noch bei Höhle der Löwen irgendwann.
Hi, ich bin der Max, 22.
Ich bin Maxi, 24 Jahre.
Ich bin übrigens auch der Max, wollte ich nochmal erwähnt haben.
Wir haben ein Start-up gegründet, das Ausbildungsbetriebe TripleMax haben wir jetzt hier gerade am Start.
Das ist Ihr Produkt, okay.
Das ist quasi ein Fernseher, ein Fernsehen-Hochkant.
So, wo kommt denn...
Wir haben uns vorgestellt, dass wir sie da hinstellen, in die Ecke.
Da ist auch gleich ein Stromanschluss.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Standort.
Das ist ja Zubisäule.
Wir stellen einen digitalen Standbildschirm zum Beispiel in die Aula und Ausbildungsunternehmen
können sich dann per Video oder Bild direkt dort präsentieren, direkt die Schüler ansprechen.
Die sind auch hier persönlich da.
Also geht das nur mit in ihrer Cloud oder wie?
Am stressigsten ist der Druck, dass jeden Monat genug Geld aufs Firmenkonto eingehen
muss, weil natürlich die Gelder bezahlt werden müssen.
Ist das Android?
Sieht aus wie Android.
So ein bisschen vom Design her, oder?
Oder was sagt ihr? Sieht so aus, ne?
Was kann schief gehen?
Vieles. Dadurch, dass das WLAN oder allgemeine Internetverbindungen auf die Städte machen, ist es überall anders.
Aber lassen wir uns mal überraschen.
Das sollte normalerweise nicht so sein.
Vielleicht ist es noch nicht richtig mit dem Internet verbunden.
Starten wir mal neu.
Es ist immer erstaunlich, wie viele Probleme sich durch Reboot beheben lassen.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist immer,
mein Kühlschrank hat mal komische Geräusche gemacht.
Ich habe nicht rausgekriegt, was ist das.
Da habe ich den Stecker rausgezogen,
wieder reingesteckt, die Geräusche waren weg.
Servus, Stefan.
Du, jetzt stehen wir gerade an der Säule in Coburg.
Wir sind mit dem WLAN verbunden, das läuft alles.
Wird auch als connected angezeigt.
Ja, das ist eindeutig Android.
Wie lange das Ding in der Schule überlebt,
ist natürlich auch fraglich.
Ich frage mich, ob es eine Brennpunktschule ist oder nicht.
Aber da schmeißt doch
sobald die Leute
mal bald einer seinen Rucksack dagegen.
Nur,
wir kommen nicht auf die einzelnen
Webseiten. Siehst du die Säule
gerade online, Kubo?
Der Hexen.
Mein Gott.
Okay,
das heißt, die haben beide, keine Ahnung,
großartig von Technik.
Wenn tatsächlich für heute extra eine Ersatzsäule eingepackt falls also wirklich
für diesen Worst Worst Worst Case, dass irgendwas nicht funktioniert.
Crazy.
Geisteskrank.
Letztendlich ist es ein Android-TV wahrscheinlich oder sowas. Im Kiosk-Bodus.
So ist das halt manchmal, ne?
Und dann muss man halt flexibel schnell Lösungen finden.
Ich glaube, daran sind wir auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, aber ich glaube, jetzt funktioniert es.
Jetzt müsste auch die Touchfunktion funktionieren.
Schauen wir mal.
Guck es mal aus.
Ja, gut, startet.
Ja, jetzt funktioniert es.
Da kann man sich gleich bewerben.
Ihr dann gut luck have fun, also das ganze Zeug einzutippen auf dem Touchdisplay.
Es ist gut aufgebaut, auf jeden Fall.
Es ist gut übersichtlich, man kriegt einen guten Eindruck auf jeden Fall.
Ja, und da könnt ihr dann so swipen, also von links nach rechts.
Also, nur damit ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, das Geschäftsmodell ist,
in den Schulen stellen die die Fernseher auf.
Und Unternehmen können sich dann quasi bei denen einen Werbeplatz quasi sichern.
Ja doch, ist ja im Prinzip Werbung.
Werbung für Stellen.
Können da quasi ihre Stellenanzeigen direkt in der Schule platzieren.
Und die Unternehmen bezahlen, die Schulen bezahlen dafür nichts.
Klingt jetzt erst einmal nicht so blöd.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Wir brauchen 15 Minuten hin.
Und 12 heute mal dort sein, das schaffen wir wahrscheinlich.
Wo ist der Maxi jetzt?
Und ihr hofft jetzt, dass die kaputte Säule in der anderen Schule geht, oder was?
Wir haben uns in der Schule kennengelernt.
Ich wollte immer ein Unternehmen gründen, wollte es aber nicht alleine machen.
Dann gab es nur den Maxi im Umfeld, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
okay, mit dem hätte ich wirklich Bock, ein Unternehmen zu gründen.
Und ich habe dann eines Tages die Netflix-Dokumentation
Das Dilemma mit den sozialen Medien gesehen,
wo ich mir dachte, das braucht die Welt.
Wir müssen an die Schulen gehen und über den Zusammenhang
zwischen Social-Media-Nutzung und psychischer Gesundheit sprechen.
Aus den hervorragenden Kontakten zu den Schulen
hat sich dann Azubisäule.de entwickelt.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Azubisäule.
Azubisäule.de
Wir akzeptieren alles.
Werben Sie direkt an Schulen, sichern Sie sich die besten...
Ich finde die Idee gar nicht mal so blöd.
Über uns, unsere Mission, Feedback, Entstehung.
Was kostet so ein Ding? Kosten.
70 Euro pro Monat, 20 Schultage.
Ja gut, da ist ja dann natürlich nicht nur einer drauf.
Also die spekulieren ja schon drauf, dass sich da mehrere Leute dann da einbuchen.
Kundenfeedback
von Norma.
Gucken, wie die Webseite aussieht.
Die Webseite sieht auch ganz brauchbar aus.
Mal kurz was checken.
Es scheint eine
WordPress-Seite zu sein.
Ich dachte es mir.
Ich dachte es mir irgendwie schon.
WordPress stellt es.
Aber warum auch nicht, ja?
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Schüler sehen es wie auf einem XXL-Handy
jeden einzelnen Tag,
aber eben nicht auf Social Media,
sondern an dem Ort,
wo sie sich mit ihrer Zukunft beschäftigen müssen.
aber wieso wieso ist das problematisch die persönliche land früher gab es auch schon
so wirklich schon ewig her gab es denn irgendwie in der s-bahn station oder so
so ein ding wurde irgendwelche werbesachen bestellen konnte so
das ist nicht so das problem
die sollten aber vielleicht einbauen nicht nur du kannst dich hier direkt bewerben sondern die
sollten auch direkt anbieten hier einen qr code den kannst du mit einem handy scannen und kommst
auf die Seite, weil viele Leute geben es ja
vielleicht viel lieber auf ihrem Handy ein.
Also QR-Code, also falls das mal irgendwie
jemand sehen sollte, wäre so meine
Idee jetzt noch dazu.
Dem musst du einen QR-Code anzeigen, dass du es mit deinem Handy
einscannen kannst. Und was auch nicht
schlecht wäre,
weiterleiten per Mail.
Wobei das natürlich
dann auch wieder, da kannst du spammen, das ist wahrscheinlich
in Deutschland problematisch, wenn du dann eine E-Mail-Adresse
eingeben kannst, dann die der Linke geschickt wird.
Aber zumindest QR-Code, den man mit dem Handy
scannen kann, das wäre natürlich sehr sinnvoll.
Weil es hat nicht jeder Bock, da seinen kompletten Namen und sowas, die meisten haben auch gar keine Zeit, sich so lange damit auseinanderzusetzen.
QR-Code einblenden, Handyscanner können es die Leute später machen.
Zusätzlich zu der Option, sich direkt zu bewerben.
Was wäre denn interessant? Polizei?
Polizei, Bundeswehr, okay.
Bundeswehr, da haben wir bloß auf.
wie die Schüler sich auch informieren.
Das passt viel besser zu ihnen.
Die Plakate werden selten beachtet, aber wenn sich was bewegt, ist es gleich viel interessanter.
Wir sind beste Freunde, aber natürlich hat sich das Verhältnis ab dem Zeitpunkt,
wo wir dann auch Geschäftspartner wurden, komplett verändert.
Weil du ständig über irgendwelche Themen diskutieren musst, die auch mal konfliktrechtig sind.
wo es automatisch Reibungen gibt und das muss die Freundschaft dann aushalten letztendlich.
Auf der anderen Seite sind wir ein bisschen wie ein Ehepaar. Wir kennen einander extrem gut.
Ich vertraue keiner Person mehr als dem Maxi.
Wir haben alles vom ersten Euro an selbst aufgebaut, ganz am Anfang,
jeder 100 Euro aufs Firmenkonto überwiesen und irgendwann kam dann die Entscheidung,
auch mal mit der Bank zu sprechen. Da haben wir dann eben einen ersten Kredit bekommen
über 50.000 Euro, mit dem wir dann Bildschirme finanzieren konnten.
Wir sind jetzt bei uns hier im kleinen, aber feinen Lager.
Unseren USB-Stick mit den Dateien drauf und dann schließen wir quasi an das Gerät auch gleich eine
Maus und eine Tastatur an. Dann können wir nämlich leichter agieren.
Ja also letztendlich, Fernseher mit Android drauf, da habe ich was schon gedacht.
Wir müssen bei jeder Webseite, die verlinkt wird, schauen, dass ein Schüler nicht auf
irgendwelche anderen Websites gehen kann.
Über Links zum Beispiel, über Instagram, TikTok-Verlinkungen.
Und das ist wirklich nicht einfach.
Ganz am Anfang haben wir geschaut, wenige Säulen zu kaufen und direkt wieder...
Ach, die gehen da einfach direkt auf die Webseite vom Werbetreibenden quasi.
Ich dachte, dass das irgendwie das eigene Kram wurde.
Okay.
Hm.
Naja, würde sich das nicht
erstmal prinzipiell über DNS lösen lassen.
Das Ding hat einen lokalen DNS
und der lässt halt einfach keine anderen
Domains zu, als die, die gebucht sind.
Wobei das ja nicht funktioniert.
Also die ganzen Webseiten brauchen ja JavaScript-Frameworks, die sie von irgendeinem CDN ziehen und sowas.
Aber so in der Richtung, gut, wenn jetzt da einer direkt IP-Adressen drin hat als Link, dann kannst du nichts sagen.
Wobei, ja, das lässt sich mit einer Kombination aus lokalem DNS und ein paar Firewall-Regeln bestimmt lösen.
Oder ein Proxy dazwischen, der guckt, dass es nur die, ja du kannst es über ein Proxy dazwischen irgendwie lösen, der dann guckt, ob das nur auf bestimmte Domains geht, ja das Funds bestimmt ein Proxy dazwischen.
Wieder rauszuschicken und dann am besten auch gleich die Rechnung zum Kunden zu schicken,
dass wir wieder Geld haben für die nächsten Säulen.
Schlimm ist es dann, wenn die Kunden nicht zahlen in der Zahlungsfrist und du weißt,
okay, ich muss aber wieder Säulen bestellen, ich habe gar nicht so viel Geld auf dem Konto,
um die zu bestellen.
Das heißt, da ist man immer unter Druck, da muss man Kunden mal anrufen und sagen,
wie schaut es aus eigentlich mit der Rechnung und so.
Das mache ich ungern.
Läuft.
Super.
Also ihr könnt's einpacken.
Können wir einpacken? Alles klar.
Es bietet natürlich immer mehr Angriffsfläche,
desto mehr man zusammen was macht.
Also wenn man zusammen wohnt, hat man mehr Angriffsfläche
an Streitereien oder
auch wenn man eben auch zusammen arbeitet ab und zu.
Da würde ich durchdrehen.
Den ganzen Tag
Zusammen.
Arbeit ist ja nicht immer nur negativ und schlecht und böse und Hauptsache keine Arbeit,
sondern manchmal macht Arbeit auch Spaß.
Meine Hoffnung ist schon, dass sich diese Strategie, dieser Plan irgendwann für uns beide rechnet
und wir in vielleicht 10, 15 Jahren mehr Zeit miteinander haben als jetzt
und aber auch mehr Zeit, als wenn ich jetzt irgendwo 40 Stunden angestellt werde.
Hallo.
Was ich mir da vorstellen könnte,
langfristig, um damit richtig viel
Kohle zu machen, ich weiß
nicht, wie gut, ich weiß, ich muss
jetzt das doofe Buzzword verwenden,
ja, ich weiß nicht, wie gut
man das skalieren kann. Ich meine,
es gibt ja nur eine beschränkte
Anzahl an Schulen, die dafür relevant
sind, nämlich die Schulen, wo die Leute ihre Abschlüsse drauf
machen.
da gibt es zwar
einige, aber die
also die, die sich da, es ist
jetzt in der Summe jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn
in der Menge, ja, es gibt jetzt irgendwie
nicht drei Millionen Schulen oder so
die dafür
in Frage kommen
und
ob es so viele Betriebe gibt
die dann, das kann man echt
schlecht schlecht abschätzen ja
ja laufen war das beste für die finde ich es an sich finde ich es echt eine
gute idee
auch gar nicht so viel marketing bullshit wie ich mir das vorgestellt
habe das ist eher startup mäßig ja
abendessen haben wir das ganze erfahren und dann war es halt ebenso da musste auch halt
geld kommen ist das eine banane in so einem maße dass man sagt man kann kleidung nahrung
irgendwie das war weißwurst weißwurst oder finanzieren und dann war natürlich auch diese
gewisse druck da ist es vielleicht sonst ohne kind gewesen wäre maxi wurst eigentlich hast
Hast du die schon mal gegessen?
Weißwurst.
Ich finde, dass wir gemeinsam zu Abend essen, pünktlich um 18 Uhr eigentlich, ist eigentlich
richtig selten bei uns.
Sie spielt schon immer noch so eine halbe Stunde mit dir, würde ich sagen, am Abend,
oder?
Aber das war es dann halt.
Halbe Stunde doch so viel.
Also mein Tag ist dann eigentlich immer so beendet.
Ja.
Da musst du dich halt richtig reinknien bei sowas, ne?
Was ist dein Ziel?
Natürlich abzuschließen.
Und heute noch am besten.
Hi, guten Morgen.
Hoher Besuch heute.
Habt ihr was geplant mit der Mädchenrealschule oder Weinberger mittlerweile?
Kommen die da schon ran?
Ja, da haben wir tatsächlich gesprochen mit ihnen.
Wir haben jetzt vorerst kein Interesse an der Zubisäule.
Da können wir natürlich dann immer nicht viel machen.
Das ist ja das Angebot, über welches wir sprechen.
Ja.
Genau, die vier Schulen. Wann wollt ihr starten?
Im Januar.
Ist das so für euch in Ordnung?
Ja.
Super.
Dann würde ich dir gleich die Auftragsbestimmung zukommen lassen.
Gerade regional, das ist halt wirklich verdammt schwer in so Schulen reinzukommen.
Und wir nehmen da echt alles mit, was geht.
Ja, die kriegen halt keine Leute mehr.
Die reißen sich da alle um die Haarzuvis.
Die finden ja alle keine mehr. Und dann sind sie mit der Ausbildung fertig und sind Junior Server Admin und finden nichts.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie dafür was suchen. Ich gehe davon aus, dass auch ganz viele Handwerksbetriebe und sowas was suchen. Die haben wirklich Probleme Azubis zu finden.
Also an der ersten Anzeige des Unternehmens verdienen wir gar nichts. Ab der zweiten verdienen wir ein bisschen was und ab der dritten verdienen wir wirklich Geld.
Und deswegen ist unser Konzept so, dass wir versuchen möglichst viele Ausstattungsbetriebe zu finden, die auch zuvisuelle werben.
Und das natürlich auch langfristig.
Also positiv, es ist natürlich super gelaufen, genauso wie gewünscht.
Ich schicke jetzt dann später im Büro gleich die Autosuchstätigung raus und es geht zum nächsten Kunden, würde ich sagen.
Da läuft der Karriere-Crime hier.
Ein großer Kostenpunkt braucht man einfach, um von A nach B zu kommen, um auch die Säulen auszuriefern.
Bei uns sind die Autos geleast.
Das macht einfach dadurch, dass wir komplett bootstrapped sind, am meisten Sinn, um einfach die Liquidität zu schonen,
weil einfach Liquidität ein Riesenthema bei uns ist und wir immer versuchen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Autos, aber ich glaube, das ist ein Cupra, oder?
Ja, da so viel wie möglich auf dem Konto zu lassen.
Norma ist einer unserer ersten Kunden überhaupt. Die haben schon geworben, wo wir
nur 40 Standorte hatten. Deswegen super wichtiger Termin heute und bin deswegen auch ein
bisschen aufgeregt. Jetzt geht es natürlich darum, um neue Standorte mit
ihm zu besprechen, die neu dazugekommen sind.
Alles klar Max, dann nimm Platz bitte. Dankeschön. Du hast was neues für uns?
Richtig, ich habe ein paar neue Standorte, die glaube ich auch in deinem
Gebiet vor allem für dich interessant sind. Zum Beispiel hier in Rodingen. Konrad Adenauer
wie Eichwieder-Rodingen. Sehr interessant, ja. Das haben sie jetzt nochmal nachgestellt
für das Fernsehteam. Ich kann nicht hundertprozentig messen, aber ich kann nur eins sagen, seit
wir diese Säulen an den Schulen stehen haben, ist aus dieser Region sind deutlich mehr Bewerbungen
eingegangen. Max, ich begleite dich noch mit runter. Ja, danke. Da kriegst du definitiv noch Zeit
mal von mir, eine Rückmeldung. Ich denke auch, dass da mindestens so ein, zwei neue Schulstandorte
dazukommen noch in diesem Jahr. War sehr erfolgreich. Zufrieden? Ja, bin zufrieden. Was zahlt ihr euch denn aus?
Es gab Zeiten, da hat es nicht für die 500 gereicht. Man musste sich 250 auszahlen. Irgendwann haben wir gesagt,
okay, wir machen jetzt konstant 1000 Euro pro Monat, dann waren wir bei 1500 pro Monat, dann eine ganz
lange Zeit bei 2.000 Euro im Monat und dann irgendwann kam der Schritt zu sagen, hey,
wir sind auch Geschäftsführer, wir leisten viel, wir husteln viel, wir dürfen uns jetzt
auch mal 3.000 entnehmen.
Man denkt sich jedes Mal bei der Gehaltserhöhung, also die man sich selbst ergibt, klappt es
die nächsten Monate weiterhin so.
Man hat immer Angst.
Ja, du hast immer im Hintergrund, ja, das kann ich schon nachvollziehen.
Ah ja, vielleicht klappt es nächsten Monat nicht mehr, weil ich mir jetzt mehr Geld entnehme oder so. War bisher zum Glück nie der Fall.
Hallo. Hi, Servus. Hi.
Ja, guck mal, sogar sechs Mitarbeiter schon. Das läuft doch echt nicht schlecht hier.
Ich meine, es ist schon ein bisschen sehr klein dort. Die haben drei Leute, die ein Minibüro hatten.
Immer wenn ein neuer Auftrag hier da ist, egal ob schon Bestandskunde verlängert wird
oder Neukunde bei uns Anzeigen schaltet, dann haben wir hier unsere Klingel.
Oh ne!
Pfli!
Und klingeln einmal kurz zur Feier des Tages und Feier des Anlasses dann.
Zweifel hat man ja heute noch permanent.
Also das ist, da kommt man nie raus aus diesem, ich nenne es immer Abwärtsspirat.
Das ist so Vertriebler-Kram.
Dann springt irgendwo ein Kunde ab und dann denkt man sich,
und wenn im nächsten Jahr alle Kunden dann abspringen,
weil, keine Ahnung, niemand mehr ausbildet oder so,
dann können wir die Tore schließen, was ja nicht der Fall ist.
Rückblickend würde ich mich einfach weniger mental reinstressen,
weil am Schluss kann man rückblickend immer sagen,
okay, das was damals da passiert ist, das war auch wieder ein Learning.
Der ist mir jetzt schon wichtig, weil es einfach ein Neukunde ist mit viel Potenzial
und es natürlich wehtun würde, wenn der Kunde gar nichts bucht bei uns.
Deswegen muss ich da jetzt schon schauen, dass ich performe.
Hallo Frau Schönborn, danke, dass Sie sich heute einmal Zeit genommen haben.
Die Frau Schönborn, die hat keinen Bock auf Kamera.
Weil ich dann nur so 20 Minuten Zeit habe, weil ich dann schon weiterhin den Nix nicht drehen muss.
Ja, das ist kein Problem. Also eins und Videospot sind immer 20 Sekunden. Es werden wirklich extrem viele Schulen denkbar für Sie. Wir haben das kleinste Paket, das sind die sechs Monate, geht hoch bis drei Jahre. Am Anfang muss man natürlich wirklich die Türklingen putzen und das haben wir gemacht.
Vertriebler sind die krasseste Investition.
investition das stimmt ja also dass das in diesem ding in der fall auf jeden
fall es bringt dir ja nichts wenn du geiles produkt hast aber keiner kennt
keiner kauft keiner macht was damit
wenn du leute hast du das an den mann bringen können oder an die frau bringen
können oder mwd bringen können ist das schon gold wert ja wenn du das erste mal
mal Personal einstellst und siehst, was da weggeht, das sprengt alles, was man sich davor
vorgestellt hat. Also ich hätte nie gedacht, dass Personalkosten so heftig sind.
Was wäre jetzt so ein Paket, was Sie jetzt so aus dem Bauch heraus am meisten ansprechen
würden?
Ja, zum Testen ist vielleicht für uns erstmal so kurze Variante sinnvoll. Ich melde mich
dann Ende Januar mal bei Ihnen zurück.
Ich freue mich auf das nächste Gespräch im Januar.
Und? Leider wenig Zeit.
Die hat sich jetzt nicht so motiviert angehört.
Ich habe jetzt mit mehr Zeit gerechnet. Trotzdem denke ich, ist es sehr positiv verlaufen.
Wir haben in jedem Geschäftsjahr mindestens eine Verdoppelung des Umsatzes.
Wir haben uns natürlich auch immer hohe Ziele gesetzt.
Für mich war es schon eine Überraschung.
Mich freut es sehr, dass wir jetzt Ende Jahr 2025 bei der Endjahressumme stehen, wo wir jetzt gerade sind.
Am besten sollte jede Schule in ganz Deutschland eine Azubisäule bekommen.
Da kann man natürlich noch ganz, ganz, ganz stark skalieren.
Also wir können noch viele tausende Schulen.
Das ist das, was ich gedacht habe, aber da haben die natürlich auch schon dran gedacht.
In Deutschland ausstatten.
Das Hintergrundbild, Alter.
Selbst wenn es eine schwierige Entscheidung war, aus dem operativen Geschäft von AzubiSol rauszugehen,
ich habe die Hoffnung, dass ich in dem Bereich mal sehr erfolgreich werden kann.
Für mich lohnt es sich definitiv. Ich finde es cool, dass ich jeden Tag etwas Neues zu tun habe.
Das macht mir total Spaß und ich finde es auch cool, so ein bisschen Monopoly zu spielen im Real Life,
also um da wirklich das Unternehmen wachsen zu lassen.
Wer weiß, vielleicht sieht man uns ja noch bei Höhle der Löwen irgendwann.
Für viel Geld sind wir bereit, Prozente abzugeben.
Wie viel Geld?
Da nennen wir jetzt keine Zahlen, weil das wird uns sicherlich zum Verhängnis werden.
Deswegen nennen wir keine Zahlen.
Also kann man investen in Azubisäule.
Also ganz ehrlich,
ich habe jetzt gedacht, es kommt irgend so ein Marketing-Bullshit-Gelaber.
Das war echt gut.
Den drück ich die Daumen, dass es klappt.
Ist auch eine gute Idee.
Find ich gut.
Azubisäule.
Exzellent.
Ich guck mal kurz, was mein Essen macht.
Muss ich mal kurz checken.
Oh, Leute.
Essen wird vorbereitet.
Gleich gibt's Butter.
Was hat euch überrascht?
Wer verdient mehr?
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, wie gut wir das hinkriegen.
Ein Flugbegleiter oder
ein Fahrer.
Ich würde sagen ein Flugbegleiter, aber auf der anderen Seite...
Ich sag Flugbegleiter.
Fahrlehrer.
Boah, ein Fahrlehrer.
Ich hab meinen Führerschein erst vor einem Jahr gemacht und ich hab nicht so viel, was
ich dafür bezahlen musste.
Ja, stimmt.
Ich hoffe, da kommt bisschen was an die Fahrlehrer dann auch.
Das ist der Fahrlehrer.
Boah.
Was ist das denn? Wie viel?
Das ist unter Mindestlohn.
Boah, echt? So wenig?
Okay.
Fahrlehrer oder Müllwerker.
Oder?
Also ich weiß, dass die ordentlich Zulage kriegen.
Aber ich würde trotzdem Fahrlehrer sagen.
Aber Müll, die kriegen ordentlich
Zulage.
Aber der Fahrlehrer war jetzt auch nicht so richtig
krass. Ne, ich sag Müllabfuhr.
Müllwerker.
Der Fahrlehrer.
Fuck!
Voll verkackt,
Alter. Ich hätte
es spontan auch Fahrlehrer, aber als ich mir das überlegt habe,
na gut.
Fahrlehrer oder Krankenschwester.
Das kommt drauf an.
Also normalerweise würde ich sagen, ganz klar
Fahrlehrer wieder, weil die teilweise im Gesundheitssystem
nicht richtig bezahlt werden. Aber,
aber, aber,
ähm,
ich weiß, dass du im Gesundheitswesen
recht gut Geld
verdienen kannst, wenn du bereit
bist, also an unterschiedlichen
Standorten zu arbeiten und sowas.
Also wenn du sagst, ey, heute,
die Woche in Hamburg, die Woche in München
und so, da gibt's richtig Kohle.
Dann sag ich jetzt mal die Krankenschwester.
Das ist die Krankenschwester.
Tatsächlich, gut so.
Verdiene ich als Ergotherapeutin weniger?
Tja, aber wir haben es verkackt.
Alles falsch beantwortet.
Was verdient ein KI-Startup?
Okay, das ist garantiert Bullshit.
Bingo, hoch 10.
Finanziell hat es sich nicht gelohnt.
Hallo, ich bin die Stimme Ihres Teams.
Oh, nee, nee, das halte ich jetzt nicht aus.
Das müssen wir das nächste Mal gucken.
Das halte ich jetzt nicht aus.
arbeitete deine mutter noch nie ganz diesen rente die es wird dieses jahr 75
warum nicht youtube angemeldet
warum bin ich nicht youtube angemeldet also mit meinem privaten account will
ich mich ja hier nicht anmelden.
Geht ja auch so.
Heute ist Muttertag, ich weiß.
Ja, ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Was war denn das hier?
Wir hatten ja doch hier noch irgendwie sowas.
Die EU-App wurde in
zwei Minuten gehackt.
Oh.
Hat mich letztens im Stream noch jemand erzählt?
Also ich habe mich ja letztens im Stream ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht.
Wenn das Ding kommt, wird das eh nichts taugen.
Und da meinte noch jemand im Stream, Max, die EU hätte da einen ganz guten Track Record, was das angeht.
Anscheinend wohl doch nicht, oder?
U hat eine App gebaut, die Kinder im Internet schützen soll.
Und innerhalb von zwei Minuten...
Okay, okay, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Wenn ich diese Begründung schon höre,
weiß ich, dass das vorgeschobener Grund ist.
Egal, was versucht wird, irgendwie durchzudrücken
oder durch die Brust ins Auge so hintenrum,
es werden immer zwei Sachen gesagt.
Es wird gesagt, wir wollen Kinder schützen und gegen Terrorismus.
Das sind die zwei Sachen.
Das ist immer so die Standardbegründung. Und dann macht man es immer so schön häppchenweise, bis es bei dem kleinsten Kram auch ist.
... hat ein Sicherheitsforscher sie komplett ausgehebelt. Aber das Hicken der App ist nicht mal das eigentliche Problem. Das eigentliche Problem ist, was diese App wirklich ist. Und zwar der Grundstein für eine europäische Identitätsinfrastruktur, die weit über den Kinderschutz hinausgeht.
Siehste? Sind wir schon wieder beim Thema, das ist immer vorgeschoben.
Machst du mal Tabs zu ab und zu? Ich mache aber mehr Tabs auf als zu.
Und genau das schauen wir uns heute an. Willkommen zurück bei Hood Informatik.
Am 15. April 2026.
Die wollen jetzt VPNs verbieten noch oder so. Gut, lack have fun.
Wir machen uns ja immer bei solchen Sachen, ich finde das immer erstaunlich,
Wir machen immer so auf super überlegen.
Also versteht mich nicht falsch, ich finde es hier auch besser als in der Türkei oder in China.
Keine Frage.
Aber wir machen immer so auf überlegen und so nach dem Motto,
in den anderen Ländern ist das aber ganz schlecht, was Pressefreiheit angeht.
Aber in anderen Ländern ist es aber ganz schlecht mit Datenschutz und Überwachung.
Guck mal, was da andere Länder machen.
Und wir machen genau den gleichen Scheiß.
Nur bei uns ist es natürlich was ganz anderes. Bei uns ist es ja nur zum Besten für alle. Ihr könnt mich mal, Alter.
Tritt die EU-Kommission vor die Kameras und verkündet,
Kinder sollen vor erwachsenen Content geschützt werden.
Die App nutzt Zero-Knowledge-Proofs, basierend auf dem Framework der European Digital Identity Wallet
und wird als datenschutzfreundlichste Lösung der Welt vermarktet.
Klingt erstmal gut.
Als datenschutzfreundlichste Lösung der Welt,
wenn man sagt, ja okay, die Daten fließen zu irgendwelchen Unternehmen ab,
meinetwegen vielleicht, ja.
...schützen, Plattformen in die Pflicht nehmen, Privacy by Design.
Wer würde da widersprechen?
Nun ja, da hätten wir 438 Sicherheitsforscher und Kryptografie-Experten aus zwei...
Und was man auch nicht vergessen darf, ähm...
Und sobald die Infrastruktur da ist für solche Sachen, dann wird das auch genutzt. Und wenn man zentrale Services hat, hat man auch ein zentrales Einfallstor zur Not.
Und als nächstes kommt dann so Sachen wie, man möchte Social Media verbieten und sowas, wo man ja beispielsweise in Korea schon gesehen hat, wie doll das, nee, nicht Korea, Australien, wie doll das funktioniert.
Und was mich echt abfuckt ist, es wurde ja schon ein paar Mal solche Sachen, das gleiche wie mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wurde ja immer wieder gesagt, nee, gibt's nicht, gibt's nicht, gibt's nicht. Aber es wird jedes Mal wieder neu unter anderem Namen probiert, das irgendwie durchzudrücken.
32 Ländern, darunter Ronald Rivest.
Der Name sagt euch vielleicht nichts, aber die RSA-Verschlüsselung bestimmt.
Ah, das ist das R im RSA.
Und Bart Prenel, Präsident der International Association for Cryptologic Research.
Aber auch Hannes Federath und Matthias Fischer von der Universität Hamburg
und dutzende weitere deutsche Forscher von der TU Darmstadt, dem KIT
und praktisch jeder relevanten Sicherheitsforschungseinrichtung in Deutschland.
All diese Forscher haben am 2. März 2026 einen offenen Brief veröffentlicht, in dem sie einen sofortigen Stopp aller Altersverifikationsdeployments fordern, bis die Risiken wissenschaftlich verstanden sind.
Das ist nicht irgendeine Aktivistenpetition.
Na die müssen doch alles kontrollieren. Die müssen doch rauskriegen, wer wieder was von wegen Pimmel auf Twitter geschrieben hat.
Das sind die Leute, die die Kryptographie entwickelt haben, auf der große Teile unseres
Internets basieren.
Und die sagen nicht, dass es schlecht umgesetzt, die sagen, das gesamte Konzept ist falsch.
Der offene Brief erklärt auf 7 Seiten warum.
Ich habe ihn komplett gelesen und verlinke ihn euch in der Beschreibung.
Die wichtigsten Argumente gehen wir jetzt durch, zusammen mit dem, was seit der Veröffentlichung
des Briefes passiert ist.
Fangen wir bei der Implementierung an.
Nicht weil sie das Hauptproblem ist, sondern weil sie das konzeptionelle Versagen so greifbar macht.
Am 16. April 2026, einen Tag nach der großen Ankündigung, postet der britische Sicherheitsberater Paul Moore ein Video auf...
Ich fände es sehr angenehm. Ich sag nicht zum Content. Content ist super.
Wenn er ein bisschen entspannter sprechen würde.
Darin zeigt er, wie er die App in unter zwei Minuten vollständig umgeht.
Moore hat die PIN-Werte aus den Konfigurationsdateien gelöscht, die App neu gestartet, eine neue PIN gesetzt und hatte danach vollen Zugriff auf die bestehenden Anmeldeinformationen.
Kurze Einordnung für alle, die nicht aus der Security kommen.
Das ist kein aufwendiger Exploit.
Das ist ein Konfigurationsfehler, den ein motivierter Teenager mit einem File Explorer und einer Suchmaschine easy...
Das ist definitiv kein TikTok-Content, WTF.
...reproduzieren kann.
Aber es geht tiefer.
Der niederländische Sicherheitsexperte Diebrand Mulder hatte eine technische Analyse veröffentlicht, die ein noch fundamentaleres Problem aufzeigt.
Die Passverifikation und der biometrische Gesichtsabgleich, also die beiden kritischen Prüfschritte, finden vollständig auf dem Gerät des Notarier-
Ja, wie war das bei Shootern? Client-Side-Hit-Detection, Leute?
Das ist ungefähr so,
wie wenn ich bei Lieferando was bestelle
und dort auf der Webseite
editiere, dass ich
minus 50 Euro hab.
Und dann kriege ich Geld.
Das wäre das Gleiche, ja?
... akzeptiert, als käme es aus einer vertrauenswürdigen...
Dann überweisen die mir Geld.
... die Europäische Kommission hat die Befunde heruntergespielt und von einer Demo-Version gesprochen.
Sowohl Moore als auch der französische Kryptograph Olivier...
Ach ja, jetzt ist es auf einmal Demo.
Hatten die nicht eben noch gesagt, dass sie ready ist?
... einer der 438 Unterzeichner des offenen Briefes, haben dem öffentlich widersprochen.
Sie haben die zu dem Zeitpunkt ihrer Analyse aktuellste Version des Codes getestet.
Später hieß es von der Kommission, das Problem sei behoben.
Aber der Fix basiert auf Verschlüsselungsbibliotheken, die Google selbst als Deprecated markiert hat.
Also als veraltet und nicht mehr aktiv gewartet.
Die Kommission baut die Grundlage einer europäischen Identitätsinfrastruktur auf Software, für die der Hersteller keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr garantiert.
Jetzt könnte man fairerweise ein Auge zudrücken und sagen, dass das sind Implementierungsfehler, die lassen sich bestimmt beheben.
Stimmt. Aber genau hier wird es interessant.
Denn selbst eine perfekte Implementierung würde das eigentliche Problem nicht lösen.
Und zwar aus Gründen, die der offene Brief präzise benennt.
Erstens, den Vergleich mit der Offline-Welt, den Befürworter ständig bemühen, hinkt fundamental.
Ja, altersbasierte Kontrollen gibt es in der physischen Welt.
An der Casinokasse, beim Alkoholverkauf oder in der Videothek.
Aber diese Kontrollen basieren auf bestehenden Ausweisdokumenten,
erfordern nur einen Menschen, der kurz draufschaut und hinterlassen keine dauerhaften Aufzeichnungen.
Zweitens, und das ist der entscheidende Punkt, die App behandelt das Symptom.
nicht die ursache die frage die man sich stellen muss ist wovor genau schützen wir kinder wenn wir ihnen den zugang zu einer plattform
verweigern vor den inhalten vor den algorithmen oder vor dem geschäftsmodell die antwort ist vor keinem davon
die app reguliert den eingang aber das problem ist das innere des gebäudes ein
19-jähriger der die altersverifikation besteht ist danach exakt denselben toxischen empfehlung
das stimmt wohl ja jetzt hier auf maximales engagement dass das stimmt also dasselbe profiling und das stimmt und ich bin der meinung
wir brauchen da nicht
wirklich mehr von
sei es jetzt bei Social
Media Seiten, sei es bei Porn Seiten
oder sonst was
wir brauchen Leute, die
geübt sind im Umgang
mit Technik
also wo sich die Eltern auch drum kümmern
und nicht sagen, ey Alter, setz dich mal hier
an den Computer und geh mir nicht auf den Sack
also die Leute müssen Ahnung haben, wie man
mit dem Internet umgeht,
beziehungsweise mit Online-Informationen umgeht.
Und
ich hab ja so ein bisschen
eine, also ich hab
eine persönliche, ich hab
eine persönliche Theorie dazu, ja,
keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Bezieht sich jetzt hauptsächlich auf
Technik-Know-How. Ich übertrag
das jetzt mal auf solche Sachen
auch mit, wie geh ich im Internet
richtig mit Informationen um und so.
nennen wir mal ein paar Technik-Know-how.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
die Generation vor mir,
oder zwei vor mir,
also Generation vor meiner Mutter zum Beispiel,
da gab es das nicht,
als sie aufgewachsen sind mit Technik.
Die sind komplett überfordert.
Ich habe meiner Mutter eine Fitnessuhr geholt.
Die hatte auch so eine Garmin-Fitnessuhr.
Sieht jetzt immer beim Wandern an
und beim Einkaufen an
und so kann sie tracken.
Die ist mit dieser Bedienung komplett überfordert. Meine Mutter versteht den inneren Zusammenhang von Funktionen bei Technik nicht. Die kann Anleitungen abarbeiten. Also wenn ich der zum Beispiel sagt, du musst dreimal auf den Startknopf drücken, damit das losgeht, dann kann die das.
Aber sobald die nicht im richtigen Startbildschirm ist und wo aus du nicht dreimal Start drücken kannst, check die nicht, dass die vorher einmal zurückdrücken muss und dann dreimal Start.
Wisst ihr, die hat kein Verständnis für die Zusammenhänge.
Die kann beispielsweise auch auf ihrem Tablet die Sachen nach Anleitung bedienen.
ja sie kann aber die ist schon überfordert beispielsweise in safari
aufzumachen und da drin einen neuen tab und solche sachen so habe ich ja guck
mal das ist doch genau wie in der anderen app das weiß ich nicht also die
haben probleme so die innere zusammen die inneren zusammenhänge zu erkennen so
wo wir intuitiv sagen wo mir wo wir intuitiv sagen ist doch ganz klar was
Zum Beispiel, nächstes Beispiel ist hier, im Wohnzimmer haben wir eine Android-TV, also eine Shield-TV mit Android-TV drauf und ich habe dir schon ein paar Mal gesagt, ey guck mal, wenn irgendwie eine App hängt oder so, schließ die App einfach und mach sie neu auf.
also ja wie wie kann ich deine app schließen habe ich das guck mal das ist im prinzip das gleiche wie
auf deinem tablet ja bei deinem tablet wischte nach oben und dann machst du die app zu bei
android tv drückst du zweimal das häuschen und gehst du auf das x das checkt die nicht das ist
zu viel das kapiert die nicht das ist für uns das banalste und naheliegendste das kapiert die nicht
und ich behaupte mal meine Mutter, wie gesagt
75, dann wird die jetzt
die kapiert das schon mehr
als die meisten anderen in dem Alter
mein Vater ist auch komplett
mein Vater denkt immer noch
das heißt nicht Desktop, sondern Deskop
der ist der festen Meinung, das heißt Deskop
nicht Desktop
und so ein paar andere Dinge, die sind da komplett
aufgeschmissen bei
so, das ist die Generation vor mir
also die kannst du mit Technikverständnis
kannst du auch schon mal vergessen
So, ähm, dann kam eine Generation und vielleicht noch die Generation danach, die sind mit Technik aufgewachsen, aber die Technik war noch nicht so durchdesignt, dass die Idioten sicher war.
Das heißt, du musstest viel selbst basteln und musstest dich auch schon noch mit den
Funktionsweisen auseinandersetzen.
Das heißt, meine Generation und die Generation danach, das sind die Generationen, die richtig
Plan haben und vieles auch einfach intuitiv kapieren, was so Bastel-Kram und Technik-Kram
und Internet-Kram angeht.
Was ich?
Ich bin 1984 geboren.
Meine Generation ist so ein bisschen gespalten.
Es gibt in meiner Generation welche, die haben, so wie die Generation davor, gar nichts mit Technik zu tun und welche wie mich.
Aber die Generation danach, die hat es auch noch richtig mitgekriegt.
So und das was dann kam, da war das Zeug schon so ausgereift und durchdacht und durchdesignt, dass du im Endeffekt auch wiederum keine Ahnung davon haben musstest, was eigentlich dahinter passiert.
so nach dem Motto, ich mach App auf
und
was drumherum passiert ist mir egal
die haben auch keine Ahnung
und so ähnlich sehe ich das auch
und das sollte nicht sein
und deswegen liegt es an meiner Generation
und der Generation danach
den jetzt Jüngeren
beizubringen, wie man
ordentlich mit dem Internet und Technik umgeht
Weil wir wissen es noch
Die wissen es noch nicht
Und da bringen irgendwelche
Zusätzlichen Regularien nix
Oh ich krieg Essen Leute
Da bist du gerade bei der jetzigen
Naja ich sag die jetzige Generation
weil Leute in meinem Alter haben Kinder
und beziehungsweise meine Generation
und eine Generation weiter,
die haben heute halt die Kinder, die es betrifft.
So, wir gucken das jetzt aber noch fertig hier, das Video.
Und dann gehe ich was essen.
Äh, what the fuck?
Geschäftsmodell.
Bart Prenel formuliert es noch direkter.
Statt Regulierung auf die Unternehmen durchzusetzen, erlegen wir unserer eigenen Bevölkerung Regeln auf.
Die Verantwortung wird von den Plattformen auf die Bürger verlagert.
Und die Werkzeuge, um das anders zu machen, existieren bereits.
Der Digital Service Act ist...
Aber es macht doch keinen Sinn, zu sagen, du darfst nicht mehr auf TikTok.
Das ist essentieller... Social Media und sowas, das ist essentieller Bestandteil, das...
das, wie soll man sagen, so,
des Lebens der Leute heutzutage.
Da kannst du doch nicht sagen,
ey, du darfst bis 18 nicht benutzen
und ab 18 prasselt dann
alles auf dich ein. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das musst du ganz
normal lernen,
damit umzugehen.
Februar 2024, vollständig
anwendbar. Er verpflichtet sehr große Online-Plattformen,
die Risiken für Minderjährige zu
bewerten und zu minimieren. Er verbietet
gezieltes Targeting von Minderjährigen und er verlangt altersgerechte Gestaltung. Die Instrumente sind also da, die Kommission setzt sie nur nicht konsequent genug durch.
Stattdessen baut sie eine App und das ganze bringt mich zur folgenden Frage. Eine App bauen ist ja auch easy.
Wobei so easy anscheinend doch nicht, wenn man sieht wie easy das umgangen werden kann.
Dann gehen die halt auf irgendwelche Darknet-Shock-Sites, welche null reguliert sind.
Naja, als nächstes wird Tor-Browser in irgendeiner Art und Weise versucht zu blocken.
...Sätze ausreichen. Warum dieser Aufwand? Dazu kommen wir gleich. Aber zuerst, was sagt die Empirie? Australien zum Beispiel...
Wobei das schwierig wird.
...hat Ende 2025 als erstes westliches Land ein Gesetz verabschiedet, das Kindern unter 16 den Zugang zu Social Media verbietet. Studien zeigen, 61%...
Äh, das sind Australien, ja?
Der australischen Kinder zwischen 12 und 15 haben trotz des Bands noch Zugang zu den gesperrten Plattformen. 70% geben an.
Und das nächste, was dann kommt, die Leute, es gab ja auch diese Untersuchung, dass als das in Kraft getreten ist in Australien, da sind die Suchanfragen und Installationen, oder zumindest Installationen weiß man nicht, aber Suchanfragen weiß man, zum Thema VPN in die Höhe geschossen.
Das ist übrigens das nächste, was dann kommt, dass man VPN verbieten will und so einen Scheiß.
Die Sperre leicht umgehen zu können. Über Accounts älterer Freunde oder Geschwister, Manipulation von Altersschätzungssystemen oder VPNs.
US-amerikanische Forschungsdaten bestätigen das Muster. In Bundesstaaten mit Altersverifikationsgesetzen sinken die Suchanfragen nach gesperrten Plattformen.
Aber die Suche nach Offshore-Alternativen und kostenlosen VPN-Diensten explodiert.
Die Nutzer verschwinden nicht, sie migrieren auf Plattformen, die weniger reguliert, weniger moderiert und oft deutlich gefährlicher sind, als die Mainstream-Dienste, von denen sie vertrieben werden.
Und als nächstes kommen dann so feuchte Träume, wie sie da haben, von wegen Klarnamenpflicht, dass sofort, ohne dass sie sogar noch zur Polizei gehen müssen, die die Leute anzeigen können, der irgendwas von irgendeinem Pimmel wieder auf Twitter geschrieben hat.
Das ist halt echt problematisch.
wurden. Der offene Brief der Forscher benennt diesen Effekt explizit de-platforming. De-platforming
Ganz ehrlich, dann ist mit Meinungsfreiheit eh vorbei. Mit Klarnamenpflicht ist vorbei.
Poste mal irgendwas Kritisches mit Klarnamenpflicht.
Hält Nutzer nicht davon ab, eine Aktivität vorzuhalten. Oder sag deine Meinung, wenn
sie vielleicht nicht ganz konform ist mit Klarnamenpflicht. Good luck, have fun.
vorzusetzen, sie suchen sich einfach
eine andere Plattform. Und da die
regulierten Mainstream- Und ich rede davon nicht unbedingt,
ja, es machen einige Leute
schon, ja, aber viele Leute haben da auch Probleme.
Ich rede davon nicht unbedingt,
dass wenn einer was von wegen
Pimmel schreibt, dann wieder die Polizei vor der Tür steht.
Das kann natürlich auch passieren.
Viel, viel zu oft und viel zu missbräuchlich
mittlerweile verwendet.
Aber ich rede auch davon, dass
sie dann im Zweifelsfall
Zeug an die Wand geschmiert kriegen,
das Auto kaputt gemacht wird
oder irgendwas angesteckt, angezündet wird oder sowas.
Also das ist ja heute schon teilweise problematisch.
Wenn du siehst, Leute, die öffentlich was auf Twitter posten,
was anderen Leuten nicht passt und man rauskriegt, wer das ist,
dass dann zum Beispiel versucht wird,
beim Arbeitgeber anzurufen, dass der den entlässt und sowas.
Ja, also da sind ganz abgedrehte Sachen am Start.
Also meiner Meinung nach ist das, du musst im Internet anonym posten können,
das ist ein ganz essentieller Bestandteil von, du kannst deine Meinung frei äußern.
... wegfallen, landen sie auf Seiten, die sich der Regulierung entziehen.
Das negiert nicht nur die beabsichtigten Vorteile, sondern setzt die Nutzer neuen Gefahren auf.
Und seid mal ganz, und seid mal ganz vorsichtig mit dieser Aussage, die höre ich auch relativ oft,
so nach dem Motto, ist ja auch gut, es trifft ja die Richtigen.
Das ist erstens ganz große Frage des Betrachtungswinkels und morgen kann es schon komplett 180 Grad entgegengesetzt aussehen und das, was ihr postet, ist auf einmal nicht mehr so, wie man es haben will.
Also der Wind kann sich da ganz schnell drehen, deswegen sollte das erst gar nicht vorhanden sein, solche Sachen wie Klarnamenpflicht und so ein Blödsinn.
Malware und fehlende Inhaltsmoderation.
Die Forscher gehen sogar noch einen Schritt weiter und benennen eine Gefahr,
die in der politischen Debatte fast nie vorkommt.
Die Idee, kinderfreundliche Räume zu schaffen,
in denen nur verifizierte Minderjährige miteinander interagieren,
klingt intuitiv richtig, aber sie setzt vor...
Ja, und ich weiß, dass auf Social Media enorm viel Bullshit gepostet wird,
aber ich bin der Meinung, den Großteil des Bullshits, wenn das nicht strafbar ist,
den Großteil des Bullshits, den muss man aushalten.
Ja, man sondern selbst sicherlich auch viel Bullshit ab, andere Leute sondern viel Bullshit ab. Man kann sich nicht vor jeglichem Bullshit schützen wollen, weil dann hast du wieder das Problem, wer entscheidet denn, ab wann ist es Bullshit, wann nicht?
Ja, das ist echt, ich finde, diese Büchse sollte man nicht aufmachen. Und man muss, und das merke ich in der heutigen Zeit, ist echt für viele Leute echt problematisch, man muss, es muss ja nicht mal Bullshit sein, ja, man muss Ansichten, die nicht dem eigenen Weltbild entsprechen,
also andere Ansichten, die nicht dem eigenen Weltbild entsprechen,
das muss man ertragen können, dass sie jemand ausspricht.
Man muss die ja nicht gut finden.
Man kann auch sagen, Alter, was brauchst du hier für einen Scheiß?
Das ist Blödsinn.
Aber man muss es aushalten können, dass jemand was sagt,
was nicht dem eigenen Weltbild entspricht.
Ich finde es auch sinnvoll, dass Beleidigungen strafbar sein können.
Allerdings muss man sagen, generell bin ich der Meinung, Politiker sollten nochmal, zur Zeit ist es ja eher so, dass du mehr Probleme bekommst, wenn du Politiker beleidigst, als wenn du anderen beleidigst.
Ich finde ehrlich gesagt, Politiker müssten sogar noch eine höhere Grenze haben, ab wann es dort zählt.
Weil die eben einfach in der Öffentlichkeit stehen.
Also da kann es nicht einfach sein, einer der ein Schwarzkopfbild macht und da Dummkopf drunter schreibt, dass da die Polizei vor der Tür stehen hat.
Generell ist es auch ein absolutes Unding, dass Hausdurchsuchungen als Bestrafung verwendet werden.
Ja, also wir haben wirklich ganz große Schritte die letzten Jahre über gemacht, in die Richtung, wo wir uns eigentlich immer drüber beschweren, so, oh, es ist in der Türkei so schlecht, oh, es ist in China so schlecht, oh, in vielen Ländern ist es so schlecht, was Menschenrechte, Meinungsfreiheit, Pressefreiheit angeht.
Wir machen da ganz große Schritte auch in die Richtung, nur dass wir immer so tun, oder zumindest, dass es so gesagt wird, bei uns ist das alles ganz toll und bei uns ist das okay und bei uns ist es nur zum Besten von allen, das ist bei uns genauso wenig zum Besten für alle.
Du kannst mich Schwachkopf nennen, ich zeige dich deswegen nicht an, das ist mir scheißegal.
Ich bin der Meinung, sowas muss man aushalten, wenn einer zu einem sagt Schwachkopf.
Ich meine, das heißt nicht, dass ich dich nicht bannen kann im Chat oder so.
Aber das muss ich aushalten.
Es ist durchaus so, dass Erwachsene sich nicht als Minderjährige ausgeben können.
Und genau das ist mit der heutigen Technik nicht zu verhindern.
Und was kaum einer anspricht, es gibt bisher keine wissenschaftliche Evidenz dafür, dass das Aussperren von Minderjährigen von Online-Diensten einen positiven Effekt auf deren psychische Gesundheit hat.
Der Brief formuliert das unmissverständlich.
Eine Technologie mit derart weitreichenden Auswirkungen einzuführen, ohne deren Implikationen für die Sicherheit und Privatsphäre von Individuen...
Ganz ehrlich, ja, ich kann dich anzeigen, man kann jeden wegen irgendeinem Scheiß anzeigen.
Ob du wirklich Ärger bekommst dafür, wenn du mich Dummkopf im Chat nennst, ich weiß nicht.
Ob das verfolgt wird, da passiert nichts.
Video in Gemeinschaften und Gesellschaften zu verstehen, kann nicht als verhältnismäßige Lösung bezeichnet werden.
Die öffentliche Debatte nimmt als gegeben an, was die Forschung nicht bestätigt.
Soweit zur Wirksamkeit.
Aber die Altersverifikation hat auch noch ein strukturelles Problem, das sich nicht wegdesignen lässt. Man kann nicht beweisen, dass jemand über 18 ist.
Äh, Hoflord, das ist tatsächlich ein guter Punkt. Das könnte durchaus sein, dass es noch deutlich interessanter wird, wenn man es eben verbietet. Ja, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
dann sind dann die Leute auf einmal voll beliebt in der Schule, die wissen, wie man ein VPN installiert.
Kann durchaus sein.
Hey, endlich mal ein Grund, wie man als Informatiker-Kellerkind beliebt werden kann in der Schule.
Du weißt, wie VPNs funktionieren.
Perfekt, vielleicht solltest du das doch einführen.
ohne zu wissen, wer diese Person ist, zumindest in dem Moment, in dem die Anmeldeinformationen erstellt werden.
Ja, die App nutzt Zero-Knowledge-Proofs.
Und ja, das bedeutet, die Plattform, bei der man sich anmeldet, erfährt nur, ob man über 18 ist oder nicht.
Also ein einfaches Ja oder Nein.
Nicht den Namen oder das Geburtsdatum.
Das ist der Datenschutz-Layer, den die Kommission bewirbt.
Und gegenüber der Plattform funktioniert das tatsächlich.
Das muss man fair anerkennen.
Das Problem liegt aber woanders.
Lasst uns mal über die Architekturoption sprechen, die diese App haben könnte.
Schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare, wenn ihr weitere Ideen habt.
Option 1. On-Device-Verifikation, so wie jetzt.
Datenschutz ist gewahrt, weil der Aussteller die Identitätsdaten nicht sieht,
aber die Sicherheit ist nicht gegeben, weil der Nutzer die Umgebung kontrolliert und die Ergebnisse manipulieren kann.
Option 2.
Das ist mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein Ticken zu schnell.
Da macht mein Boomer-Gehirn nicht mal mit.
Option 2. Serverseitige Verifikation.
Der Aussteller prüft den Pass und die Biometrie selbst auf seinem eigenen Server.
Jetzt ist die Verifikation nicht mehr manipulierbar, zumindest nicht mehr so einfach.
Ja, aber zentral auf dem Server und da wird garantiert auch Sachen gespeichert.
Aber jetzt existiert beim Aussteller genau die Verknüpfung zwischen realer Identität und ausgestellten Credential.
Option 3, Hardware-Attestierung über eine Secure Enclave oder ein Trusted Execution Environment.
Das Gerät beweist also dem Aussteller kryptografisch, dass die Prüfung in einer vertrauenswürdigen Hardware-Umgebung stattgefunden hat, ohne die Rohdaten zu übermitteln.
Theoretisch das Beste aus zwei Welten.
Aber in der Praxis setzt das Trusted Execution Environment fähige Hardware voraus, die nicht jedes Gerät hat.
Ältere Smartphones, günstige Modelle, Geräte mit alternativen Betriebssystemen wären hier ausgeschlossen.
Und unabhängig davon, alle setzen Smartphone-Besitz und ein gültiges Ausweisdokument voraus.
Wer keines hat, also zum Beispiel Geflüchtete, Asylsuchende, Obdachlose oder Menschen ohne festen Wohnsitz, werden vom digitalen Leben ausgeschlossen.
Und dann die VPN-Frage.
Eine logische Konsequenz, die selten zu Ende gedacht wird.
Wenn Altersverifikation umgangen werden kann, indem man über eine VPN auf Dienste in Ländern ohne Verifikation...
Ja, deswegen haben sie ja schon im Hinterkopf, dass VPN verboten werden muss.
...ist die nächste politische Forderung vorhersehbar.
Und zwar VPN-Regulierung.
Der offene Brief warnt davor explizit, VPNs sind essentielle Sicherheitswerkzeuge für Unternehmen,
für Bildungseinrichtungen, für den Schutz von Missbrauchsopfern und für sicheren Remote-Zugriff.
Die Forscher ziehen hier die Parallele zur Debatte um Ende-zu-Ende-Verschüsselung.
Sichere Kryptografie ist weltweit verfügbar und lässt sich nicht zurück in die Box stecken.
Der Versuch, VPN-Nutzung zu regulieren, wäre genauso wirkungslos wie ineffektiv
und würde gleichzeitig die Sicherheit aller verschlechtern.
Das alles müsste bei euch jetzt eine Frage aufwerfen.
Wenn die App nicht wirkt und massiven Kollateralschaden anrichten könnte,
warum wird sie trotzdem gebaut?
Die Antwort steht auf der offiziellen Webseite der Kommission.
Die Altersverifikations-App basiert auf denselben technischen Spezifikationen wie die European Digital Identity Wallets.
Die sichert Kompatibilität und ermöglicht die Integration der Altersverifikations-Funktionalität in die zukünftigen Wallets.
Das ist kein Nebeneffekt, sondern Architektur.
Die App ist hier nicht das Produkt. Die App ist die Einfahrrampe.
Unter dem Vorwand des Kinderschutzes wird eine Infrastruktur aus...
Ist das, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe?
Es wird immer gesagt, für die Kinder wird das gemacht und gegen Terrorismus wird das gemacht und gegen schwere Straftaten wird das gemacht.
wird wachsende Mengen an Daten sammeln und damit weitere Risiken bezüglich Tracking und Profiling einführen.
Die Studie von Altersverifikation in Isolation kann dazu führen,
dass die langfristigen Konsequenzen für Sicherheit, Privatsphäre und die Sicherheit des Internets unterschätzt werden.
Der offene Brief fügt einen weiteren Punkt hinzu, und zwar Zentralisierung von Macht.
Wer entscheidet, welche altersbasierten Kontrollen existieren und wer sie durchsetzt,
gewinnt enormen Einfluss darauf, welche Inhalte für wen zugänglich sind.
In den falschen Händen etwa einer autoritären Regierung könnte dieser Einfluss genutzt werden, um Informationen zu vermitteln.
Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist immer,
ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, als man bei Corona
so einen Zettel ausfüllen musste,
wenn man in ein Restaurant gegangen ist.
Und da wurde gesagt,
das wird rein zweckgebunden
benutzt,
um Infektionswege
nachvollziehen zu können.
Und was war?
Ein paar Wochen später kam die bayerische Polizei
um die Ecke und hat gesagt,
wenn die Daten da sind,
dann wollen wir die auch benutzen.
Für andere Sachen.
Also da kannst du überhaupt nichts geben, was heute gesagt wird.
klaren Empfehlung. Viele der Schäden, gegen die Alterskontrollen helfen sollen, werden durch
algorithmische Praktiken der sozialen Netzwerke verursacht. Die Regulierung dieser Praktiken wäre
wirksamer als umgehbare Zugangskontrollen und würde gleichzeitig sichere Dienste für Kinder
und Erwachsene schaffen. Daneben empfehlen sie, Ressourcen für die Verbesserung gerätebasierter
Kindersicherung bereitzustellen, damit Eltern den Zugang zu nicht altersgerechten Inhalten
lokal auf dem Gerät kontrollieren können, ohne dass Service-Provider Alterskontrollen
implementieren müssen. Und das ist keine utopische Forderung. Jedes moderne Betriebssystem,
sei es iOS, Android oder Windows, hat gerätebasierte Parental Controls bereits eingebaut. Eltern
können Apps einschränken, Bildschirmzeiten setzen, Inhalte filtern, App-Downloads kontrollieren
und so weiter. Die Technik existiert. Und sie funktioniert. Sie erfordert auch von niemandem
seinen Personalausweis zu scannen und sie hinterlässt keine zentrale Datenbank. Und
auch Estland argumentiert, statt junge Menschen auszusperren, sollte Brüssel bestehende Instrumente
wie die DSGVO und die Plattformregulierungen der DSA stärker nutzen und in digitale Medienkompetenz investieren.
Die Lösung für das Problem, Kinder.
Ja, in digitale Medienkompetenz sollten sie wirklich investieren.
Internet besteht also aus drei Komponenten.
Erstens, konsequente Durchsetzung des DSA mit Strafen, die proportional zum verursachten Schaden sind.
Nicht symbolische Bußgelder, sondern Sanktionen, die Geschäftsmodelle verändern.
2. Designverpflichtungen, die toxische Algorithmen, Autoplay, Infinite Scroll und Push-Notifications für Minderjährige einschränken.
3. Investition in Medienkompetenz, in Schulen, in Familien und in der Gesellschaft.
All das erfordert keine zentrale Identitätsinfrastruktur, keine Ausweisscans, keine Biometrie und keinen Single Point of Failure.
Den offenen Brief der 438 Forscher verlinke ich euch in der Videobeschreibung.
RF-Programmer, da müsst ihr mir erst Gedanken zu machen.
Lest ihn, teilt ihn. Und wenn euch dieses Video geholfen hat, das Thema zu verstehen...
Ja, gutes Video.
Der macht generell gute Videos.
Ich würde mir nur manchmal wünschen, dass es ein bisschen, ich sag nicht langsamer, ein bisschen ruhiger gesprochen ist.
Das fühlt sich echt so an, als wird da gerade verfolgt von irgendjemand.
So, ich muss das Video jetzt schnell aufnehmen.
Ansonsten sind die Videos echt gut.
Ich bin ja selbst teilweise so unterwegs in Videos.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so schnell.
Aber wäre angenehmer zuzuhören.
Sonst schaltet das TikTok-Brain ab.
Ja, das wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich echt sein.
Ja, das ist es.
Okay, Leute.
Schön, dass ihr da wart.
4 Stunden 43.
Heute haben wir richtig lange am Start.
Also, ich gehe jetzt auf was futtern.
Ich habe hier eine Riesenportion Spaghetti mit Hackfleisch und Tomatensauce stehen.
Die wird jetzt gefressen.
Und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream.
Bis dann, Leute. Macht's gut.
See you.